go talk to a lawyer and ask if they need
to file there's been less of that since
the pandemic began there there are
weirdly resilient careers that um
thrive during times like this like repo
men and bankruptcy protection lawyers so
like those people aren't yet seeing like
a boom in business correct i've actually
i talked to a number of bankruptcy
lawyers reporting on this story and a
lot of them told me they're having one
of their quieter years ever
most of them are expecting a big pickup
but for the most part that hasn't
started yet yeah is there a sense on
when that might happen i've heard a lot
of people say a lot of different things
everyone seems to agree that a wave is
coming with the level of unemployment we
saw in march and april not very many
people have a great idea of when it will
likely have to do
when some of these protections stop and
next year when we see the foreclosure
moratorium and and some of these other
things uh there are a couple of things
that have already ended that maybe could
lead to a pickup in the fourth quarter
of this year like the enhanced
unemployment benefits it's been a long
time since there was a stimulus payment
so there likely are going to be more
people who are cash dressed the rest of
the year than there have been so far
maybe we're looking at a ticking time
bomb waiting to go off if you're
considering personal bankruptcy you're
not alone
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident my way way and i'll talk to
the novelist and political scientist
elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
what am i worth well i've got a few
assets
and to be honest more than a few debts
most people say that to calculate your
net worth you should add up those assets
and then subtract those debts
but that really doesn't show the whole
picture
[Music]
the thought of having a net worth above
zero when you're just starting out maybe
you've got student loans and very little
income might sound ridiculous and i
understand because i'm very young and
cool too
[Music]
but even if you don't have a lot of
money to invest you can still invest in
wait is it really that corny yeah
you can still invest in yourself
or to put it better you can invest in
your human capital suzanne wooley of
bloomberg wealth thank you so much for
being on good money can you explain to
me what human capital is human capital
is basically our potential you may feel
first starting out that you don't have a
lot of money maybe you have student debt
um you feel like you're not very rich in
assets
but the fact is that
here's another corny line for you like
you are your biggest asset
you have years of earning potential so
you may not have a lot of money in the
bank but your potential at that point is
huge um so you're actually rich in that
respect even though you may feel sort of
everyday poor
can you explain to me the ways in which
human and financial capital sort of
converge as a lifetime goes by so when
you just start out you have untapped
human capital you have huge earnings
potential for decades and decades but
you don't have a lot of financial
capital going through life you are
building your financial capital you're
also building your human capital but say
at age 55 or so you may be in your peak
earning years so when you look out down
the road you know 20 30 years your
earning potential is not that huge but
by this point you probably have a lot of
financial capital
you've saved in your retirement savings
program maybe you have other outside
savings so at this point your financial
capital might be
a little bit ahead of your human capital
say um and
that's pretty much sort of as it should
be
so how can i invest in my human capital
what actions can i take to make the most
impact
huh
your ability to earn an income is one of
your greatest assets oh hi
who are you
i'm very best dojohan i'm a certified
financial planner
oh well thanks for coming on the show
how is my career one of my biggest
assets that salary that you're bringing
in the employer benefits there is so
much that can add to your net worth over
time which is why you need to really
nurture your career to make sure you're
extracting everything you can out of it
what are some steps i can take to
nurture my career
the basic ones that we all know about
are those promotions the salary
increases and you know asking for
increased responsibility at your job the
big thing that was misconstrued
especially for young people is those
only come around so often you can
actually drive that process as well
oftentimes many people are waiting to be
recognized you're waiting for that
annual review you're waiting for your
boss or somebody to recognize your worth
or the good things that you're doing and
so the biggest thing that we can do as
young people is really take your career
by the reins and think and make a plan
for yourself you want to communicate
with yourself with your boss and your
supervisor to make sure you're clear
number one on what you can do to advance
your position in your role you can set
your own career growth goals and really
you can drive that process of meeting
with your supervisor you might not get
that raise every quarter every six
months but you can still have goals and
check in to make sure that you're clear
of like how are you tracking are you
doing the right things are you on track
for the raise or the promotion that you
are seeking out and and you're getting
that feedback line that feedback loop
does not need to be once a year the
goals don't really work if we're only
checking in on them once a year so
beyond those six-month check-ins and
making sure that i'm on the right track
what else can i do on my own time to
build my human capital so a couple
things one i like to say focus on
education so you can sign up for online
courses covering any topic that you're
interested in so for example if you're
marketing social media marketing how to
use industry specific software ways to
improve your leadership skills so
there's ways that you can actually round
out yourself as a manager and a leader
as well a lot of the times we're
focusing just on like on the technical
skills but there's some software skills
that we need as managers and leaders in
advancing the growth ladder
another one is checking in with your
employer and if they they fund or offer
any uh continuing education
opportunities will they actually pay for
you to go and take any of those classes
or courses to advance yourself
is another one and then um
certifications so depending on your
industry there's i'm sure a variety of
designations or specialties or
certifications that you can get and you
can seek those out on your own so what
if i feel stuck like i'm at a dead end
in my current job you're feeling stuck
in your current position at work one of
the things that i usually say is go back
and and take stock of like what are your
career growth goals are you in an
industry that you enjoy
is it something that you want to
continue to pursue and i think the
biggest thing is don't be afraid to to
jump if you want to go in for one last
push i like to say build a career
um
reverse bucket list what are all of the
things you've accomplished in your job
that you're currently in if you want to
go in for one last push or kind of like
conversation around negotiating or
growth
and if it doesn't work out look for
another job if you're feeling stuck
nobody says you have to stay thanks so
much mary beth for stopping by
so hypothetically i get to the point in
my career where i can start investing
some actual financial capital but how
should i invest that based on the type
of career that i have
william bernstein bill thank you so much
for joining us on good money um could
you just
really quickly introduce yourself and
say what it is that you do i'm a
recovering neurologist i haven't
practiced for 15 years i write about
finance i write about economic
and technological history
i do have an investment advisory firm
that i uh co-founded uh with a lady
named susan sharon official frontier
advisors
uh
and uh that's it in a nutshell i guess
let me ask you based on their careers
what should people be thinking about how
they should invest their money
you have to ask yourself is your job uh
a um
a bond or is it a stock or a lottery
ticket how are you risky is your human
capital and so if your human capital is
not very risky if you're that tenured
professor uh
or a government employee you can afford
to take lots of stock market risk but if
you're working in the financial services
industry uh you're already invested your
job is already invested in the stock
market so maybe you want to take a lot
less risk in your investment portfolio
if you look at your total capital okay
your investment capital plus your your
human capital uh
when you're very young
the
your your your human capital
overwhelms your investment capital so
there's nothing wrong with taking a lot
of risk particularly if you have a
relatively secure job so if you have a
job that's a bond you have a nice secure
teaching position or government position
or a reasonably secure job in your
industry with good employment prospects
no matter where you are
then essentially you have a lot of bond
capital and you're in you're on the
human side so there's no reason why you
can't go whole hot and invest all of
your investment capital when you're
young in stocks and at least the theory
says that's what you should do
the problem with that comes on the
emotional side which is there are very
few people seeing very few sentient
beings in this quadrant of the galaxy
that can tolerate an all stock portfolio
when they're 25 years old let's say that
you have a more freewheeling career
what kind of safe things should you be
putting your money in the classic
riskless asset uh right is of course a
t-bill has no it's perfectly reasonably
safe the government can always print
money uh to to pay you to pay you back
there's no there's no credit risk uh or
almost no credit risk and there's almost
no duration risk uh either
in terms of the last few decades what
has changed about what jobs are bonds
stocks
and and and has that gotten worse or
better i suppose oh much worse uh
you know um we're
we're living we're living in libertarian
heaven uh
right now where no one has you know
fewer and fewer people have have job
security i mean you're a journalist i
don't have to tell you about that so
there are far fewer bond like jobs out
there and a whole lot of jobs that are
more like really bad lottery tickets
yikes so maybe my career is more of a
lottery ticket i hope it hits
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where is
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillions etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
the happy valley in the hong kong jockey
club it's kind of a mecca for horse
racing
people there bet more in terms of their
income than almost anywhere else on the
planet
in 2001 the very large jackpot had built
up roughly 20 million u.s
one million people placed a wager on the
triple trio for that race that's
equivalent to about one in seven of the
population of hong kong at the time
last look at the triple three on the way
they go a reaper the triple trio is
three races
the top three finishes in any order in
all three races the odds are something
like 10 million to one bobo duck in
front mascot fighting back the bobo in
front and there's the training double
for derrick cruz no one came forward to
claim the prize but the winner was
an american professional gambler at that
point he was making so much money from
his gambling activities that it didn't
matter to him
this is the story of a shy computer nerd
who came up with a system to beat horse
racing and made a billion dollars
my name is kit chalel i'm a reporter for
bloomberg and a writer for businessweek
the fundamental unfairness of sports
betting is that
over a period of time you will almost
always lose if you make a lot of bets
gambling sports betting is slanted
against you as a punter as a gambler
bill benter decided to beat that system
he just became captivated this idea
that these games which supposedly
casinos have this long-standing
advantage you could actually beat with
the right methods
i'm adam kucharski i'm a mathematician
and science writer
when he was younger he saw a sign in
atlantic city that said card counters
are banned from our games and for him
that sign
basically said card counting must work
he picked up a book by ed thorpe called
beat the dealer which outlined the
fundamentals of card counting you're
looking for how many high or low cards
have emerged and how many might remain
in the pack if you think there's a high
chance that there are lots of high cards
left in the pack that changes the odds
in your favor
lots of people went and tried card
counting bill was more successful than
most managed to make some money and make
a career out of it
he teamed up with alan woods an
australian professional gambler but as
is always the problem with professional
gamblers casinos don't like people who
win
and they were systematically excluded
from all the major casinos around vegas
so they needed to find a new game
alan woods was interested in horse
racing and between them they talked
about it and became attracted to the
betting scene in asia and in particular
the hong kong jockey club where they
were aware there was this huge horse
racing market they might be able to tap
into
one of the reasons that hong kong has a
big advantage if you're trying to use
mathematical and statistical methods
is it's almost like a laboratory for
studying horse racing in hong kong
you've got two race courses that
dominate you've got a huge amount of
betting activity you've got a pool of
about a thousand horses you've got
hundreds of races a year so if you're
designing something that's going to
generate reasonably consistent data to
study these patterns hong kong is the
place that you want to go so they sent
alan woods to hong kong and he came back
with with all the results of racing in
hong kong going back five ten years i
think and they manually fed that into a
very basic early computer to try and
create a statistical model they fed the
numbers into their computer it took them
a long time it took them about nine
months
so what they would do is use these these
measures of horse's quality and come up
with a prediction of each horses in a
given race their chances of winning and
then they would compare that to what the
odds on the board implied those horse's
chance of winning and what you want is a
horse where the odds imply it has a very
low chance but your model says it has a
pretty decent chance in the course of
researching the story i spoke to
gambling experts they said it was
impossible couldn't be done if you bet
log enough on horses you will lose money
there are lots of factors that go into a
horse winning or not the favorite
doesn't always win
in his first year of betting i think he
lost 150 000
it had all sorts of glitches because
their data wasn't perfect
the fact that the jockey club takes a 15
cut makes it harder to be sustainably
profitable
it means you have to be not just better
than the market but you need to be about
20 percent better than the market to
start making a profit
in a parry mutual system in this case
the hong kong jockey club the odds are
determined by the action so the number
of people betting on each particular
horse and the sums they better determine
the odds and what they did alongside
developing predictions was find ways of
really carefully trickling their money
into the market
if there's a certain amount in the pot
and you go and put a huge amount on a
particular horse you're actually going
to
affect how much money you can make back
because you're going to swing the market
so much towards a particular horse
eventually he came to incorporate the
public odds into his model and that was
a huge breakthrough for him he'd worked
out that the individual decisions of a
million punters in hong kong were
actually a fairly accurate predictor of
of a horse's chance of success
[Applause]
bill bento has been betting for a few
years in hong kong and he's starting to
make serious money
enough that he can hire employees to
place bets over the phone hall for him
he buys a load of computers he hires a
nice office it was really operating like
a business and much like you'd see
the sort of actions in the modern hedge
fund in that they were accumulating
really good data they were analyzing
that data and then they were developing
predictions that they could act on
and
really
the nature of this business for these
syndicates it wasn't that they were
placing it on bet and then celebrating
it was just almost a systematic trading
role where they were expecting to make
money over time
one day he gets contacted by the hong
kong jockey club
and as a professional gambler who's
worked in vegas i think he assumed it
was going to be bad news they might try
and kick him off the betting pool and
instead they said you're one of our best
customers what can we do to make your
life better
because they take a percentage of the
total betting pool
the more computer betters there are and
the more money they're betting the more
profit they make
bill wanted a computer and they gave him
one they gave him something called the
customer input terminal and allowed him
to
stop having to have employees pick up
the phone to spend 10 20 seconds each
time placing a bet he could do it in a
fraction of a second so it allowed him
to make more bets the more bets you make
the more likely it is that your edge
pays off
so when he was suddenly able to make
thousands upon thousands of bets a click
of a button it dramatically increased
his profitability
there grew this kind of sub industry of
specialists i don't think the hong kong
betting public had broad awareness that
there were computer experts using
statistical modelling to bet in the same
pools that they were they simply weren't
well known they never appeared in the
press no one knew the name bill benter
the amount of money that was coming out
of the pool and going to computer teams
just grew and grew and grew and grew
the computer betting teams got too good
they were making too much money they
were making so much money the jockey
club saw what was happening
and they realized that if word got out
that the specialist computer teams
foreign owned and run
were siphoning money out of the betting
pool to the detriment of the average
better it might discourage people from
from going to the racetrack and making
bets
they abruptly cut off bill benter
but then this record jackpot came along
i think they made 50 000 bets they spent
well over a million hong kong dollars
they went into it deciding that even if
they won they weren't going to claim the
money they almost did it to test how
good their model was by this point so
they come up to the home benz and zero
and faith trying to make all mascot
treasure goes to him now does bill
benter fit into the stereotype of
professional gambler no
hardly at all treasure got to the front
and kicked the length clear he had more
than 30 winning combinations but he had
one single winning tickets that
correctly predicted all nine placed
finishes and that was the one that had
the big payout
mascot fighting back at bobo in front of
him there's a purity about what he did
you know he was faced with a technical
numerical challenge his job was to beat
the oils in horse racing and the way he
did it was applying science to this
problem in a way that most gambling
people don't
he's still working away at that problem
you know it's a the algorithm is is
constantly evolving and changing and
improving bill was really one of the
first people to apply
computing power and technology
to a system of odds making but that
practice is now spread all over the
world not just by bettors but by
bookmakers too so in a sense he
transformed the industry
his obsession is the science of gambling
and probability and to this day it's
what he does
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident my way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillions etf masterchef only
on quick take
coming up on quick take
on october 19 2017 at the haleakala
observatory in hawaii human beings
detected the first ever visitor from
interstellar space
it's called omuamua
which roughly translates as messenger
from the past reaching out to us in
hawaiian
we would like to have missions that are
maybe ready to go built and in orbit
waiting for new discovery or something
that could be launched immediately
that's why teams of scientists are
planning missions to wait for objects in
space and spring into action as soon as
something interesting is detected
it may be humanity's only chance to see
an object from another solar system up
close
then
the very bizarre thing is that when
you're in a place where gravity is
stronger
time moves more slowly though humans
don't experience it in their daily lives
gravity and movement can change how time
elapses ultra precise atomic clocks are
now able to measure these tiny changes
known as time dilation it's a
technological advance that could
revolutionize our understanding of time
all this and more on quick take
[Music]
on october 19 2017 at the haleakala
observatory in hawaii
human beings detected the first ever
visitor from interstellar space
an object from outside our own solar
system
a pair of harvard scientists say a
massive fast-moving visitor to our solar
system may have been a probe sent by an
advanced alien civilization it's an
alien spacecraft some sort of alien
technology perhaps exploring the cosmos
it's called omuamua
which roughly translates as messenger
from the past reaching out to us in
hawaiian
everything in our solar system is on a
closed loop you know some orbits are
nearly circular some are elongated this
one was an open-ended orbit which means
it's coming from outside the solar
system
then something even more strange
happened upon leaving the inner solar
system astronomers reported an
unexpected acceleration
only adding to the hypothesis that omumu
was some sort of alien creation
it would be exciting to think this is an
alien spacecraft
you know it's one of the
burning questions on many minds is are
we alone
but you have to be responsible about it
and if there is a perfectly common
explanation you shouldn't go to the
exotic explanation
after observing the object most
astronomers agree that it's probably a
comet like 2i borisov the other
interstellar object seen a year later
but we may never know for sure
things that come in on these type of
very elongated orbits move really fast
when they're close to the sun and then
there's much slower as they move out of
the solar system
so when you looked at the brightness of
this object it was going to only be easy
to observe for about a week
[Music]
in that short window of time with just a
pinpoint of light scientists were able
to make guesses on the object's shape
its size
how fast it was spinning and its color
which is thought to be reddish
but there are a lot of questions about
amumua and space that will remain
unanswered unless we're able to act more
quickly
right now many of the teams are saying
we need the capability to have reactive
missions fast missions that can respond
to a discovery
because right now the the missions the
way nasa works with the small missions
is you put in a proposal and it takes
many years to get that approved and then
it might be a decade between proposal
and actually launching a mission and
obviously for omua that would have been
pointless
so we would like to have missions that
are maybe ready to go built and in orbit
waiting for new discovery or something
that could be launched immediately
that's why teams of scientists are
planning missions to wait for objects in
space and spring into action as soon as
something interesting is detected
it may be humanity's only chance to see
an object from another solar system up
close
the space between solar systems is huge
unless warp drives become a reality
traveling from one to another anytime
soon is probably not possible well i
mean i'm i'm a star trek fan and
according to star trek in 2063 i think
safran cochrane in invents the warp
drive is that from cochrane
of alpha century
the discoverer of the space war
that's right captain
so if that happens definitely
if not i think it's quite difficult to
reach anything within my lifetime
currently the only way that we have to
see some of the material from these
other star systems
is stuff that is in interstellar space
that gets to us
although we've never gone near an
interstellar object we've learned a lot
from approaching objects from within our
solar system
[Music]
in 2014 the european space agency's
rosetta probe rendezvoused with comet
67p
rosetta is the first mission that ever
delivered a lander to the surface of a
comet this has never been done before it
is the first mission that went into
orbit around the comet and it
accompanied it for
two years and a bit from 2014 to 2016.
and from this mission the european space
agency made a lot of interesting
observations
i think this shape was one of the major
surprises that we had at the beginning
no one really expected that another
really big discovery i think was that
the water that came off comet 67p
is not that kind of water that we have
on earth and if it's not the same you
know that they're probably not from the
same
source
um so i think this was quite unexpected
because people really thought this comet
could be a real possibility to bring
water to earth
scientists are still looking at the data
from the rosetta mission and making
exciting new discoveries about 67p
and those discoveries in turn give us
hints about the early days of our solar
system
i think comets are very interesting um
because they can actually tell us where
we come from um
the comets are always thought as kind of
um
leftovers from the solar system
formation
and if we explore comets we can
understand how the solar system formed
how earth formed and basically how
humans in the end came to be because
without earth that we wouldn't be here
while the rosetta mission was a success
comet 67p orbits the sun every seven
years and is affected by the heat
losing gases and changing its
composition with each orbit
scientists at esa recognize the need to
study a comet with a pristine surface
one that's never been near the sun and
that's largely unchanged since the
formation of our solar system
this is known as a new comet
they were talking about this problem of
pristine surface versus changed surface
and they said well
you know what we should do we should try
and get to one of those new comets
and so the comet interceptor idea was
born this is very different from
previous missions that we've done where
we've always gone to comets that go
round and round in the solar system
and the reason why we go to these is
that we know where they are we can
observe them and then get
their position very accurately
but comet interceptor doesn't want to do
that comet interceptor wants to go to a
very new comet
and observe it with three different
little spacecraft
one mother spacecraft as we call it and
two sub-spacecraft
and we want to basically observe
everything we can we'll take pictures of
the comet's nucleus which is the little
thing in the middle will take pictures
of the gases around it the dust that
comes off of it the environment
interstellar objects are not common
interceptors primary target
since we've only ever detected two we
don't know when or if we'll detect
another one this mission is mainly going
after unknown new comets from beyond
neptune in the oort cloud this is the
spherical outer part of the solar system
and is believed to contain trillions of
comets
the majority have never entered the
inner solar system
but every once in a while one of these
icy bodies gets a gravitational bump
from another object flinging into the
inner solar system
and comet interceptor hopes to be ready
for the next one
and there is another very interesting
target family let's say which is
interstellar objects so
if there is an interstellar object
like um or borisov
that's obviously where we will be going
because that's by far the most
interesting thing that we can explore
and comet interceptor is the only
mission that has the capability to
explore such an interstellar object
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
schafer
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
but to catch up to a new comment from
our solar system or an interstellar
object they needed to come up with a way
to deal with the short lead time
something that's never been done before
the problem is that
these dynamically new comets are usually
detected
just a couple months before they get
close to earth
and a couple months as everyone involved
in any space mission knows is not enough
to build a spacecraft and go somewhere
with it
um
so
we're actually more looking at a time
frame of five years for the mission
um where we have
five years of waiting time and we can
choose whenever
we detect a suitable comet and we think
that the chance of detecting a suitable
dynamically new comet that we can reach
is over 90
over these five years
to be able to wait for a comment out in
space for up to five years they'll send
a small probe to the earth's sun
lagrange point a place where the
gravitational pull from both bodies
cancel each other out creating a stable
orbit
and when comet interceptor gets there
it'll just wait for five years
and once we detect the comet we'll be
setting off towards a rendezvous point
and this will be done with chemical
propulsion
data gathered by the interceptor could
be compared to other comet missions so
scientists will be able to predict the
effects of the sun on comets giving them
clues as to what the formation of our
solar system was like and in turn teach
us how earth came to be
it is a very ambitious mission that's i
think why it's so exciting i mean if you
just do things that are easy it's a bit
boring
so this mission is very difficult to
pull off
and
i think that
the
team here at esa
has done a very good job in
kind of
reminding everyone
of the constraints of the mission while
still
getting the best science out of it that
we can expect at the end
although not as far along as is comet
interceptor which is set to launch in
there is a team at mit in its initial
planning stages designing a mission
specifically targeting interstellar
objects
so um we see interstellar objects as the
new frontier in
planetary
sciences and now that we detected them
it really opens up the door of like oh
what new things can we discover and how
does these new discoveries frame our
thinking about the formation of this
star system and other star systems so
it's really science in a nutshell
their proposal is called dynamic orbital
slingshot for rendezvous with
interstellar objects
much like the comet interceptor it will
wait in space and spring into action at
the right time
so the unique part about our concept is
that using the solar cell our payload
remains stationary we can completely
cancel out this force of gravity of
course the materials that are required
for this are exotic
some of the materials are currently
being developed at academic labs so we
think it's within the realm of
possibility for future mission to do
something like this
we can lay in weight
watch
our
local space for any interstellar objects
that might be entering that space and
then spring to action and get a close-up
view of that interstellar object
once an object is detected it would be
allowed to leverage the gravitational
force of the sun in a free-fall
trajectory towards the detected object
matching its path
the team received phase one funding from
nasa which gives them nine months to
come up with a solid plan before
applying for the next phases
we're optimistic about phase two and we
hope to eventually get to a phase three
and if we're able to get there then this
technology becomes closer to becoming
reality
both of these missions are coming at a
good time
telescopes that are coming online in the
next few years will be able to detect
more pristine comets and interstellar
objects than ever
before large synoptic survey telescope
the reuben observatory is being built in
chile and that's going to be much bigger
and scientists are predicting we might
start to see one of these each year once
that is built because it goes much
fainter
why is it important to study objects
like this
well i think
omuamu and other interstellar objects
are
really important because they are the
likely leftovers of building planets in
another solar system
and right now we don't have the
sensitivity or resolution
to really watch that process unfold
and you know for example are all solar
systems chemically the same is it the
same physical processes that build
planets because this is important for
the question of are we alone
and so some of the ways to answer those
questions require detailed
chemical
uh compositional makeup which you can't
do remotely
i think we should be interested in
interstellar object because it really
tells us something about our own history
whether or not our star system is unique
or are is our star system similar to
other star systems
and if we find out maybe some
compositions of the materials around
other star systems it could inform us
what's out there
if we can explore an interstellar object
we can
explore
by proxy another solar system
and that's something really exciting
because we know there's
so many other solar systems with
exoplanets and with maybe even
exoplanets that are kind of like earth
and understanding those systems better i
think is really interesting
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafa
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quicktake
[Music]
in the movie interstellar a landing
craft explores a planet near a black
hole that has a mass 100 million times
that of the sun
the crew spent just a few minutes on the
planet but when they return to the main
ship 23 years have elapsed i've waited
years it's 23 years
four months eight days
the idea of time dilation by going into
deeper gravitational fields is actually
pretty
accurate first theorized by einstein in
his theory of relativity
it's known as time dilation
the very bizarre thing is that when
you're in a place where gravity is
stronger
time moves more slowly
but that's not all
another way time dilation occurs is
through your relative movement through
space
[Music]
if you have two observers
that have clocks that take at exactly
the same rate
and then one of those observers moves
away at very high speed the moving
observer's clock will tick more slowly
their time will literally pass slower
and a lot of people are confused by this
because they think it might be a
mechanical thing it's the clock but no
it is in fact literally time it doesn't
matter what the clock is it can be a
clock it could be your heartbeat it's
time
[Music]
this is even true for someone who is
walking compared with someone sitting at
a table
time moves slower for the person who is
walking
similarly for gravitational time
dilation
someone who is at sea level compared
with someone on a mountain will also
experience time at a slower rate
that's because gravity is stronger when
you're closer to the earth's center of
mass
but in these examples
the amount of time dilation is so
minuscule that it's totally unnoticeable
[Music]
apart from a few examples
humans don't deal with fast enough
speeds or enough gravity to experience a
significant amount of time dilation
but that may not matter
because atomic clocks are reaching a
sensitivity that can measure even the
tiniest amount of time dilation
[Music]
i think that's the place where
relativity will start to become far more
important it's because not because we
can go so fast i mean i wish we could go
fast but i think the real place will be
because we can measure things with an
incredible precision that's amazing
that level of precision will enable us
to use time in ways we never thought
possible
like monitoring tectonic plates
large movements deep below earth's
surface and climate change
atomic clocks could even lead to new
discoveries regarding the nature of time
itself
i think that's one of the really
exciting things about this is that we're
really you know exploring the unknown
um
we're able to sense
effects that no one has been able to see
before
using the precision of the clocks
in 2010
two ultra precise synchronized atomic
clocks were put next to each other now
these clocks were so precise
that they would lose about one second
over the history of the entire earth
then one of them was raised by just 33
centimeters
the result
the clock that was higher up began to
tick faster
but nothing was wrong with the clocks
it was actually time that sped up for
the higher clock relative to the lower
clock due to the tiniest decrease in
gravity as the clock moved higher up
ultra precise clocks measured the
effects of relativity side by side being
changed by that much
absolutely amazing fantastic experiment
atomic clocks were used in the 70s for
that very purpose
testing relativity and other scientific
experiments
they
flu some atomic clocks on airplanes
around the world
compared to the time before and after
doing that
what they found confirmed their
predictions
time slowed down for the moving clocks
the technology ended up being integral
to devices that we depend on every day
gps
global navigation satellite systems
depend on atomic clocks to help
determine where you are
the time it takes for a signal traveling
at the speed of light to reach your
phone will give you the distance
using four or more of them you can
triangulate your position
you know i really think of the atomic
clocks as constantly working in the
background
you don't see it but atomic clocks are
really important for having the whole
thing run
the invention of gps meant that time
dilation suddenly went from being a cool
theory to something that needed to be
dealt with on a daily basis
due to the speed at which the satellites
are orbiting the earth 14 000 kilometers
an hour
and the lower gravity in space
they are actually experiencing time
differently relative to us on earth
if you add everything up the clocks
change by about 40 microseconds 40
millionths of a second of a day which
sounds like nothing
but if you did not take that relativity
into account
every day your position on your receiver
would say that you were six miles off
from where you actually are so it would
very quickly be completely useless
these dramatic effects of relativity are
central to the work done here at the
national institute of standards and
technology or nist in boulder colorado
nist is a leader in the development of
optical atomic clocks
these clocks use lasers to control atoms
and measure their oscillations
[Music]
atomic clocks are currently the most
stable and accurate way of measuring
time intervals and like any other clock
at the heart of an atomic clock is a
very stable
oscillator so you think about
a grandfather clock
it has a pendulum
that serves as the reference oscillator
it oscillates at one cycle per second an
atomic clock is very similar so at the
heart of an atomic clock is an
oscillator which is the atom itself
instead of having a bunch of
gears and levers and springs and things
it's a series of lasers
atoms trapped in an electric field
receive a series of pulses which aid in
controlling and measuring their
oscillations
instead of one tick per second
these clocks oscillate or tick a million
billion times per second allowing for
much more precision
so it's a really small
inaccuracy it's
hard for anyone to conceptualize that
level of performance
these clocks are so reliable that it
would take more than double the age of
the universe so around 30 billion years
to drift by even a second
that precision means relativity can also
be measured with incredible accuracy
so if you move a clock up by one
centimeter of height it will
tick faster
by this
one part in 10 to the 18 and now we can
detect
that kind of change
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policy makers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where is
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
although this kind of precision could be
problematic since atomic clocks keep the
official time that synchronized devices
all over the globe
that seems like a huge problem i mean
how do you decide where to place the
clocks if just the tiniest change in
gravity causes time to slow down or
speed up
that is a good point and it's a problem
that we're sort of anticipating
now the
clocks are getting so good that we don't
know their gravitational potential well
enough to
define time globally at that same level
it does seem like a simpler environment
somewhere out in space farther away from
these local gravitational variations
the problem of determining standard time
aside this one centimeter level
precision has the potential to
revolutionize the way things are
measured
using clocks to calculate height and
gravity
based on the amount of time dilation
this is particularly useful in geodesy
the study of the earth's shape
orientation in space and its gravity
field
we're studying the the motion of the
crust of the earth plate tectonics
the tides
the polar motion of earth there are many
many effects that are observed and that
can be explained for instance in sweden
and canada uh it's rising on the order
of one to two centimeters per year
that's quite a lot
and
on another part of our planet uh there's
actually a downward land movement so
somewhere it's going up and somewhere
it's going down and such effects of
course change everything like the global
sea level
earthquakes
they change even the rotation of the
earth and much more
understanding these movements can help
aid in understanding climate change
natural hazards and construction of
major structures like bridges and roads
if atomic clocks were used in this field
they could in theory give you height
measurements that are sensitive to just
one centimeter
a level of accuracy gps is not capable
of
and because current methods utilize gps
and a gravimeter for determining gravity
at a single point
it doesn't always give you a clear
picture of what's going on
well i'm from germany so let's give you
an example in germany we're proud to
have our highest mountain it's called
such pizza it's almost 3000 meter high
but also this mountain has permafrost
underneath
which is now melting and that actually
gives rise
to a shrinking of the mountain so the
top of the mountain is probably
decreasing but also one or two
centimeters per year
but we have not observed and measured it
yet
because at that place if you would put a
gravimeter
you would not see this signal because on
the mountain you have a varying snow
cover from summer and winter the snow is
changing the groundwater level is
changing
and all these local changes in mass or
disguising the actual effect
so if you would combine now your
gravimeter with a clock on top of such a
mountain then you really could resolve
what the melting of the permafrost is
doing to the to the alps
because the clock would not be sensitive
to a very local mass change like a snow
cover
but it will really measure an average
mass and then
gravitational potential and really show
you the physical height of the mountain
that's why geodesy missions using atomic
clocks are expected to take place in the
next few years
so there's actually a mission in germany
where geodesists want to make for the
first time a clock measurement they want
to blink bring a clock to helgoland this
is the offshore island in the northern
sea
um to compare and get the data because
at the moment this island could not be
leveled it's too far out in the ocean
and satellites would not resolve it it's
too small
and that's why there's right now
geodetic mission to bring a portable
atomic clock to this island
and compare it to a continental clock
helgeland's location and size make
getting precise height readouts
difficult
using gps with gravimeter data requires
multiple readouts every two kilometers
so offshore areas or areas near ashore
technically require you to place a
gravimeter in the ocean which isn't
possible
that's why the island's elevation hasn't
been accurately measured to this day
clocks can bridge the gaps to islands
deserts or mountainous areas which are
hard to access with classical leveling
methods
in turn they can also act as height
reference points for understanding ocean
dynamics and global sea levels
but it's not all about geodesy
we may even learn things about
gravitational effects that we don't
entirely understand
it's hard to predict what the
measurement will tell you
but certainly we're up to many surprises
and this is actually the boundary that
we physicists are trying to push now to
measure more and more precise
time frequency
space time
as we know it's connected in general
relativity
atomic clocks could be the key to
answering some of the biggest mysteries
in physics today that shape the universe
as we know it
dark matter
we know that there's dark matter that's
making up most of the matter in the
universe and there are also you know
models of dark matter
that can be searched for and constrained
using atomic clocks so there are a lot
of scientific applications
as clocks get more precise we could find
that constants used in everyday physics
equations are wrong
and that could completely change how we
understand the universe
atomic clocks that we're building are
the most sensitive way
to look for this present day variation
in the fundamental constants it really
has the potential to revolutionize
physics so do you think
atomic clocks could lead to an
einstein-esque discovery about time
i think it's certainly possible if
we did detect that there was a drift in
the fundamental constants over time that
would be a revolution similar to
you know the discovery of relativity or
the discovery of quantum mechanics
basically we're doing a lot of tests on
the predictions of albert einstein
because can we really assume that
general relativity is the sole
theory explaining everything
or is there may be a deviation from the
predictions that general relativity
makes
the fact is i don't think we do
understand time very well
it's always possible that there is going
to be some bright young person out there
who's really terribly disturbed by the
the conundrum of time and thinking it
over and might come up with something
brilliant but it's going to require a
different way of thinking it's going to
require that flash aha moment that
happens once per century or even once
per millennia
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
[Music]
if you looked on a globe and found the
most remote landlocked point this is
where you'd end up
and it's near this spot where kazakhstan
and china have built a giant
multi-million dollar land port economic
zone and border towns entirely from
scratch
their goals to lure manufacturers to the
area that might want to take advantage
of an overland shipping route to europe
establishing kazakhstan as a logistics
and manufacturing hub
and to strengthen an economic
partnership that's been decades in the
making
but on the china side in the heavily
police xinjiang province known for its
detention of muslim uighurs it isn't
proving to be the ideal business
environment
in the early 90s the people could travel
without visas yeah but very quickly it
finished and now it's difficult for
chinese to get visas to kazakhstan and
it's difficult for kazakhstan to get
visas to china
and now with what's happening in
xinjiang is becoming you know even more
problematic
so can money alone attract businesses to
a route so far from the beaten track of
global trade where geopolitical tensions
run high
corgos is on the chinese kazakh border
near an area that geographers refer to
as the eurasian point of inaccessibility
this is literally the middle of nowhere
by definition it's one of the furthest
places from any major ocean we have
satellite imagery of
that area in 2010
and there's nothing there it's barren
step
you flash forward seven years and you
see this gleaming infrastructure that's
there
if everything goes to plan it will be
the largest dry port in the world
but the port itself is only a small
piece of the puzzle
they have not only new train track but
also facilities that are set up to
transfer cargo from the chinese gauge
track which is more narrow
to the former soviet track which is
broader
they also have a special economic zone
and they've set out an area that they
hope will be developed into
manufacturing facilities and they even
have a town that they're building near
this that is supposed to house
workers
on the china side a town of 100 000
people called korgos has been built in
just six years these new towns train
routes and facilities are what china and
kazakhstan hopes is the start of a major
rush out west
but so far it's not attracting clients
as they'd hoped
although there has been a steady
increase experts say it's due to heavy
subsidies given by the chinese
government to companies that use the new
train routes
and it were those subsidies to be taken
away
i think you would see some of the usage
go down in those routes we also we
haven't talked about the fact that
there's a lot less coming back to from
europe just given the trade imbalance
and that's a structural challenge that
these roots face
because china exports so much more than
it imports trains often return empty
and with border crossings different rail
gauges and political issues not
encountered on maritime routes the
majority of companies using sea or air
are unlikely to switch to less
predictable and significantly more
expensive overland freight shipping
so i think last year corgos had a
hundred and sixty thousand teu which are
you know think of it as
containers that are moving through there
and
to put that into perspective shanghai
which is the world's
busiest port had 43.3 million 270 times
what corgos is doing
although it doesn't appear to be a great
investment by china that's not the whole
picture
korgos has become a highly publicized
flagship project of xi jinping's one
belt one road initiative
promoted as a reopening of the ancient
silk road that transported goods over
land from china to europe starting from
the second century bce
including corgos the initiative promises
to invest over 1 trillion u.s dollars in
nearly 140 countries and organizations
she hopes that by extending credit and
creating a network of economic
dependencies around asia africa latin
america and europe
china will also be able to punch at its
weight in terms of global influence
critics call this method infrastructure
imperialism but it's also been called
infrastructure diplomacy and it's not
the first time it's been used
the roman empire famously built roads
and highways spiraling out from rome
as a conduit for military and
commercial activity
the us marshall plan in the years after
world war ii was an attempt to shore up
europe to create a bulwark against the
threat of soviet imperialism and a big
part of that was u.s financing for the
reconstruction of europe after the
devastation
of world war ii working together with
the aid of the marshall plan
the nations of europe have come a long
way toward recovery and some would argue
it worked
the countries were rebuilt and in return
sided with the us limiting the influence
of the soviet union
where china differs i think is on the
pace and the scale of the activity
the marshall plan was big
but 15 billion dollars in spending even
back in 1948 wasn't that significant
china
on even the most modest estimate is
spending hundreds of billions of dollars
and building not just in europe but
around the world
there's also an economic dimension
china has the world's leading
construction companies it has enormous
capacity to produce steel and cement
china hopes to export its production
capacity creating new markets and new
profits for its businesses
the main question on economists minds
will china's strategy of building first
and finding demand later ever lead to
real growth
china follows a field of dream strategy
on infrastructure building
if we build it they will come
if we go back in time around 10 or 12
years and we think about one of the main
stories in china it was the ghost town
narrative
china had built enormous amounts of real
estate and there was no one living in it
and journalists in china traveled around
and they saw cities in the desert that
were unoccupied tower blocks where no
lights came on at night
what happened though was that over a
period of years with policy support with
incomes rising and with continued
urbanization a lot of those ghost towns
filled up i think about zhongzhou for
example a ghost town 10 years ago now a
thriving urban center beijing's hope for
its belt and road project is that a
similar dynamic will play out
they built early they provided supply
ahead of demand
demand will catch up
and china is set to get something else
out of all this
the development of xinjiang the
country's largest administrative region
that borders kazakhstan
yeah one of the expressed goals for the
belton road
expressed by chinese officials was to
develop western china
and it was also to try to address some
of the inequality that exists between
eastern china and its coastal cities and
western china inland
[Music]
that economic disparity along with the
government's repressive policies against
religious and cultural practices has led
to clashes between the local muslim uiga
majority and the more well-off-hand
chinese who live in the area
by developing the economies of xinjiang
and kazakhstan which share many cultural
similarities chinese policymakers hope
to put an end to unrest in the region
the same communities live on both sides
of the border we have a lot of uighurs
in kazakhstan we have a lot of kazakhs 1
billion kazakhs living in xinjiang so
there are these connections and we
course in xinjiang they have family
links with kazakh citizens
we are muslims we eat
the same food so there are important and
deep linkages
[Music]
xinjiang has a large kazakh community
about 1.6 million people while
kazakhstan has a large uyghur diaspora
with a population of around 261 000
this link could be an incentive for
china to develop the region and calm
ethnic tensions by investing money in
kazakhstan
the main goal is to become one of the 30
most developed countries which implies
modernizing the economy upgrading the
economy diversifying it for sure
i would say quite a few projects
wouldn't be possible without china not
only without chinese money but chinese
kind of believe in the
usefulness of this project
[Music]
a year after the program was announced
president noor sultan nazarbayev
announced their own infrastructure
project called brightpath this project
works in tandem with the belton road
initiative a 9 billion domestic economic
stimulus plan to develop and modernize
roads railways ports i.t infrastructure
education and civil services
and is necessary to lessen the country's
dependence on oil which has seen a sharp
decline since 2014.
it has this natural resource wealth that
is not going to exist forever and i
think in order to make the most of that
they need to
you know make investments with an eye
toward the future and what kind of
economy do they want to have
and i think they want more services a
little more manufacturing all of those
are goals that you see in small ways in
the planning around gorgos
but it hasn't come without resistance
the shift towards china and away from
russia has played into deep anti-chinese
sentiments and fears of china that date
back hundreds of years
kazakh nationalists complain that their
country having gained independence from
moscow now risks becoming a satellite of
beijing
and the these fears they are linked to
the uh territorial disputes
that we had historically
did in some chinese textbooks
the parts of the territory of kazakhstan
are considered part of like historical
china
and in fact there was kind of this dual
jurisdiction of kazakh lands
when the kazak government announced
legislation in 2017 to let foreigners
rent land for long periods protesters
took to the streets to denounce what
many saw as the start of a chinese land
grab
[Music]
to make matters worse worries have grown
in recent years as china has built a
sprawling surveillance state and
internment camp system to target its
turkic muslim population especially
uighurs
but now over the past couple of years
kazakhstan also found themselves
inside these camps so the public opinion
uh got even more concerned with what's
happening in china and what they're
doing to our co-ethnics
it's unclear how many people are in some
sort of detention but the u.s state
department estimates more than one
million people have been detained since
2017.
china who were first denied the
existence of the camps is now doubling
down on the need for them and beginning
to defend them as a vital weapon against
terrorism
this has led the u.s and eu to increase
sanctions on companies who operate in
the region
i do think that western china exposes
what is really a big contradiction in
the belton road you know the belton road
is advertised as something that's
supposed to increase connectivity
between china and the world
[Music]
you go into western china and there are
security checkpoints everywhere and you
know you're you have
minorities who are being detained it's
abhorrent from you know an ethical
standpoint but it's also in very
practical terms a horrible business
environment and so you know china has
talked about increasing connectivity and
yet in this area it's putting up
barriers not only for the flow of goods
and people but also for data the
difficult business environment may be
why corgos hasn't been met with the
enthusiasm governments had hoped for
and with the china-u.s trade war a
controversial security law in hong kong
and the global pandemic china is
signaling a tougher stance elsewhere on
the belton road
the 62 billion chinese pakistan economic
corridor has been scaled back amid
pakistan's increasing debt problems
while a major port deal in myanmar was
slimmed down from roughly 7 billion
to 1.3 billion dollars
i think we're not really going to know
how many white elephants are
roaming along the belton road until a
bit longer but we are now increasingly
in an economic environment where some of
that i expect is going to start bubbling
to the surface
at this point it's unclear how much
china is willing to spend to make the
korgos dream a reality twenty years ago
it was america it was europe it was the
world bank that was funding
infrastructure development spending
around the world
as the west has been rocked by a series
of crises and shifted the focus of their
economic policy back towards problems in
their domestic economy a huge gap has
been opened up a huge infrastructure
funding and expertise gap
china is now moving into that space and
on a project by project basis there are
successes and there are failures the
larger picture though is that as china's
dollars continue to flow as china's
concrete continues to pour china's
influence continues to increase
[Music]
is
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
coming up on quick take
when i started i had no idea was going
to turn into
this this is the tracksuit empire
i don't have any investors all this is
all money in this is me going out and
hustling bringing that money back and
just building building it building it
you got to think about a person that was
homeless at one point
didn't really have any money coming in
the fact that this person was relentless
and just determined to succeed and not
let rock bottom define him as an
individual
i like to do it the old school way with
respect
i can take things and put them together
and take them apart and make them better
and put them back together i respect the
craft so i don't want to minimize and
disrespect the value of each step of the
craft and
do by machine what should be done by
hand
all this and more on quick take
i like to do it the old school way with
respect
i can take things and put them together
and take them apart and make them better
and put them back together i respect the
craft so i don't want to minimize and
disrespect the value of each step of the
craft and
do by machine what should be done by
hand i've made a career out of making
colorful clothes like i'm a grown man
that makes colorful clothes you know
these clothes look so playful and easy
but it's such an intricate process and i
want people to know that this is what it
is this is luxury this is luxury
athleisure
for many generations
african american designers have not been
included within the conversation of high
fashion or considered high fashion in
recent years we see that emergence in
that movement to really kind of put
black designers on that same level that
we have cared for european designers in
that way
with black designers their work is just
as critical just this artistic
as any european or white designer or
non-black designer
i hope that black fashion is inspired by
my movements by the simplicity of what i
do by how clean my stuff is by my
ability to just
put my flag in luxury and say
i'm a black designer and i do luxury too
hello my name is fresh i'm the
creator i'm the ceo creative director
for luxury label rich fresh we
specialize in luxury athleisure and
tailored garments i'm a tailor by trade
i'm a designer by choice
[Music]
we're downtown in the garment district
you know close proximity to where
everything is
there's just an energy that's downtown
there's a creative energy
we knew that we could find the type of
factory we need to build
yeah i think about a person that was
homeless at one point
didn't really have any money coming in
the fact that this person was relentless
and just determined to succeed and not
let rock bottom define him as an
individual i was it for puff daddy
i always say i'm from memphis but i was
born in germany you know my parents were
both military they were in the army
a lot of my early memories are like
germany so like the colors on the
clothes that i used to see people
wearing the font was different the
advertisements were different the
architecture was different everything
was just different in germany than it
was in the us subconsciously it just got
planted there somewhere and i always
kind of revert back to this doesn't feel
like something you see in america it
feels like something you could see
in germany or abroad
once we moved to the states my first
grade was normal but i was bored i was
bored out of my skull
the second grade they put me in this
advanced class with second graders and
third graders who were really performing
on like a fifth and sixth grade level
and there was this girl who i had a
crush on
i knew i'm one of the smartest kids at
the school
and math is my thing
so
the teacher asked if i would tutor her
and then at this moment where i heard
god and i have this thing from time to
time where i hear the voice of reason
that said
you're doing this all wrong she has a
higher purpose she has information that
you need to acquire
so the first day of tutoring as soon as
we sat down i just looked right in the
face and like you need to know math i'm
very very very good at this i got you
i suck at girls
how about we do an exchange i'll teach
you this you teach me that
she was like honestly it's the way you
dress like i think you dress different
girls would like you like you just do
you dress like a kid
and i said what's it called she said i
think it's called fashion that's it hmm
all right well let me uh see what this
fashion thing does
appreciate it first thing i do is i i
meet with the client ellis all right man
all right
i take their measurements
44 and three quarters
27 and a half
track jacket length at a 26 and a half
skin angle at an 11 and a half
and then we discuss colors concepts
maybe black kind of goes with that yeah
and that olive is nice nice pop of color
nowadays too yeah i like that then i put
together a digital mock-up of the
tracksuit with all the various colors
you know that i'm going to use for the
base for the top stripe the bottom
stripe the piping all the different
layers of the tracksuit
then i'm going to send that to michelle
who's my production manager she takes
everything from concept to
production she is responsible for
delegating who gets what like i've got a
number of jacket tailors i've got a
number of pant tailors i've got a number
of hand finishers who are going to
complete the process
the first step of the production cycle
is the pattern you know you can't make
any garments without a pattern so she's
going to take it to our pattern maker
and show him all the various
measurements
he's going to build out the pattern draw
every piece out cut every piece
this old school process
of measurements marks measurements marks
measurements margin drawing lines
drawing lines drawing lines drawing
lines drawing lines drawing lines
cutting
that's your block that's your pattern
so the pattern has to get transferred to
the garment and oftentimes it'll just
get laid on top tailors are so precise
they don't even need to pin it and then
from there you've got to cut
out the fabric
it's a special grade of neoprene more
water repellent it's a little bit more
dense it's a lighter weight you know it
absorbs colors really well so and it has
a nice sheen to it you know it looks
really luxurious
my senior year in high school i was like
i'm gonna take home act just to see if
there's anything else i can learn my
teacher was out we had another teacher
who came in to instruct but they
couldn't sew so i volunteered to be that
person because i could sell better than
anyone else in the class
the kids would call me ralph they would
call me tommy because you know tommy
hilfiger was ralph lauren my brother
chase he used to dress real rough
camouflaged pans oversized and i always
saw how he got dealt with and so one day
i was like hey bro we gotta switch that
up
the first
moment i knew there was like something
different like other than the rest of
the kids that were playing basketball
and tennis
and baseball in the neighborhood was
this dude made a pair of moccasins and
then took them to school and was like
selling them to kids
actually taking orders
so i started like dressing you know
styling them like the whole thing from
head to toe you're gonna get your hair
color i'll get my hair cut we're gonna
do this boom boom boom and so i saw his
image shift he was perceived differently
and regarding
this new era that we're in this new
chapter
where you have these black designers
really inserting themselves into the
luxury space
is quite a fascinating dichotomy i
applaud it they're really kind of
building on the shoulders
of african-american designers who
couldn't and couldn't really stay there
for a long time and have long-standing
power
zelda wen valdez very much known in the
harlem realm of dressmaking and in new
york fashion specifically uptown she was
credited with producing manufacturing
the playboy costume kind of a heralding
figure within fashion and for african
americans because really she was a part
of several organizations that really
mobilized around the education of
african americans within dressmaking and
within the garment industry and giving
them new opportunities that most people
weren't even thinking
you have stephen burrows in the 1900s
who rose to fame with one of the most
notorious fashion events on this side of
the pond the battle of versailles in
1973 that took place at the palace of
versailles where you had the american
designers pitted against the french
designers
stephen burroughs was the only black
designer present a lot of things
happened within his journey
some things that were out of his control
you have to chalk it up to the system of
fashion that didn't allow him the
standing power
that someone like ralph lauren had
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
schafer
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where is
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
everything is custom everything is so
specific
we don't have an assembly line system
when it touches the tailor
it finishes with that tailor
the pattern maker is also cutting the
fabric so he's going to cut the block
that's going to be the trouser he's
going to cut the block and it's going to
be the jacket
there are a number of steps to go into
it
we've got to assemble
the sleeve panel this sleeve is a two
panel sleeve
so this is two different pieces that
have to be sewn together
we need to top stitch just to reinforce
the outer seam on the sleeve we've got a
chest panel which takes into account
each of the track stripes you've got a
pocket that's cut into the lower panel
on each side but again this pocket is
cut through the stripes they've got to
put each of these pieces together very
specifically
we've got our collar assembly
the outer collar we've got our inner
collar assembly
the back has to be
assembled so
you know all the stripes have to be
built into
the back panel as well
there the zipper assembly with the
zipper facing is built in all the final
touches before it makes its way to hand
finishing
i got married young i got divorced john
but i got married when i was 20. so now
i'm 21
i'm starting this new business doing
alterations this is the only thing i
really know how to do and i figured you
know the goal is to get volume i need to
get money i started my first business
maybe six months later doing alterations
for dry cleaners two years i had it and
then i closed it which was a traumatic
experience but then i noticed a cool
thing people started calling me not for
the cleaning but for the tailoring it
was like hey man
sorry to hear about your cleaners but
can you still alter this suit i really
love the way you did this than the other
so i was like um i'm gonna position
myself as a concierge tailor and i'm
gonna just travel to people
before i got divorced i had a child so
right when my daughter was like six
months old me and her mom split it was
the first time i just thought about like
i don't have to do this thing here in
memphis like life is going to change
dramatically i don't have to do this
thing while i've been doing it you know
i just got tired of being broke in
memphis then my brother lost his job in
nashville so i was like bro just you
know come back to memphis and figure out
what it is we would talk about dreams
and big things and like what could one
day be possible we just came to the
realization that it was where we were it
didn't matter how progressive
we moved the environment was not going
to lend itself to the success that we
deserve we had to be somewhere else
let's go to the west coast
we hopped in the car and we just drove
for three days across the country landed
in san diego started up the old business
doing alterations for dry cleaners
and then you know disaster struck my
friends got divorced right when my
daughter was born so up to that point my
dad had never even seen my daughter and
then out of nowhere we get a call that
he's in the hospital and it's bad and he
dies
at 52.
it's out of nowhere i ended up losing
all my accounts with the dry cleaning
and stuff like my brain wasn't there i
didn't care about any of that anymore so
one day we decided to just take a drive
to los angeles and i had a client a rich
client he said he needed a bunch of
suits made
i was like you talking my language jack
i use my money to front the cost to
produce all these suits which is all of
the money
that payment never got made so here i am
now
i ain't got no more money i went from
having eight thousand dollars just the
other day
so now i got like 200 bucks
i look up and now i'm um
i'm homeless
i hear god and i hear this voice that
says
you know you're so mad you're just so
mad i'm just really disappointed in how
you've chosen to make this man your god
and not me
you go to this dude every day asking for
this money you ain't came to me not once
he cannot save you
i can save you
you need to talk to me and i listen to
god i don't want to be this guy rich who
has just chased the money but he lost
his soul in the process i want to be
something different so i want to change
my name to fresh i want to chase that
the money's going to come but let me
just be focused on the business and
being different i left the shelter with
and i told god i'm going to take this
measly ass 300
and i'm gonna turn this into a million
dollars in a year
the real kicker was that track suit when
he dropped a track suit
i was like
that was it that was game over
i noticed this lady with a color block
sweater on and i just thought about how
cool it was that whoever designed that
sweater could design it one way
but change the colors and manipulate it
to create 10 000 different variations of
that one sweater
i thought about what i could create like
that and i came up with this pant that
had prominent stripes you know they were
like trousers but it was some color
blocking and i could design it one way
and make it in a bunch of different
colors and the material would be super
comfortable
then i followed up with a jacket just i
needed a jacket to wear with it and i
like retro style he did some suits for
draymond green and some other ball
players like right out the gate he was
doing some really dope suits rich fresh
made the suit he
can go by rich fresh he's from l.a well
he's not from l.a but he lives and works
out of la
it's really good
a rich fresh garment is not a rich first
garment without two indicating factors
one is this yellow tab
right on the side of this garment
there's a yellow grosgrain tab it's very
specific it's on the side of every
single rich fresh garment
in existence
on the trousers
as well as the jacket
on every garment whether it's a suit
jacket whether it's a robe i don't care
and then the second
thing there's always
rich fresh made in los angeles because
it is in fact made in los angeles and
people should be aware of that
and then it goes from there it's almost
the last step in the production process
you've got the waistband this is the
trouser waistband it's got a built-in
hook and eye closure
if you do lose a little bit of weight
you can actually cinch this and it'll
take it in three quarters of an inch on
each side
[Music]
once the sewing process is done it goes
to one of the hand finishing titles
there's a lot of hand work even on a
tracksuit like the hem on these trousers
is done by hand there's an insane amount
of hand finishing on the insides of the
jackets because it's unlined so when you
open it it's beautiful
man
once i'm presenting the suit to the
client you know it's a full-on
presentation so it's a very minimal
garment bag you don't know what to
expect i kind of like that element of
surprise you didn't see it all did you
yeah great great great remember what we
discussed yes i'm from memphis
i'm gonna say something slick what did
we discuss
uh navy blue the black oh and then what
else
is that true
and then i'm gonna open it and the
client's usually gonna scream
like this oh man i see this
or exhale real heavily
there's always a moment of drama every
time i unzip and
fold it back oh good it wasn't by chance
bro my chance bro some i guess
something like that you put these on and
when you come back i'll put this on you
all right
so i'll let them have that moment
oh 100 oh wow
100 percent right
like you don't have to think about it oh
right
i'm gonna make sure that
you know everything fits the way it's
supposed to
and again if anything needs to be
modified
now is the time
um but if not
we shake hands we hug it out and they
take it with noticed
my hope is that they will be given more
and more opportunities to flex their
skills to show
how dynamic they are and what new fresh
elements of art they can bring to the
fashion industry
it's kind of like a pursuit of happiness
story almost
you know and like that was one of his
favorite movies not even live he watched
it so much he used to get on my nerves
it became part of his story
one of the most important things i could
take away on an entrepreneurial level
and as a businessman is just dream big
and and go after your goals the only one
that can stop you from becoming
successful is yourself
when i started i had no idea was going
to turn into
this this is the tracksuit empire
i don't have any investors all this is
all money in this is me going out and
hustling bringing that money back and
just building building it building it
there's so much more beyond this guy
there's really no telling what he would
come up with but we do know whatever he
comes up with is going to be dope
so
yeah there's really there's no limit you
can't put him in a box
you can't put a you can't put a sky over
him cause he's gonna bust through it
yeah
[Music]
so
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafak
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where is
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
[Music]
to me a good tattoo is a clean outline
smooth shading
if it's color solid color
and originality
what makes a good tattoo changes
if you have lighter skin you can almost
do a tattoo just as you would a painting
but if you have darker skin then you
need to simplify it so it can be seen
when it comes to tattooing i'm just a
vessel of that
creativity i'm just sitting back
watching my hand move
i'm not thinking about it
i know it ain't me no more
it's creation it's god it's another
place
and i don't care what the complexion of
the person is i'm gonna make them
something beautiful
[Music]
who is maya bailey
i would probably say artist
community builder team builder
i would describe peter street station
first is an art and design community
center down here in atlanta
we got tattoo artists our painters our
writers our musicians our singers
underwear roofs and we feed off each
other
and my whole goal is to create new
styles of art
and let these younger artists shine
train them
make sure i got full attention on their
resources
my whole goal is to see them to go as
far as they want to go
right now i shall lead you into the
humble abode
when people come in and they get in a
tattoo we give them a twitter building
maya has his private art collection
hanging up here
my whole goal is to make sure that
people come here feel welcomed so this
is my station this is where you will be
getting tattooed i want them to be
excited too because when they excited it
made me excited
when the client get here i'm not gonna
be here
but i got apprentices
and
what they're supposed to do is get this
client comfortable nice to meet you
[Music]
all right so what are you getting today
i don't know you don't know no
there are a couple of elements i would
like to include like i would like to
home that's very important to me like
it's a very big part of who and what i
am
before i get to work you know the first
thing i do i make sure i got some alone
time
take a long walk
i kind of take as much time i can on my
dogs enjoy that watch them play around
i really truly don't know exactly what
i'm going to do till i get there
good to meet you you as well
tell me a concept today so um
i'm a tattoo artist yeah right um and
you are my inspiration for being one oh
thank you
damn i would love anything in your style
i like bright colors and i love cartoons
if you think like your favorite cartoon
the simpsons yes
when i meet the person for the first
time i kind of just let them do they
talking you know what i'm saying like
when they explain it to me face to face
i can feel it i like abstract work i
like masks i have a lot of people in
healthcare in my family so i wanted to
kind of just give a little tribute to
the healers in my family okay okay once
they started reading out the story it's
like okay either gonna be family based
the
trauma or overcoming
or
spiritual growth
when i was telling my wife about coming
here and like how this was i don't want
to say it's a religious experience for
me because but it is you know what i
mean and so i just want that pouring
into this
before we start step one my apprentices
they prepped the whole area
they set up my inks in certain orders
the darks delights
then they're gonna shade the arm
and just make sure that the skin is
completely smooth without hair you want
a needle jacket up in a piece of hair
or you run over a piece of hair you mess
up your line or get tangled and it pulls
the hair out that hurts you know what
i'm saying
the next step is to freehand work
i get my red marker first
red is just sketch so you'll see me
sketch with the red
get a nice rhythm going
then i take a black marker and then i do
the black line that's the actual line
that the client is going to see
that's when i'm showing the actual
designs my guidelines the black lines
when i use straight lines
that means i'm thinking logic
thinking thoughts but anytime you see
curves and movement in it it represents
love or emotion
after i finished doing the black ink
then that's when you know i'm kind of
finished the design let the client stand
up look in the mirror
usually they like it
i just wait for that expression and once
i get that expression on a face
then i know
that uh it's gonna be a good session
[Music]
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quicktake
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
increasingly the institutional art world
is honing in on tattooing as being a
kind of art
and we've seen people that have
completed their art degrees moving to
tattooing
i'm david lane i'm an assistant
professor of criminal justice sciences
at illinois state university
part of what i study is crime and
deviance and the other part is culture
and art
the crime and deviance pays the bills
but i also get to do the art part when i
study tattooing
the oldest human bodies ever recovered
have tattoos on them meaning that we
know it's at least a five thousand year
old practice
there's not a single tribal society in
the world in which the indigenous people
don't practice tattooing
we can go to new zealand historically in
the maori tribes often their face
documented a lot of things like whether
people were on their first or second
marriage what kind of labor they carried
out their family lineage all sorts of
things could be read off the face here
in what's now the united states
we have documentation that alaska
natives tattooed people in the southwest
tattooed themselves even in tennessee we
found two thousand-year-old tattoo
needles
and then ultimately if we think about
our contemporary context
tattooing it's more popular and
accessible than it ever has been before
there were a few sort of pop culture
things that all sort of coincided over a
number of decades
[Music]
we had pop stars getting tattooed and by
the 1980s and definitely by the 90s
you're starting to see athletes whether
it's football or nba they're visibly
tattooed
by the time we get into the mid-2000s we
sort of have the birth of social media
and that allows people to take images of
their own tattoos or take images of
tattoos they produced and spread it to
new audiences easier
when i first started doing this research
and this is over a decade ago
jackie gresham was one of the first
names that ever came up
the conversation around jackie i it can
be summed up in a couple words
original
and and groundbreaking
my name is jackie gresham and i've been
in new orleans for 45 years tattooing
i'm the first black woman to
tattoo
this shop
back in the 70s and 80s we had bike
clubs come in here every sunday they
would come in here
and back then that was pretty much your
clientele
jackie was doing imagery
that was an aesthetic challenge to what
some white tattooers had considered the
sort of essence of tattooing so she's
sort of broken ground in that sense
today
tattoos the different types are endless
if you can see it we can do it as a
tattoo
miss jackie the world should know who
she is in my opinion
she's special
imagine what she had to deal with i came
up in the 90s and it was super racist
so i couldn't imagine anything she had
to go through
i think it makes it harder that i was a
black person i think also women in the
industry have a hard time as well
when i wanted to buy this building i had
fifteen thousand 000 down that's 25
but the people would not sell it to me
so that is a prime example
but with our society today i don't think
you're gonna have a problem
they have a lot of super
black artists that are incredible tattoo
artists and i think that people will
come to you and appreciate the good
artwork that you're doing
[Music]
once this tattoo is laid out and i'm
doing freehand
i start everything from the right hand
corner so i don't swipe off my stencil
so you'll see me go do a quick outline
around the whole entire thing because if
i don't it's going to be wiping off the
person's going to be sweating all this
stuff so i'm doing a quick outline
around the whole entire thing so i don't
lose it
then i come in different line weights
doubling up lines to make it fatter
thicker
and then i fill up my solid black areas
next to build out contrast
when i'm doing color i always say what's
the darkest part of my tattoo
so i might do say hey i'm gonna use
turquoise and i'm gonna do another color
next to turquoise that's not related to
turquoise so it can make the darker
turquoise color look even brighter
with the blackened grays there's more
thinking with black and gray a little
bit because with black and gray you
really got to make an image pop out
using only a few tones
with a color tattoo the black and gray
under the tattoo it's just your contrast
and you throwing color right on top of
that like an overlay so those pores are
open and they're healing at the same
time so you got to hurry up doing this
color
it's getting swollen and sore right now
i gotta knock this out before this
person tap out on me
i was probably always an artist growing
up
my mom was like i wouldn't even be
walking
and i could draw
and then as a child
i was going to the library and one of
the books i picked up was created by don
ed hardy
and i read it i thought about my father
having a tattoo
so
my mind clicked i'm like man you know
i think i'm something i'm interested in
doing
you know and in my time wasn't black
tattoo artists at all it was probably
like at this time probably four in the
world and
it was no black tattoo artist in north
carolina period i was the first one
so i ended up going to a tattoo shot
called liquid dragon
took me in man and just showed me some
ropes but i was messing around in the
streets and kind of blew that just
trying to find myself as a young man
getting in a whole bunch of trouble like
most young men do
and i blew my opportunity but it kind of
opened up a door for me to move out of
my hometown and move to atlanta
and i ended up opening up my first
tattoo shop
it made some good money so it gave me
that freedom to be able to paint and
explore art more in the gallery scene
i'm a painter that's what i really do
for a living painting i feel like that's
my right there you getting to see pure
me
i'm not worried about nothing
i'm not worried about if it's pretty or
not
because tattooed i gotta make it pretty
i gotta make it beautiful
the pain you don't have to make it
beautiful
you feeling ugly then you can express
that
we are done
once you finish the color or the black
and gray whatever tattoo you're doing
the next step is really
they're going to see it
they look at it from that angle but then
you want to look in the mirror so they
can see the reflection how it would be
naturally on their arm
the second reaction is very important
you know what i'm saying because you
definitely it's over you want them for
relief and you want them to be happy at
the same time
you like it i love it
thank you so much thank you
that's the part i like the most when i
client looking at mirror and see that
permanent thing i put on them
yeah man it's a big it's a big
responsibility
then we bring them back
i take my photos my pictures for my
social media
and then i wrap them up
i use like a saran wrap basic stuff just
to catch the blood and it'll mess up
their clothes
thank you so much
[Music]
when it's done
i'm more thankful than anything
because i'm like damn i just made
fifteen hundred dollars and this money
is going to go back to this apprentices
hosting them it's going back to their
careers getting them a place to work and
it's just a good cycle that's what i'm
trying to do
if you want there to be a vibrant tattoo
culture you ought to go be a member of
it
so go meet tattooers and get to know
them and figure out if you like them
because you're going to have a moment
that's going to be with you for a while
you might as well have a good time while
doing it
when it come to tattooing i'd be feeling
more like a healer or sherman
even though you really don't need a
tattoo but it made me feel like they
needed that and it's released for them
it's really for me
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quicktake
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
i always try to put a little bit of my
soul in the guitar
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a mixture of sweetness which i
sometimes have not always and a little
bit of bravery
[Music]
the part that i love the most about uh
working with wood it's uh touching it
the the feeling of the wood in my hands
it's something that always reminds me
about who i am
where are my roots where i belong to
the wood needs to be dried at least for
30 years which means that i'm using the
materials that my grandfather bought
i never met him he died one month before
i was born so i get to touch the things
that he picked
without knowing if they will be for me
because i'm the first woman in the
family to make it up so it's it's quite
special
once you have picked the material then
you start to prepare all the parts of
the guitar we always start with shaping
of the neck
second part it's the top when we decide
the materials we decide which one of the
templates that we have are we gonna use
[Music]
the first thing that you do when you cut
it
is to put it in the solera the solar is
a mole that we use for the for the top
and the back to give the guitar this
little
curve so it sounds better
and then for the top we need to put the
rosette in it and it's little pieces of
wood and we make the the drawing the
design and we have to start putting
every single piece so it matches the row
set it's one of the most difficult parts
to do but it's also one of the most
creative ones where you are allowed to
do whatever you want
it takes me like two months and a half
to make a couple of guitars because we
are always making a couple of them so
when one is gluing we can work with the
other one
actually when a guitar is glueing we're
gonna use this old form of clamp these
ones we made ourselves here so we can
put pressure on the guitar
the flamenco classical guitar they may
look equal but in the construction
they're different classical player they
always look for a neat note bright
sound but the flamingo ones they just
want soul
[Music]
everybody asks about the side spending
you have to put them under the water for
a couple of hours and then you do this
bending with heat
we use a little oven and if you get the
wood wet through the process you can
bend the sides to the separate guitar
[Music]
second business started with the uncle
of my grandfather in 1915.
nowadays in this workshop we are three
people plus my father
at first continuing the the tradition it
was not something that i had in mind and
my father suggested me to come to the
workshop in the evenings just to try
and i found it beautiful to know
how the family business work and how to
make a guitar
[Music]
the first
guitar that i close i remember going
back home and my smile couldn't be
bigger
because it's the first moment that you
see a complete guitar
for joining of the back we need to put
enough pressure to stick the back and
the sides but it's not so much so the
sights could break
the tradition is to give your first
guitar to your mother but i'm not a boy
so i decided to to give it to my father
which was my master i was totally afraid
that it would be a mistake and a mess
and it wouldn't sound
but it did sound
and it did sound well
and i couldn't be more proud
i remember this as one of the most
exciting days in my life
once you have stacked all the guitar
together then you start with a
fingerboard we always use ebony from
africa and it's a really tough material
because it has a lot of density it's
really heavy
you have to be very careful in the
distribution of the frets if you were
mistaken by just one millimeter you
wouldn't be able to tune it it would be
impossible
after that you only have to to give the
last touches
[Music]
[Applause]
once agata is finished you have to
adjust the neck bone and the bridge bone
and this is really important because
that will decide the tension of the
strings
[Music]
sometimes you need a whole day to adjust
the guitar to find it perfect
but i guess
it will never be perfect because it
depends on the person who plays the
guitar
[Music]
i have really good memories with
flamenco music and and for me it's it's
it means home actually it comes from the
heart of a personality
[Music]
i have this romantic idea that this is
my
grain that i
live in this world
so someone else can make music which
gives life to all of us
[Music]
foreign
it's an ode to the way that things used
to be made it's not just something
that's been mass produced or put through
a line and made millions of we make them
hand by hand individually each one
there's definitely faster ways there's
ways to cut corners but how do we make
something without cutting any corners
what's the best way we can do it it's a
long way to do it it's a hard way to do
it but if there's a way to do it that
way then we figure it out
you can really see that in the quality
of the bags when you get one when you
hold one
[Music]
my name is lindy mcdonough and i'm the
creative director at load of leather
for us you know we grew up in new
england and i would get a bag one season
and have a big logo on it and then two
seasons later you'd almost be
embarrassed to have it and you know
that's not in new england how we grow up
how we have goods you know you should
have a thing that you can pass down to
your next to your next generation to
your next that's going to get more
beautiful as you use it and that was
always the ethos for the company
the triumph briefcase from the outside
it looks very clean but it's actually a
very complicated bag it's one of the
most difficult bags that we make
takes about four to six weeks to make
each one there's no rushing mat the bag
has about 61 individual pieces in each
bag
we start on the cutting table
we roll out a hide our hides all come
from a family-owned tannery our leather
is all made specially for us all of the
leather is fully vegetable tanned so no
chromium no formaldehyde nothing in the
base if you've ever had a
piece of leather goods that over time
starts to peel and there's white that's
showing through that means that there's
actually some sort of chemical or
chromium inside the leather that's
causing it to rust our leather won't do
that it'll get more beautiful and patina
as you use it
you're also looking for you know
imperfections in the height so tick
bites scars
open cuts anything like that just making
sure the beginning process that you find
it make sure we don't use it
the bags then go through and all 61 of
those pieces are cut from one hide
you're actually getting someone who laid
out that cut and then thought about what
was the piece that's going next to it
and then thought about the piece that
was going next to that
[Music]
they all get cut and individually
numbered and then we'll bring them over
to the splitter
[Music]
is taking the leather and making it
thinner we have different weights for
every part of the bag
from the design process too it's one of
those things that we spend a lot of time
thinking about like could this be a
little bit thinner could this be thicker
we measure every single piece and we
measure it to actually the tenth of an
ounce we really do pay a lot of
attention to the weight of every piece
[Music]
once everything is split it goes to the
grinding station the grinding station is
where all of the pieces are
shaped we take all of the pieces and we
sand them straight all of those pieces
are shaped and ground and done by eye
it's one of those things of why what we
do can't be automated
from the grinding station it moves to
the painting station we have about four
people painting to every one person at
every other station
because we do fully traditional
burnished and polished edges the
painters get the ground pieces they
paint a layer and they essentially raise
the grain of the leather and then they
bring it over to the buffing machine and
then buff it and then they bring it back
to the painting station and then they
paint another coat of edge dye and then
they would buff it again and you're
going back and forth with all 61 of
those pieces at the minimum of three
times and some of which ate
that's why we hire artists they have an
eye for it and they're like this is not
right yet and they will finish it until
it's right
so when we started this space this
manufacturing space five years ago we
had three people and now we are at 22.
it's pretty rad
our team at lodif is 75 women 75
of them are under the age of 35 and
about 70 of them have a bachelor's
degree always the biggest struggle has
been how do you find work that you know
you have a day job from nine to five
that can support your life as an artist
and that was always the vision behind
what we do for lotive we have furniture
makers jewelry designers print makers
illustrators painters and so making a
great job they could come in work with
us 30 hours a week get full benefits
healthcare
all of those benefits and then getting
to do their studio practice outside of
it is a really amazing thing and we get
amazing work because of that and i think
it's what makes
what goes into the bag so special
in between the painting phase and the
stitching phase there's one piece in
every bag that gets the bag number and
the load of logo and so those pieces
come to the monogramming station
we log all of the numbers um in our
records so we know what pieces we're
going through what color it was what
style it was and what number is
correlated to that
then things go to stitching
so all 61 of those pieces for the
triangle again brought over and get the
first level of stitching
we use a super strong thread that's made
by a local maker we get all the thread
dyed to match each one of the leather
colors
for the most part every single one of
the pieces has a specific amount of
stitches that's there stitch width from
the edge is really specific the amount
of stitches per inch is really specific
all of that is considered and then they
get moved to the turn and burn station
which is our hand stitching station so
they finish the thread with a hand tied
knot burn it and then tuck it back into
the same hole where it came from so it
will actually hold and then close the
leather over it so it's locking
essentially that stitch inside of the
leather
the hand stitching element is something
that makes our bags pretty special
after it's turned and burned it will go
back to painting and buffing and then it
would all go to assembly
assembly station is where they're gluing
and assembling the bags from the
two-dimensional pieces into the
three-dimensional and there's different
levels of that
[Music]
they will take all of the gussets and
all of the partitions glue them and then
they hammer it
there's kind of a lot of back and forth
between those stations until it's done
it goes back to grinding and then back
to painting and then just the full loop
all the way again and it does that about
five times before the bag is finished
the very last thing that we do is
monogramming the bags
[Music]
and then we hand write note and then
there's a card that goes in every bag
that has the bag number let's put in a
beautiful gift box
that's the last step
before the bag is shipped out
it's important that everything's made
here it's about accountability it's
accountability to our customers it's
making sure that we are
doing things the way that we say that
we're doing it and watching every step
of the way and we really couldn't do
that if we weren't making it here and
making it ourselves and
we can really say that we look at every
single piece and make sure that it's
perfect before it goes out the door
we're not just a marketing company but
we're actually we're a maker company
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition so before you
invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
i think one of the things that you can
say about me is i never when i was broke
i didn't let my my bank account define
me and right when i'm not broke i'm not
gonna let my bank account to find me i
am you know i'll try to be my own person
and just my friends are my friends that
that never changed my pittsburgh friends
are still my my great friends you know
my college friends my rugby friends all
the different segments of my life
they're still my guys
what's going on what up tv not a thing
how you doing good man thanks for having
me man i appreciate you my pleasure
appreciate you coming through
absolutely um so to start it off uh tell
us who you are
oh my goodness um grew up in pittsburgh
pennsylvania um born in squirrel hill
moved to the south hills birdland um and
then mount lebanon and um
my dad did upholstery on cars my mom did
odd jobs just just a normal kid man that
just happened to
be have an aptitude for business from as
long as i can remember was was it one of
your dreams like as a kid like i know i
was in the backyard man my brother
was trying to be michael jordan and
scotty pippen uh i was mj of course but
uh like was it a dream of yours to own
an nba team no hell no
yeah
honestly it wasn't until i
tried to buy the mavs that even crossed
my mind really like yeah when i was a
kid you know i played sports not very
well but yeah i wanted to be earl of
pearl monroe i had his skin move and
everything in a baseball game salem
state university by the way
exactly
i never really thought that i would ever
be in a position to own anything man i
just wanted to have a good life and try
to find my way to college so now
you know all these things that you've
done in life all this stuff that's been
a part of your journey tell us a little
bit about what that was like like what
it was like growing up and um in
pittsburgh you know my mom was really
young when she had me she was 20 and so
you know in hindsight i realized how
little my parents really knew right
because they were just young
but my dad would just get up and go to
work and he was he
neither one of them went to college and
they were like you guys i have two
younger brothers brian and jeff like you
guys are going to college and we're
going to figure it out because education
is important
and you've got to find your own path and
he was always pushing me and both my
parents were pushing me to to be
independent
and
however it started i don't know from the
time i was nine ten years old i was
hustling i was i was one of those kids
that was always selling something yeah
yeah like i was selling baseball cards
right i would go buy baseball cards and
then i'd flip them right get as many you
know get good at flip and package it
then i'd go down to the park where we
would pick up play pickup or whatever
there would be this bench that was there
and i would just sit there and repackage
baseball cards and i'd say okay there's
definitely one pittsburgh pirate in one
of these right you might get roberto
clemente you might get willy starcho and
i'd mark him up and make some money and
you know and that's how i'd get spending
money and i remember one day my dad was
playing poker
i was like dad i need a new pair of
converse right and he's like i see those
you know those shoes on your feet they
still work right and i'm like yeah he's
like well when you have a job you can
buy whatever you want but until then
those shoes still work and i'm like dad
i can't get a job i'm 12 years old and
one of his poker buddies speaks up and
goes yeah i got a job for you i'm like
what he goes i've got these boxes of
garbage bags and you can go sell them
around the neighborhood and i'm like
cool like boxes and boxes garbage bags
right so literally i would go to our
neighbors and i go
hi i'm your neighbor mark do you use
garbage bags you sound like a shark tank
yeah right yeah exactly and of course
everybody uses garbage bags never forget
they cost me three bucks for a box of a
hundred i would sell them for six bucks
and i would just
take them to them every couple weeks
right whenever they needed more garbage
bags and i'm making 20 bucks a week
which was like
big time i got my shoes and you know but
that taught me to be confident and that
taught me that i could sell and that
taught me that selling was helping not
convincing you know because once i
figured out that everybody needed
garbage bags then it really became
obvious to me that if i can find things
that people needed right and wanted and
i could do it a better way than what
they were doing it then i could make
some money and that's kind of stayed
with me i was just about to say it's
crazy how you was thinking about that at
12 and everything you just said
basically translates to everything
you're basically doing now in life yeah
exactly i mean because that's what it's
all about i mean you know selling isn't
convincing somebody to do something they
don't want to do selling is
understanding what chris paul needs and
then finding a way to provide it in a
better way than what they're doing now
you make it sound way too easy but it's
not as hard as it sounds right but most
you know it's like basketball right
there's a lot of guys that maybe we're
more talented than you right right one
thing i know and respect about you and
the few times we've talked like you talk
about you know doing the work
right getting on synergy sports which i
was excited about because the company i
had helped get going right and invested
on and always watching the place knowing
the other teams plays you know when they
call them out so you know what's going
to happen being able to guide business
is the exact same way most people don't
put in the work business is the exact
same way you know i have all these corny
sayings practice too you can't get it
wrong how you do anything is how you do
everything yeah
i just still to this day try to remind
myself of these things all the time for
you you started college in pittsburgh
yeah and then went to indiana yeah why
when i was 16 i decided i wanted to take
college classes at night just to see if
i was as smart as i thought i was
and so so at 16 you were what uh junior
junior in high school yeah and he just
started taking college yeah so i just
said what the hell right i'll just take
these classes and i took a psychology
class and did good in it and
then i wanted to um
take a business class at my high school
mount lebanon high school and they
wouldn't let me do that
and so i'm like
well then i'm just going to go to
college right so i dropped out of high
school didn't go back for my senior year
and went to the university of pittsburgh
but they didn't have a real business
school back then i decided i wanted to
go to business school saw a list of the
top 10 undergraduate business schools
and indiana was the cheapest and got in
and had never seen the campus didn't
visit none of that stuff just went sight
unseen and turned out okay
you graduated from indiana what was your
dream job
well i was i wanted to start my own
company at some level right so all
through indiana i had all kinds of side
hustles because i pretty much had to pay
for my own college and so whether it was
party promoting my freshman and
sophomore years
to
having a chain letter to pay for my
junior year
to um
opening up a bar that was like the hot
spot on campus my senior year until we
got busted for letting all my friends in
because i just turned 21 you know so i
was a hustler a bunch of my buddies had
come down to dallas
and they were like you got to come down
is that what got you to texas yeah yeah
a bunch of my buddies were down here and
they're like look the weather's good the
economy's really starting to hop um and
the women are hot i'm like i didn't hear
the first two i'm like i'm coming boom
right i'm on my way on my way three
bedroom apartments five other roommates
so six of us live in a three bedroom
apartment i was in last so i was the guy
who didn't have his own room didn't have
his own closet on the floor
or some you know buddies were out i'm
taking their bed so that's where i got
started in dallas and i got a job
working as a bartender at night and then
finally got a job um
in the computer industry and that's
really where i realized okay i really
like these computers i mean i have an
aptitude for it and this this is it i'm
going for it so when i say broadcast.com
yes i mean you menu
[Laughter]
right
when it comes to crypto and blockchain
and stuff how do you feel about that i
think it's a guy they're a big part of
the future i really really do but i
think people are looking at the wrong
way
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
so when i say broadcast.com what is that
menu
[Laughter]
right yeah i don't think people realize
what it was all about though um because
it's been so long now i sold my first
company micro solutions in 1989 um 1990
i guess when it closed
and retired just took time off party
like a rock star
and would get together with one of my
indiana buddies todd wagner and one day
he's sitting down it's you know late
1994 early 95 and he's like look this
new internet thing there's got to be a
way that we can use it to listen to
indiana basketball because we're in
dallas and you know this is before you
could get it with directv or cable or
whatever right and i'm like okay let me
see if i can figure it out because my
first company i would write software
taught myself the right software did
networking wider so it was a perfect fit
to figure it out so i bought a packer
bell computer put into the second
bedroom my house connected a radio to it
and we just started working with
different software didn't write all the
software but wrote enough to get it up
and running next thing you know we
started this website called audionet
worked with the local radio station
kliff i set up um and a vcr an
old-school vcr next to their radio
station i would record it take the vcr
tapes encode it put it on a server in
the second better in my house and then
just email and go online and tell as
many people look if you want to listen
to dallas sports and stuff come to the
site called audionet.com blew up
immediately three years later it turned
into broadcast.com we added video we
went public it was the biggest first day
ipo in the history of the stock market
at the time and we were youtube i mean
literally hundreds of internet radio
stations hundreds of radio stations tv
stations you know streaming like we went
and got the rights to um north carolina
basketball we were showing online
michael jordan mixtapes once you get
that it's a wrap yeah right so we would
just we just blew up and then yahoo came
along and bought us and paid us um
i think was 5.7 billion dollars in stock
not in cash so then i had to protect my
the stock that i got because you know
fortunately i did i did this thing
called hedging and it protected me when
the whole internet bubble burst and
that allowed me to turn it into cash and
then
a couple weeks later i was trying to buy
the mavs yeah so on to that on to that
so all of the stuff that you were doing
in technology computers and everything
like that
why the mavericks well i was a season
ticket holder right but i've been going
to mavs games since i got to dallas um
but in the 90s they were really bad and
literally you could buy a ticket
upstairs and just walk down and sit in
the front row right because there was
nobody there and even though we were
awful it was the start of the 99-2000
season i was there with my girlfriend
now wife
and
the place wasn't sold out you know and
so you're a season ticket holder 99 2000
yeah right and where are your seats at
my seats are right by the mavs bench
where you sit
close close yeah a little bit yeah two
rows back i was into it right and then
there was nobody there and i remember
yeah there was nobody there right nobody
it was opening night and the place
wasn't sold out and this was in the old
reunion arena and i'm like i can do a
better job than this right then it hit
me ding ding ding now i could afford
this stuff right right right you know so
my my i talked to my ticket rep um a guy
named mark who then connected me to mark
mcguire and mark aguirre was working for
ross pearl jr who was the owner then and
he connected me together and the season
started like beginning november end of
october by january 4th um so only six
weeks later give or take
i owned the mavs
what yeah no no no no tyler you rewind
you don't just sit at the game and then
six weeks later pretty much on the death
i like that and what's what's crazy for
me is around then i was 16 years old 16
17 years old and i'm a high school
basketball player and i
i'm telling you man like my senior year
in high school even like when i was a
freshman at wake like i loved everything
dirk yeah everything jerk was the bad
yeah i used to like turn my feet in on
my free throws you remember when dirt
free throws like this yeah a little
knock kneed yeah yeah yeah i used to do
that for a little while what not just so
i can shoot like dirt and i tell you
even to sit here and have this
conversation is so crazy because i
i remember when you bought the team and
i saw you like this
right seriously i think at some point we
all thought that someone buying a team
or something had to have a suit on and
all this different type stuff and to see
you today the same way you worked in i
think says a lot you've always genuinely
been a fan of not just your team but the
game and that's that's dope to see man
yeah i mean because it's for all of us
right yeah and i always say i don't own
the team i just handled the finances but
all mavs fans everywhere on the team
that's what makes basketball we're all
sports right so much different than
traditional businesses look at apple
right true multi-trillion dollar market
cap no one's throwing a parade in
cupertino when they have you know a
super quarter right right right right
there's not a whole city that gets on
fire right when you're moving like when
you guys you know with the suns last
year just coming out of nowhere and bam
getting into the finals the whole city
is on fire that's a great point yeah
shark tank yeah
what was the pitch to you that got you
involved in shark tank um
it was like we're doing this this
business show right do you want to come
on as a guest
and i'd watch the show and i'm like okay
you know it was on abc and it was
bouncing around right it wasn't on any
one night and i'm thinking
all right i'm gonna go on and i'm just
gonna blow them up right because they're
not gonna see me coming and this is a
business show and it's okay right but i
don't think it's gonna last so i'm just
gonna this is you know prime time
network tv and i'm just gonna mess with
everybody so i get on there and just
tear them all up they had no idea what
was coming but all of a sudden you know
like it did in other countries shark
tank starts to take off and
you know what it from what it started as
me just having fun to what it's become
which is a way to educate families kids
about business and really get kids
excited about entrepreneurship
that's what got me really to stay with
the show we'll be locked in yeah we'll
be locked in it's the coolest thing
because like you said it's not just
for adults right like my whole family my
parents my wife my kids will be sitting
there watching you know and there are
products that we
buy now all the time that came from as
long as you're my deal
right right
but for you but for you you've heard
hundreds of pitches yeah maybe thousands
of pitches thousands of pitches in
trying to figure out all these different
deals or whatnot what would be your
biggest advice to an entrepreneur or
somebody trying to start a business well
you know first know your business right
i think people will always stop and say
well i want to start a business what
should i do and if you don't know you're
not ready right you know
you've got to
have something that you're good at and
if you're going to be if you're going to
do it you got to be the best at it
because i'll tell them look if i come in
and compete with you i'm going to kick
your ass are you ready to compete with
me yeah right and you've got to work
like there's someone working 24 hours a
day to take it away from you you have a
website that lists all your different
businesses yes mark cuban.com right
right all your different businesses and
all because do you have like a separate
company that's just for like shark tape
no right no
no they're all i mean so i don't have
like a fund that i that invests in all
the different companies it's just me
making direct investments and all yeah
but this is it's not just the money it's
the time oh yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot going on people
who help me yeah it takes the people a
lot smarter than me to make all this
work right i've got a lot of really
really great people that are um around
that make me look smart so when it comes
to crypto and blockchain and stuff how
do you feel about that i think it's a
big part of the future right i really
really do but i think people are looking
at the wrong way
people get really amped up about um the
price of the the currency
cryptocurrencies right the tokens
and they think that's really what crypto
is but it's not that's the noise right
the signal is if i were going to start a
business how can i use this new
technology to give myself a competitive
advantage and disrupt disrupting
industry and so you know to give you an
example
is nfts right everybody's all amps about
nfts and you see guys with their board
api club all day long all day long
and it's a collectible just like
anything else but to me nfts are just a
proof of concept and an example of how
smart contracts work when you go through
the process of creating an nft one of
the things they always ask you is what's
your royalty rate
and so when i set one up for the first
time i'm like royalties right how the
hell does that work because there's no
other way to make money every time a
digital asset is resold and get paid a
royalty and then i'm thinking okay well
if it works for these nfts where else
can i use this stuff right what other
business applications can i use
right the nfts were just showing you
another way to do other things proof of
concept right proof of concept again
it's like basketball right basketball
right now is changing and technology
keeps on changing yeah right it went
from you know post up and all this
different types of the game changes it
changed because the technology made
people smarter right you went from
synergy right to second spectrum yeah
right yeah and then the data is
different and now we're getting into
using computer vision and ai for pose
estimation all this is just technology
changing
biomechanics all the biomechanics but
how do you track the biomechanics right
i didn't see you win championships i
hadn't seen you win big games but
i don't ever think i've seen you as
happy as you are when you're on those
videos with your kids i can get them to
do them every day twice a day i don't do
them i don't care how embarrassed i get
by them yeah it's fun right
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
one of your recent hires in the past
couple years with cynthia yeah i said
marshall yeah yeah
marshall yeah she's a machine i mean
she's she's a force of nature she's
she's she's amazing you know we had some
challenges um that we went through three
years ago and you know i i hadn't been
connected to the business side of it i
was always on the basketball side and
some things went wrong and i had to own
up to them
i needed somebody who could come in that
understood how to turn the culture of an
organization around
and she has just been a superstar she
don't play either no she don't play
yeah she says that all the time i don't
play yeah i don't play i don't play but
that's who she is and she changed the
culture she changed the organization you
know diversity inclusion is is a tough
topic you know because a lot of people
look at it just being about a checklist
and what i've learned particularly from
her is
that it's not about checking the boxes
it's about being pragmatic and doing
business the right way because what i
learned from her is
when when we bring people from different
communities that opens doors into those
communities right and so like dallas has
the sixth largest indian population in
the country i didn't know that did not
know that you just said so you want to
find people from that community to sell
into that community you want to find
people of color who can connect because
i can walk in there and people who look
like me can walk in there yeah
i'm not going to have the same effect or
have the same understanding
and she
she already knew that right she knew how
to not only understand it not only
recognize the impact but how to deliver
it and that's what makes her special and
she's just got that energy and that vibe
and that love that comes out of her
genuine yeah unbelievably genuine so
i've known you for a while mark and i
didn't even know that you you had had
kids until i seen you on tick-tock
i seen you on tick-tock
see you on tick-tock with your daughter
man to tell you the truth cause i i've
done a few of my kids you know what i
mean and i'm telling you man i didn't
see you
win championships i hadn't seen you win
big games but
i don't ever think i've seen you as
happy as you are when you're on those
videos with your kids i can get them to
do them every day twice a day i do i
don't care how embarrassed i get by them
yeah it's fun right because i mean you
know now they're the joy of my life
they're everything and
you know it took me a while to realize
that because like when they're really
really little really appreciate it yeah
but once they became real people you
know there's it's just yeah there's just
nothing better and if if i had a choice
between just spending time with them
it's like i tell people the most
precious word in the dictionary for me
is dad yeah when you hear your kids call
you dad yeah
there's only one way there's only three
people in the universe who can say that
to me and those are most important
all that we talked about you could see
you was into it but when i brought up
your kids
and jumped out at your seat and it's
scary too right because you know
you had you had to work your way up and
you know and it's your success in a lot
of respects but then it just terrifies
you you know because your kids can't
copy that same path right you know as
much as you know your path and i know my
path and it's not going to be my kid's
path they've got to find their own and
it scares me because i don't want them
to grow up to be entitled right you know
i don't want them to take everything for
granted i want them to feel something
that you have to work for to get it yeah
and it's you know but they ain't dumb
they ain't down no they
they know exactly you know who paid for
the house and how you know that's the
challenge i think that a lot of us face
man and i'm just
uh grateful to sit down and talk to you
all these years man we've never been
talking this long man so
thank you so much appreciate it yeah
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillions etf
masterchef only on quick take
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shaffer
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
part of what i love about business is
you get to build things from nothing i
don't have any investors all this is all
money in this is me just building
it's pretty much full service shadow
banking with nobody in charge
[Music]
i'm scarlet foo i've been covering
business news since the 90s i'm madison
mills i was born in the 90s and i grew
up on myspace i grew up on mixtapes and
a savings account that got seven percent
interest i don't really see the value of
a savings account when interest rates
are nearly zero
scarlett all of my that cost me seven
dollars
maddie will be my guide to the world of
influencers and meme songs sit down
we're gonna take off soon
[Music]
so here's the situation food prices are
way up and this has broad reaching
social and economic repercussions and
political ones right remember biden
clapping back at that fox news reporter
the other week
[Music]
that's a great asset more inflation what
a stupid song not good not good but it
goes to show that you know voters
especially young ones i don't think that
they're thinking about the economic
concept of inflation
[Music]
so scarlett i want to talk about one of
my favorite things food prices are all
over the place and i'm a big dollar
slice fan but the dollar slice is dying
in new york city so i got us an
interview with one of the final
remaining pizza shops that has a dollar
slice available so we're gonna go talk
to him in a little bit find out how he's
working this out and how he manages
through this whole situation i think we
should also talk to bloomberg's
restaurant editor because you've got
dollar slice on the one hand then you've
got high-end restaurants they have more
room to figure out how they're going to
pass cost along to their consumers
absolutely yeah and this affects us in
all of our life decisions right like
every day three times a day exactly
exactly nothing is more important than
food it's what we talk about all day
long we've got a fast-growing economy
we've got plentiful jobs apparently but
if everything is going up in price
you're not feeling too good and people
will take that to the polls when they
vote for their next elected official
right we keep hearing about how it's the
workers economy and we have all this
power now but i don't know that it feels
that way for everyone i mean just open
your tick tock feed right we're seeing
so many videos of people complaining
about the financial situation
understandably and a lot of them are
asking why can't the government just
print more money and we know that that
is not a solution but why is that the
government has already printed a lot of
money it's distributed a lot of cash to
a lot of people and there are arguments
that that's contributed to the rapid
rise in prices that's contributed to
inflation so if the government were to
do even more of that that would perhaps
exacerbate the inflation that we're
seeing now yeah and it affects everyone
from the top of the food chain to just
everyday americans like this is a jay
powell issue as much as it is a family
issue i noticed this stat in the paper
the other week that shocked me there's
been an eight percent increase in fast
food prices over the past year and it
makes me just remember the the lower
cost items of new york that are so near
and dear to our hearts like the dollar
slice so i set us up with the owner of a
pizza shop in soho that still has the
dollar slice interesting yes so we're
gonna go down there today open up the
books get a look into his finances and
figure out how i have so many questions
for him you're gonna be amazing with him
i already know it yeah
so food prices have risen so much it's
pushed up our grocery bills you wonder
how that changes the calculus for
actually going out to eat as opposed to
cooking at home right and we will always
take an excuse to not cook yes it brings
us back to the basics of new york a
slice of pizza let's check out champion
pizza
with its original store opening in 2009
champion pizza has grown into an
award-winning celebrity attracting
bonafide new york slice of life a labor
of love for its owner hockey octanes
you
own five pizza stores in new york city
yes i do and and how are things going as
we head into 2022
what do you think
the cost for everything must be going up
and you must be feeling it yeah i mean i
show you guys you know like what are
these what are we looking at here so
this is the company concluded that i buy
supplies from them since 2010 and it's
been almost 12 years
the same company same supply same food
everything same only different as the
price
inflation in action the pepperoni how
much was like pepperoni sliced here is
three dollars 89 cents per unit right
now it's a 544 yeah each pound
i use like almost like every day like
i'm a 20 pound that cost me almost seven
dollars the pepperoni alone yeah just
pepperoni production snags and lack of
competition have driven up meat prices
labor shortages and increased shipping
rates have made tomatoes more costly and
droughts heavy rain and deep freezes
slammed wheat crops that pushed flower
prices up all of these factors have duly
affected the humble slice
are you charging more for your pizzas
not the price is the same i couldn't
change the price
the sx pizza shop
i increased like 50 cent but for the
kids i couldn't change it because
they don't have money so it's still one
dollar
for the kids you know last you know like
believe it or not uh i save money for my
son to college i take um
all his money in
college so you use your savings
i take everything i just put my business
when you're having to make such tough
personal decisions how do you not just
say
guys i'm not doing dollar slices anymore
you need to pay two dollars that's why
you know like i keep my customer if i
play with something i'm so scared that
i'm gonna lose what i have consistent
pricing isn't just a business decision
for hockey it's a personal one from a
guy who had a tough journey and wants to
give back
so hackie you know a lot about flat
bread because
this is something that you liked eating
when you were a child growing up right
yeah in turkey in turkey i started work
like 11 and turkish pizza shop i learned
a lot over there and about the dough so
i come to new york in 2001 january 28th
and i have 240 dollars in my pocket i
don't speak word of english and two
weeks later i become homeless and i met
one guy he's from senegal his name
ronnie he speak franchise but he was
homeless as well
so he take me to bowery mission as a
homeless shelter on baudi as the the
hottest thing in the world okay to be
homeless no one choose to become
homeless believe that guys no one
when you don't have money as one dollar
is your net worth it's your everything
and one dollar for them is like a
million dollars the first paycheck when
i get paid
i want a bathroom and i said thank you
god thank you for everything all right i
cry a lot and that's partly your
thinking behind why you're keeping your
prices the way they are yeah one hundred
percent keep it accessible for people am
i gonna change it you'd rather close
stores than raise your prices yes
even i have one store i still could
survive and take in my family and you
know send my kids in school like i could
still survive to walking behind my
content
hard work and love drives a lot of small
business owners like hockey
but what's driving his customers is
simply a love for great pizza
wow oh my god
i mean this is all my favorite food this
looks amazing that one is lasagna what's
your favorite one out of all these to
eat i usually eat this one or this one
yeah either one you like the burrata
yeah i love brotha but you know like
just too much a little bit you know
sometimes yeah yeah but if you want to
be healthy yeah i go for this
it's so fun
so that's your basic pizza slice or
pizza pie in this case i know but you
kind of have to wonder how all of these
millions of other restaurants are
handling inflation yeah yeah absolutely
let's go talk to bloomberg's restaurant
editor
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11.
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
[Music]
the cost of producing cattle right now
is the highest i've ever seen it and it
don't seem to be an end in sight
[Music]
pat dean has been raising cattle his
entire life the third generation rancher
he's used to working seven days a week
365 days a year
we try to get up and get started about
seven o'clock and
we go just as long as we can and to
accomplish as much as we can and
hopefully
nothing out of the ordinary rises we get
to quit at a decent time
sometimes we're out all night over the
years he's seen a lot of ups and downs
but never a crisis quite like this
low prices for our product and high
prices for everything we need to produce
this product but it seems like in the
last year
or two years
all our outgoing money or all our
expenses the things we have to buy just
skyrocketed
american farmers are feeling the pinch
of inflation across entire production
lines the price of fertilizer corn fuel
and labor are up with no ceiling in
sight
we definitely
think
a lot more about purchasing anything
i mean we try to get by
with what we have as best we can and not
buy any new equipment and
try not to do a lot of unnecessary
unnecessary work
as people like pat struggle demand for
beef is spiking
prices were up more than 20 in november
from a year earlier
despite those markups many ranchers say
profits aren't being evenly distributed
there's no guarantee of anything prices
could be
uh 10 cents lower 10 cents higher
just we just we're at the mercy of
the buyers at the sale today
where most people
produce something they kind of control
the price
we don't we just get what we get and
hope it's enough to pay the bills
federal data shows that for every dollar
spent on food the share that went to
ranchers and farmers dropped from 35
cents in the 1970s to 14 cents recently
that could lead to some tough decisions
i hope to be able to do this till i'm
about 65 and then downsize to just a few
at the house
hopefully we've got enough money to live
on time
by that time but if we don't we can sell
our property and
downsize there too and retire on that
the white house is pointing the finger
at meat packers
since the 1980s the industry has seen
rapid consolidation with only four major
companies dominating the space today
part of that is a movement into bigger
slaughterhouses and bigger meat
processing facilities
that create these economies of scale
that reduce the price of meat but
obviously that creates a capacity
constraint and it's a big capital
investment to create a new one
mike dorning is a washington
correspondent for bloomberg news
overseeing coverage on agriculture he
says that there are a lot of factors at
hand big companies would tell you one of
the problems they face is it's harder
for them to get enough people to work
and keep those factories going
at the kind of pace they want and still
pay the wages that they want
the justice department is investigating
these companies to determine whether
they are violating anti-trust laws the
probe started in the last year of the
trump administration and biden's
administration is pushing forward
earlier this year the government
unveiled one billion dollars in aid for
smaller meat industry producers
so much of the food inflation has been
meat inflation be it beef
pork chicken and that's politically
sensitive not just on the rancher side
but on the consumer side and it
especially hurts middle and low-income
people who use a bigger part of their
budget for food
so the
biden administration has been like
looking for ways to try to attack
inflation while they wait on assistance
farmers are looking for a future that
keeps them on land and following their
passion i hope i'm always able to have a
few just because we enjoy raising them
and that's what we do we just kind of
take it one day at the time and
whatever comes along we'll get through
it one way or the other
cake crater is bloomberg's restaurant
editor we're talking about food price
inflation and how it's showing up in
restaurants you cover high-end
restaurants in new york what are you
seeing from where you sit are
restaurants changing up their menu
raising prices um they're doing all of
it i mean they're doing everything they
can to combat inflation because it's
real between supply chain shortages and
labor shortages they are looking at
every means possible and a lot there's
still also
a lot of hopes and you know sort of
betting that people who want to live
with their parents or who started
teaching yoga online are going to be are
going to say you know what i'm i need to
go back and like have a job that pays me
an hourly wage it's a brutal business to
be in truly
still sounds like they're not raising it
by the full amount they're not passing
everything along to the consumer right
is there a ceiling that they're not
willing to go past in some places
there's a ceiling we um there over the
summer we were documenting um a big
increase in seafood prices like scallops
and so we had like a very good line that
at the clam there are no scallops um and
the clam's a great uh west village
restaurant yeah and the um owner mike
price um said that he can't have an
entree that's over 40 it's a
neighborhood you know like so many
places in america if you're a
neighborhood restaurant you have to keep
an eye on what people will spend and be
conscious of it so he had to take
scallops off the menu and he put in
halibut instead as an alternate high-end
protein so we met with hockey who owns a
couple of pizza restaurants including
one that sells one dollar slices to
students
he had to rate his kids college fund in
order to keep himself in business how
long can people do that for i mean if
you're not raising prices by a whole lot
and you are determined to stay in
business there's got to be a point which
they have to make a decision it's such a
scary scenario they're all hoping for
government they're hoping for government
support um during the pandemic there was
the restaurant revitalization fund and
there was a huge lobby effort going on
to get that reinstated or to access more
money for that and that's what so many
restaurants are hoping for hockey seemed
really passionate about this idea that
inflation was going to be transitory
that this was only going to be a
momentary issue and that things would
get better but
we talk all the time about how it's not
going to get better it's here to stay
i mean i think there's some i i think
that not every restaurateur is an
economist and so i think there's a lot
of like hopeful thinking that even if
the prices don't even if the prices
don't go all the way down to
pre-pandemic that you will see some
relief from this and the other thing
they're suffering from really badly is
labor shortage that's pushing up a lot
of prices on menus but i have to talk
about my important part of the meal
which is the cocktail i feel like my
cocktail glasses in the city at least
are hilarious they're like these teeny
tiny little baby glasses
what's up with that is the bar a hedge
against inflation i think well yes i
mean bars in general for restaurants are
um are a good money maker they make
because your profit margins on food are
much smaller usually it's in the single
digits or the low double digits because
you know things can get wasted it takes
like a lot more prep with a cocktail you
can just pour a couple ingredients in
and they have a much you know they have
a forever shelf life basically so um you
don't have to throw it out you don't
have to throw it out you can keep that
bottle of vodka for your espresso
martini like you've got it for a while
but um i have noticed that it seems to
be before the pandemic prices were going
a little bit crazy like it was no
surprise to see a 20-something dollar
cocktail you know whether you were in
new york or you were in houston now i
feel like there's a ceiling on the i i
think most cocktails i see are like 18
or 19
but they are shrinking
it's true
okay good to know i'm not making it
it's sometimes in your head but it's not
too much in your head if you can see it
how what does this mean in terms of uh
the ceiling for how high a price
restaurants can charge i mean you
mentioned that they're limited by their
clientele but it seems like in a city
where the rich are getting richer
because the markets are doing well the
economy is doing well overall people who
have jobs continue to hold on to their
jobs and get paid big bonuses how high
can they go in terms of charging people
food prices i i that is an excellent
question i think that like here in new
york there are um there's a big trend in
400 sushi counters and they are like
packed you know they're filled every
night and i don't know if there's that
many other cities that can absorb that
but i'm hearing about a new place in
atlanta that is going to have um sushi
that is over 200 a person so i think
it's i think that is actually the food
you know it used to be that you would
have these high-end french places and
those are sort of disappearing in the
continental places and now sushi has
become you know the sort of like elite i
don't want to say elite but has become
the food that people are like the pricey
food that they're like wow look at this
and you know it looks good on instagram
too kate thank you so much thank you
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
schafer
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillions etf masterchef only
on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11.
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
oh my gosh eating is so stressful now i
know whether you're going out or you're
eating at home everything's so expensive
oh my god yes exactly the substitutions
are a huge thing too i mean i just went
and got this cup of coffee guess how
much this cost me that little one yeah
uh five dollars yes okay yes i know and
it's tiny i did get oatmeal which i know
is a whole thing but like i think it
would cost that regardless right no i
really didn't anticipate that so it's
it's happening at the low end the high
end the middle i think about how even if
food prices start coming down like we
see gas prices go down and up as oil
prices change but
you'll see meat prices and you'll see
fruit prices change but right your box
of cereal probably is not going to go
down even if wheat prices start to come
down yeah because that's kind of baked
in already so it's it's sticky as
opposed to transitory meaning it's going
to stay around as opposed to be
temporary and that's got people feeling
less wealthy less rich and kind of down
on the economy even though by all
accounts everything's good it's like a
there's a psychological component to
this because i've found that i've sort
of created all these little mini food
buying rules for myself because of
inflation like i'm not allowed to order
in if i'm by myself that is a hard pass
i could
do that but i just psychologically i
feel like it's just morally wrong to
order like 30 worth of food for one
person like i just can't justify doing
that at all and throwing out food now
like gives me serious serious concerns
right i don't want to throw any food out
ever because it costs so much to bring
it into the house right like to get it
those blueberries were ten dollars like
we're going to use the blueberries yeah
yeah um and like you mentioned scar
there's
this is impacting everyone across the
country
food costs are dramatically increasing
um it's the first time since we started
that we've had to across the board rates
prices on our food and i just uh cringe
every time i i have to do that but we
have to
my name is katie plohake and i am the
executive director of the healthy
community store initiative i'm in charge
of fundraising and management with the
board of directors and also manage
day-to-day operations and relationships
with all of our community partners
the healthy community store initiative
is a group of programs that provide
underserved communities with access to
fresh foods and groceries the programs
include micro grocery stores mobile
markets and a community farm we are
located in north tulsa we
have a multi-faceted approach to
addressing healthy food access we run a
mobile grocery store we also have a farm
and a food hub and a commercial kitchen
and that all uh kind of inter-integrates
together to to ensure that
our clients have access to fresh food
19.4 of the population in tulsa oklahoma
lives below the poverty line that's
higher than the national average of 12.3
percent the pandemic has affected these
communities
and the access to food in several
different ways one food costs have
increased 26 since january with the
school shutdowns many of these single
parents
even parents that are married have been
unable to work because there's no child
care and then getting to groceries if
they don't have transportation 19 of our
households do not have a car
so
you know people are afraid to get on the
public bus
and be able to in riding to a grocery
store which round trip takes about four
hours well it's hard for me to get to a
grocery store and
he's my grocery store
other than a
dollar store you know
that's about the only two places i shop
because i can't get around good i don't
have a car
no way to get around with cost soaring
low-income americans who participate in
the supplemental nutrition assistance
program otherwise known as snap are once
again caught in a crunch last year the
biden administration announced it would
implement a permanent increase to snap
benefits the boost combined with an
emergency allotment in place since the
start of the pandemic was a huge relief
for the 42 million people who rely on
the program but in 2022 most states are
ending pandemic related emergency aid
which will substantially decrease the
amount of money that people receive
we're concerned that there's we're going
to see an increased need in food as
people get reduced amounts of food
stamps
to make matters worse most snap
recipients are exposed to the worst of
the us food system
more on healthy foods in stores and
fewer healthy foods that are financially
within reach and we've seen with the
pandemic that you know these vulnerable
populations that we work with we're even
more susceptible to
to health disparities as the cost of
food goes up what what do you eat
you go back to eating
hot dogs
and baloney that's what's cheap
and that's what's killing us our health
is going to to be affected by this
increase in food costs because people
are going to start eating
less fresh food and eating more
processed foods
people need to get used to the fact that
we're going to be paying more for food
going forward i mean i think about how
maybe technology might solve some of the
problems maybe we'll come up with more
plant-based meat and that might bring
some prices down and technology is
certainly one reason why inflation was
not really a problem for the last 10
years the automation of everything
prompted everyone to say inflation's
dead but clearly it's not the case and
something the federal reserve will think
about as they get ready to hike interest
rates a couple of times well i think
this all means i'm going to be using
this kitchen a lot more let's put it to
you then yes
chicken trauma from trader joe's you
know that's always the food of choice
[Music]
[Applause]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy
trillian's etf masterchef only on quick
take
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist alif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
coming up on quick take
have you ever been cruising on a highway
and wondered where the heck are all
those trucks going there's a
behind-the-scenes world of logistics
that makes virtually everything in our
modern lives possible
not only do we take it for granted we're
completely oblivious to its
environmental cost but thanks to a
handful of companies there's a hidden
revolution happening that as it turns
out is perfectly suited to delivering a
cleaner future
all this and more on quick take
[Music]
have you ever been cruising on a highway
and wondered where the heck are all
those trucks going
there's a behind-the-scenes world of
logistics that makes virtually
everything in our modern lives possible
[Music]
not only do we take it for granted we're
completely oblivious to its
environmental cost
but thanks to a handful of companies
there's a hidden revolution happening
that as it turns out is perfectly suited
to delivering a cleaner future
[Music]
for years online ordering and rapid home
delivery have been booming
and thanks to the pandemic this trend
has evolved into a way of life
but what actually happens when i click
that tempting button to buy let's say an
old school real hardcover book
for mighty amazon which tends to capture
the lion's share of all book sales
they're trucked along with other books
to one of several amazon inbound
fulfillment centers now the book is in
amazon's massive fulfillment network
copies then journey along the so-called
middle mile and can be redistributed to
any of the hundreds of smaller
warehouses or nodes closer to customers
and major population centers
the last step is the so-called last mile
how it gets to a buyer's home the book
might be sent to an amazon delivery
station and put in the back of a
mercedes sprinter van and dropped off by
amazon itself at the customer's front
door
this system while it's a marvel of
modern day logistics still relies mostly
on traditional combustion engine
vehicles for middle and last mile
delivery
as demand for rush delivery rises
so does the number of gas guzzling
trucks hustling between warehouses
environmentally it's one of the
biggest issues there is and you know the
quicker
that the globe can sort of decarbonize
transportation
the better it's going to be so if you
look at total greenhouse gas emissions
in the us about 28 of that is
transportation and of that chunk of the
28 percent about a quarter of it come
from medium and heavy-duty trucks so
middle mile and sort of long-haul
trucking if you really want to move the
needle on carbon emissions this is a
really good place to look
so how do we solve this growing
emissions problem and still satisfy our
addiction to same-day delivery
as it turns out the size shape and
predictable limited range of these
vehicles makes them the perfect
candidate for a solution
i'm dakota semler i'm the ceo and
co-founder of exos trucks so we are a
manufacturer of commercial electric
vehicles we manufacture trucks that are
in the class 5 size all the way up to
class 8 regional hall tractors and those
are things like the ups or fedex step
bands that you see delivering packages
every day
we actually started this because we were
fleet operators ourselves
we had a fleet of medium duty vehicles
and we saw how challenging it was
becoming to operate diesel vehicles
the technology exists to convert last
mile fleets from diesel to electric
batteries and and the prices of those
batteries have fallen dramatically in
the last 10 years and any routes that
are around 200 miles or less are really
ready to make that transition
so exos is trying to perfect the frame
of the car they call it the chassis so
this is everything is sort of
underpinning the car the electric motors
the battery pack all the battery
software and cooling and technology and
kind of the brains of the car if you
will and then
the business model is basically to sell
that and let the end consumer dictate
what goes on top
our platform we call the x platform ups
is using an x platform with a parcel
delivery van body on top of it loomis
who operates an armored car fleet uses
the same exact x platform but with an
armored body on top of it
exos is currently making their modular
battery packs here in los angeles and
the packs can be customized for specific
applications but while one big problem
vehicle cost is improving as battery
prices continue to fall
there's still another major hurdle at
the other end
the best way to describe the current
state of charting infrastructure in the
us is anemic these companies don't want
to build chargers unless they're
electric vehicles people don't want to
buy electric vehicles unless there's
chargers
that's a big problem for the personal ev
space where range anxiety is often cited
as a roadblock to mass adoption
but when it comes to delivery there's a
much simpler solution
when you think about last mile vehicles
they're not operating in different basis
of operation they actually return to the
same depot every single night where they
do their charging exos actually has a
division helping fleets install that
charging infrastructure
these fleets will actually bring their
vehicles back to the yard they charge
them overnight and then by the time
morning rolls around for their next
shift those vehicles are fully charged
ready to go with the infrastructure
that's on site
with pilot programs up and running with
delivery giants ups fedex and amazon
exos is quickly becoming a major
contender in the electrification game
but there's another enormous part of
this puzzle which may end up eliminating
more than just gasoline so i'm gotham
narang i'm the co-founder and ceo of
gatek
at gatek we do autonomous vehicles for
the middleman segment of the supply
chain again middle mile is one step back
from last mile trucking that goes from
one factory or warehouse to another
the middle mileage is evolving at a
rapid pace and with the pandemic the
middle mile segment of the supply chain
was put into high gear
the prominence and the significance of
the middle mile is only going to grow in
the coming years
so gadox is a really interesting company
what they're doing is trying to both
make middle mile delivery autonomous and
electric so they're trying to move the
ball in two ways here and what's really
interesting with them is they focus
specifically on certain sector of users
namely large companies that have very
fixed routes
just as the predictable routes of
shipping and delivery make
electrification easier they make
autonomy a lot easier too
if your trucks are going the same way
every single time like gothics
that's a much easier puzzle for an ai to
navigate so what they do
they find the route they need to run
and they agonize over it for four to six
weeks just mapping it inside and out
figuring out where all the trouble spots
might be and coding their vehicles
to deal with it and often it's not
they're not taking the most director out
they're taking the safest route they're
taking the route that's most predictable
in terms of traffic
there's a common understanding in the
industry that unprotected left turns and
doing multiple lane changes are some of
the most trickiest problems in the av
space with middle mile frankly you can
avoid all of that you can take three
right turns to make a left one you know
a bag of potatoes
won't care
fattick's ultimate goal is to provide a
cheaper cleaner alternative to the
middle mile of today by saving money on
gas and maintenance by electric motors
and saving money on well drivers by
going autonomous
they've already sold some major players
on their vision and scoring walmart as a
customer bodes well for the future
startups like gothic and exos are
betting that the delivery industry is
ready for a full-on high-tech refit
in a sector where only about one percent
of vehicles have been electrified
that's a lot of potential for change
you know the usual suspects are where
you're gonna
see adoption come first you know the
larger more stable companies so walmart
amazon
ups fedex etc
i think you'll see them experimenting
with it more and and the more routes
that they can get it to make sense on
that the faster adoption is going to be
and as the technology matures and
batteries continue to get cheaper
there's another huge category of
vehicles that's ripe for this kind of an
upgrade
so the binary administration has been
super aggressive about a pledge to
electrify the entire federal vehicle
fleet which is just under 700 000
vehicles what's interesting is the
federal fleet is both really old
and really inefficient the average age
of these cars and trucks about 14 years
and the average cost is about a dollar a
mile when you add up fuel and
maintenance and depreciation which are
the three big ones it's a good place to
look if you're looking
to get carbon out of the transportation
system
[Music]
while the most exciting and flashy
developments in the world of electric
vehicles are usually around personal evs
the more impactful transition is
happening behind the scenes
so the next time you order something
online
and it effortlessly appears on your
doorstep
your package might have made at least
some of its hidden journey without
consuming an ounce of gasoline
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
shirt first i'll be meeting chinese
artist and dissident ai weiwei and i'll
talk to the novelist and political
scientist elif shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com
webinars how worried should i be about
inflation as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillions etf
masterchef only on quick take
the hyperloop
there's a good chance you've heard the
name by now this is the hyperloop system
it can take people hundreds of miles and
minutes the hyperloop a series of tubes
that would transport people in pods at
ultra high speeds over long distances
it's a remarkable new form of
transportation that can whisk people
from city to city in a flash 29 minutes
from new york to dc 30 minutes from la
to san francisco
for years we've been seeing these
futuristic utopian renderings of some
cross between a spaceship and a monorail
but lately the hyperloop is becoming
much more real
it was surreal to be even sitting inside
a hyperloop and just even more
incredible to actually be like riding
down a track in something that was
nothing more than a crazy idea six years
before
companies all around the world have been
developing and testing the technology
needed to propel passengers at speeds of
over 1 000 kilometers per hour
but for many speed is only the first
step to unlocking the full
transformational effects of a new mode
of transportation fast is what we just
take for granted in the hyperloop world
it's the network effects that really
deliver the benefit and that opens up a
completely different scale of economic
opportunity
[Music]
we've got planes
trains
automobiles and boats we're getting
around earth
but what if there was a fifth mode and i
have a name for it name for it which is
called the hyperloop the hyperloop
hyperloop yeah
in 2013 while riding high on the growing
success of tesla and spacex
entrepreneur elon musk released a white
paper outlining the basic framework of
the technology he called hyperloop the
basic idea goes a little something like
this
a tube reduces the air pressure to a
near vacuum-like environment a hyperloop
pod is then suspended in the tube
usually by magnetic levitation the whole
pod can then be propelled forward
because there's no traditional friction
sources like air resistance or rolling
friction that would push back against
the pod the hyperloop is able to move at
incredibly high speeds and do so fairly
efficiently
despite its futuristic name however the
general concept behind hyperloop is
actually pretty old
in fact new york city's first attempt at
an underground public transit system in
the 1870s was based on a similar
principle
the pneumatic transit system was
short-lived however only stretching one
block and topping out at a rather
leisurely 10 miles per hour
while elon would make some 21st century
improvements to this concept and bestow
a very 21st century name
he wouldn't end up pursuing the
technology itself
instead electing to focus his efforts on
something a little bit deeper
literally digging the requisite tunnels
via his boring company
it would take another billionaire
industrialist who dabbles in space
flight
no wait not that one
yeah that's the one
after richard branson would make a large
investment in the company hyperloop one
it would be renamed to virgin hyperloop
what we've always been trying to do as a
company
is show that this technology could work
that it could be made safe and that
ultimately it's something that's
happening in the next couple of years
not the next 20 years
[Music]
josh geigel is the co-founder and ceo of
virgin hyperloop
in a familiar tech startup story he's
seen the project go from a garage to a
large-scale testing facility outside of
las vegas so we started building the
first kind of hyperloop system in 2016.
we've done a lot of work about 500 tests
that we've done on that over the last
five years
and what we realize that we need to do
is take that technology show that it can
be commercial so drive the cost down
improve the efficiency improve the
performance but the key thing is you
know is actually making it approachable
and safe for individuals
in order to do that josh along with
virgin's head of passenger experience
sarah lucian bravely volunteered to take
the inaugural ride what her and i were
realizing is like we're the first two
people sitting in a hyperloop the only
type of people that have gone through
this environment are in spacesuits and
there we are in just like normal clothes
because of the system the safety of what
we designed three
two
one
launch and then once we started going uh
you felt a bit of acceleration we
accelerated a little bit harder than we
would in commercial be like a sports car
we got to about 108 miles an hour on
that test
and it's a short run it's about 500
yards or so
and came to a stop
the test lasting only about 20 seconds
and covering only a quarter of a mile at
just over 100 miles per hour is a long
way away from a true functioning
hyperloop but as for optics it's a
crucial step for the future of funding
the number one question we got from
investors or from project proponents or
just people in general was like is a
hyperloop safe
and what better way to show something is
safe than by actually getting people on
it
but convincing investors and governments
that would likely be fronting some of
the construction costs for an unproven
technology is no easy task
first and foremost is the question of
safety most people don't know how an
airplane works but yet they get on an
airplane they get on an airplane because
you know it's faster than driving and
most importantly they've probably gotten
off of one before they've seen someone
get off of one before
and so what we set out to do was
actually show that hyperloop could be
safe with two normal people not
astronauts not adrenaline junkies or
test pilots or anything like that to
normal people getting on a hyperloop and
then most importantly those two people
getting off
but beyond safety concerns constructing
hyperloops will undoubtedly require a
significant capital investment to the
estimated tune of around 60 million us
dollars per kilometer of track so a
track from san francisco to los angeles
for example is likely to come with a
price tag over 10 billion
and before large governments are willing
to come in and front those costs
investors who are funding hyperloop
development must accept it as a
long-term mixture of technology and
infrastructure investing investors that
are used to short returns because you're
developing apps or something to that
effect you know those aren't the
investors that really get excited about
hyperloop what you start to see is the
people that are looking at platform
technologies right so this idea that
because the smartphone existed
uber could exist right so who are like
the vanderbilts of this century and
that's the part where you're going to
get a lot more no's than yeses
but those people that have the ability
that the fortitude to stick it out to
see the game changing platform here
those are the people that we're looking
for
and since we've done that passenger test
there has been a lot of interest that's
really oh this is a lot sooner than i
thought
[Music]
envisioning the ripple effects of what
hyperloop could achieve though is fairly
challenging at this stage of development
it's fast yes but for point-to-point
travel traditional maglev trains can
move pretty fast as well
and outside of china south korea and
japan even those haven't seen much
adoption elsewhere due to the high costs
and questionable profitability
the shanghai line in china for example
loses around 100 million dollars every
year
hyperloop companies however believe they
can offer something different than
traditional railway lines
my name's alan james
and as far as i know
i'm the only guy on the planet who's
written a government government-level
business case for
300 kmh conventional high-speed rail
500 kmh maglev and thousand kmh
hyperloop
[Music]
it's fundamentally about moving people
from where they are to where they want
to go
when they want to make those journeys
and doing it in much smaller numbers so
pod designs for hyperloop range from 12
to 28 seats typically
why are they small
it's because small enables the network
to operate flexibly
and a great example of that is the
east-west strategic route across the
north of england from liverpool to
manchester to leeds
so to get from liverpool via manchester
to leeds by train is just short of two
hours today it'll probably take you two
hours driving as well in average traffic
conditions
net result is those three city regions
remain three separate entities liverpool
manchester leeds there's very little
commuting traffic between those
urban areas
hyperloop absolutely changes that
from the ground up
liverpool to manchester is a five or six
minute journey manchester to leeds is
also a five or six minute journey
what that effectively does is create a
single super city economy
in this vision the hyperloop acts a
little more like a highway where pods
have fixed destinations and don't need
to stop along the way meaning you can
travel on a hyperloop network from say
liverpool to leeds while the pod behind
you travels from liverpool to manchester
and if that metro hyperloop network is
connected to other networks from the
same location you could travel from
liverpool to paris or liverpool to
amsterdam all without making a single
stop
for passengers
for business
for leisure that is utterly
transformational
for high value freight and logistics
it's equally transformational
but critically
if you do a hyperloop network at scale
you begin to deliver
massively significant carbon savings too
a multi-regional hyperloop network could
become a replacement for both short-haul
passenger and cargo flights and
traditional ground transportation both
of which are significant carbon
producers
one hyperloop connected distribution hub
perhaps at an airport that is
predominantly used for international air
freight
replacing maybe 10 12 15 distributed
road hubs
it takes a lot of polluting and
inefficient truck haulage off the roads
that itself
means roads gain extra capacity
hyperloops will still need to use
electricity to both move pods and
maintain the near vacuum environment in
the tube
proponents of the technology believe
that this can be done by using renewable
sources including a combination of solar
panels and battery technology that could
be used along the hyperloop itself
but even with all multipliers of time
and carbon emission savings that a
hyperloop network may provide the
investment capital required to actually
build such a network becomes even more
economically and politically daunting
committing doesn't mean spending
billions on day one
committing means
how do we phase it
[Music]
one company in the netherlands is
working to develop that technology and
perhaps more importantly the
international coalition needed to make
the hyperloop network a reality
so we are here in europe's first
full-scale hybrid test facility where we
can already prove every conceptual
technology of the hyperloop
this is tim howder a co-founder and ceo
of heart hyperloop headquartered in the
city of delft
and while this testing tube might not
seem as large as others inside is a key
technology to create the on and off-ramp
type infrastructure of a hyperloop
network that is a lane switch that's
something we can already test here you
can actually see it here
the track is diverging from one track
into two that makes it possible to
eventually split up the high group track
in two sections and in that sense you
can create a complete hybrid network
that in the end will make it possible to
travel for example over over a whole
continent and take europe for example
with the same ease as you can now travel
with a metro in a city
the nice thing about this magnetic
levitation system that we have developed
is that there's absolutely zero moving
components in the track
so for example if you have to do a lane
switch
all you do is that the tube basically
splits up
and statically the tracks also split up
and whenever the vehicle enters a switch
it either pulls itself to the right with
its magnets or pulls itself to the left
with it magnets
lane switching on traditional rail
requires the physical movement of the
rail
even modern magnetic levitation tracks
use lane switching techniques in order
to transfer trains from one track to
another and this is a very crucial
element because this is the
thing that limits the capacity
and in the end the usefulness of the
real network
because the moment that a track is
switching that means that at that moment
you are creating an unsafe environment
for the trains behind it so you need a
lot of space between trains in a
hyperloop because you have no moving
components in the track all the vehicles
can be much closer to each other you can
achieve a very high frequency and
basically have vehicles moving and
merging in and out of the network very
much like a highway
for now though hart's physical testing
has been limited by the size of their
tube because the test track is only 30
meters long they haven't tested this
lane switch at speeds greater than 20
kilometers per hour however the company
is working to build a new test site
where it plans to increase that testing
speed to 300 kilometers per hour we're
now in a phase where we have proven most
of the most important technologies
in the test facilities that we already
have
and we have also demonstrated the
viability and the feasibility of a
network
if you look at all the top systems that
it consists of most of those are proven
systems already demonstrated in lab
conditions so we don't really believe
that the technology itself is going to
be the biggest challenge
because for all hyperloop companies out
there actually building a hyperloop
system requires more than just a good
product we're talking about the safety
aspects we're talking about integration
into the environment we're talking about
the social aspects do people feel
comfortable traveling in such a system
so it's about all these different
aspects
and the complexity is really getting all
the different stakeholders that are
relevant
and that the needs to
contribute to bring this to market
to get them all
following the same roadmap
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio
what's your favorite ticker it's the
best ticker ever it really kind of
captures the themes what you're trying
to always deliver is a very simple
solution and if you can deliver that
simple solution powerfully i think that
resonates quite well in the market tell
us about this portfolio where is that
spice going to come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillions etf masterchef only
on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
in order to help build this coalition of
private and public interest in hyperloop
development hart in 2018 partnered with
other hyperloop companies from europe
and canada the goal was to define
establish and standardize the framework
to regulate hyperloop systems right now
we are working with all the hyperloop
developers together in setting up the
first
let's say a structure for the for
starting the standards drafting
one of the most important goals for
heart is interoperability
which is essentially making sure the
different systems can communicate with
each other interoperability is so
important because what we want to
achieve is actually have this seamless
travel experience so you don't want to
end up for example
going from madrid to paris and then
switching because you need to use a
different technology to
get for example to amsterdam
the idea being that as companies around
europe create the first commercial
hyperloop tracks between individual
cities one day those can all be
connected to a larger network everyone
that believes that hyperloop is a future
transport system also realizes that
there is a need to have this network
because that's where a hyperloop thrives
hyperloop is such a huge project it's
definitely not something that you can do
in your own or as a single company so
you need to do it with a lot of other
companies you need to have the
governments i think in that sense the
biggest challenge that we've encountered
is to really get all the required
parties together to take the steps in
development and in commercial
implementation
[Music]
hart's next plan is to build the
european hyperloop center an open
testing facility which will include a
2.6 kilometer test track and the company
hopes to test travel speeds there at up
to 700 kilometers per hour
virgin hyperloop is also racing to
construct the first commercial hyperloop
route with projects in various states of
development in india saudi arabia and
the united states
recently the company announced plans to
build a hyperloop certification center
in west virginia which will include a
six mile long test track
proving the technology here will be
crucial if hyperloop networks can find a
home among infrastructure investments
that the biden administration hopes to
make the idea that there's multiple
hyperloop companies i think is a
redeeming aspect in the business people
really want to see something happen so
having multiple people move forward
is is good for that
i was struck
when
josh and sarah rode the pod two or three
of the major outlets use the phrase we
now have a new mode of transport and
although all of that technology had
existed before those two human beings
rode it yeah
it was the moment at which those two
human beings traveled that short
distance down the tube that in popular
imagination hyperloop became a mode of
transport the metaphor i use with my
team is that you know the wright
brothers were first but none of us fly
on wright brothers airlines anymore
if you don't continue to innovate you're
not going to be around and so we'll
continue to be at the forefront of
building our blue
back in 2013 elon had an idea
i think the difference now in 2021 is
some brilliant engineers have spent real
time
grinding out the details
and i thoroughly expect the next three
to five years to be decisive
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
if you haven't noticed lately we're
living in the future
technology that was only imaginable in
science fiction is now so mundane that
we practically take it for granted
but there's still one thing that's
conspicuously absent from our futuristic
present where are the flying cars
i was promised flying cars i don't see
any flying cars why why why
the one thing that both utopian and
dystopian visions of our future have
seemed to agree on is that by now we'd
be flying around our cities but for the
vast majority of us who don't happen to
own private helicopters we still mostly
move around at or below ground level
often stuck in congestion
but over the last decade a growing cadre
of bootstrapping startups and industry
stalwarts have been raising and spending
oodles of money on a new mode of
transportation known as urban air
mobility
could these autonomous human ferrying
super drones finally be the flying cars
that we've been waiting for
i think there are two things that are
driving the
[Music]
investment and the attention to the
sector the fact that people are moving
to cities and cities are getting more
congested and urban dwellers don't want
to own cars so anything that can move an
urban dweller from a to b is interesting
to investors we saw it with micro
mobility solutions we saw it with share
mobility solutions the next natural step
is shared aviation solutions
the concept of urban air mobility isn't
totally new for decades helicopters have
been a means for those with means to
hover and glide over traffic in major
urban centers like new york san
francisco and sao paulo
past attempts to turn helicopters into a
form of mass transit however have been
grounded mostly by the inevitable
problems of helicopter technology
noise inefficiency and danger
thanks to these issues many cities have
either limited or banned helicopter
transit outright
except for limited use such as in
emergencies
but imagine a future in which instead of
driving your own car or hopping on a
city bus or subway or taxi you could cut
your transit time significantly by
booking a flight on a sleek safe and
relatively quiet electric-powered drone
or e-vtol short for electric vertical
takeoff and landing if we
look at just 0.1
of the americans that are driving in
their cars from work to home and we
assume that's going to be our
addressable market
we're talking about 100 000 passengers a
year more or less need to be moved
if we assume that these aircraft can
carry about four to five people
and they're doing four to five trips a
day
we would need roughly five thousand of
these aircraft so that gives you a sense
of the massive opportunity we have here
given this potential market the field is
unsurprisingly very crowded
there are over 180 companies developing
some type of a veto
a lot of them are drone developers so
it's all about scale if i can build a
small version i should be able to scale
it to a larger version
one of these drone turned mega companies
is ihang a chinese firm founded in 2014
that has already earned a spot on nasdaq
from the very beginning we designed
big drones
to carry passengers right and second you
can see that for normal drones the
technology is one-on-one that means we
need one person to control each drone
but for us we design the system to
control many multiple
aavs simultaneously by using one single
platform
ehong recently secured approval from the
korean government to perform test
flights over seoul showing off the
company's prototype during the recent
three-hour tour although ehong is
designing its remote control prototype
to fit applications ranging from medical
evacuations to sightseeing it's this
so-called last 10-mile problem that
seems to be the most ripe for disruption
for example if you take
take a train to arrive in beijing right
the train uh takes about one or two
hours right and after the train if you
take a taxi you know it takes another
one hour or even two hours to go to the
destination which doesn't make any sense
but if you can transfer
uh our av
right it takes maybe 15 minutes to
arrive at the at the your destination
that's very
cool meanwhile on the other side of the
globe a german company called volocopter
has spent the last decade or so
designing a fleet of prototypes that
have recently been flying in
demonstrations over cities both at home
and abroad
we are extremely pragmatic we set out to
build a vehicle that can meet the high
safety standards that can be certified
based on existing technologies that are
available today
what came out is the volocopter we
explicitly designed it as a multi-copter
concept so we have you know
18 independent rotors that give us a
very high degree of redundancy so any
two any three rotors can fail and we can
still safely complete our mission which
gives us a huge safety advantage over
any other concept
and particularly on the urban mission
where it's about you know safely
transporting people from a to b in an
urban context
as quiet as possible we believe the
multicultural concept is the winning
design for that particular mission there
may be other missions that require
different design concepts
volocopter's ambitious plans have
attracted interest from a number of
large companies hailing from other
sectors of the transportation world
such as chinese auto giant geely
germany's daimler and most recently
japan airlines all of whom have
participated in funding rounds for
volacopter that have raised well over
100 million euros so far
of all the companies currently working
on ev tolls volacopter seems to be the
furthest along and committing to a
launch date already taking reservations
for flights beginning as soon as 2023 at
an introductory price of around 300
euros
but the main hurdle that could disrupt
that timeline isn't merely a technical
one this is a very safety critical you
know transportation mode and you need to
make sure that you have all relevant
stakeholders involved so we are really
relying on the buying of the regulators
and you know gaining their trust so we
always talk to them and be like okay do
we have an alignment of vision do we
have the civil aviation authority on
board do we have the airspace manager on
board you need to make sure that you
have alignment because any one of those
stakeholders can block you from
ultimately you know achieving your goal
part of the added challenge in gaining
regulatory approval for civilian
carrying ev tolls
is that the standards issued by
regulatory agencies are evolving in
tandem with the technology itself
they have to be
air worthy these aircraft
they're going to be running on batteries
and batteries need to be also approved
as safe enough to be in an aircraft for
this particular application
[Music]
volocopter ehong and other well-heeled
eevee tallers such as lilium and joby
are each taking a slightly different
approach to engineering an all-electric
passenger drone
some of the designs are more of a hybrid
between an ev tall and a small plane
capable of both navigating a dense urban
environment and flying long distances at
up to almost 200 miles per hour
and while some of the engineering
solutions for challenges like battery
capacity are pretty innovative such as
volocopter's hot swapping charging
stations
any eeveetol's viability ultimately
comes down to proving its safety in a
variety of conditions and scenarios
so assuming that evtol technology
eventually passes those regulatory
hurdles that still leaves a very
important question about this untested
market
who exactly are these for
if we look at elon musk's master plan
the first iteration in 2006 he was very
clear he said he was going to build an
expensive car to help paying for a less
expensive car to help pay for a mass
market car
so i think we're going to see something
quite similar in this specific segment
where companies will be offering the
service to high-end consumers
but in the end that will subsidize the
technology so that everybody can access
it in the long term
mass adoption of urban air mobility
though
might pose its own potential issues once
the product trickles down and more
people start using it we fear it might
actually cannibalize users from public
transit in cities which will have
negative consequences in our view
mainly because it will just shift
congestion from the road up into the sky
before we get to that point though these
companies face yet another technical
challenge integrating urban air mobility
into the existing transportation
landscape on this front uber has taken
advantage of their own learned
experience building a revolutionary ride
sharing platform to bring their
technology into a third dimension and
they're not even waiting for ev tolls to
get started
back in the quaint pre-pandemic days of
late 2019
i gave their uber copter service a
whirlpool
all right we're on road to jfk
yeah i can take this to work every day
we're really thinking of this as kind of
a version 0.1 of our vision of this
future uber air product the key thing
what we think is the the important
learning that we are developing right
now
is this foundational feature kind of
this core core experience of
multi-modalities so true multi-modality
so we're with a single button press for
the product we dispatched the first mile
car the helicopter and the last mile car
bi-directionally from downtown to jfk
and
and we're using our technology to do
that all behind the scenes
admittedly it's extremely satisfying to
fly above new york city's snarling rush
hour traffic and plop down on the
landing pad at jfk airport within 10
minutes where our car is waiting to
shuttle you directly to your terminal
but even uber understands that once the
novelty wears off it needs to make
economic sense in order for customers to
adopt it
the economics of these vehicles will
allow us to push and bring it to be a
much more accessible product that a
broad a broad base of users can use on a
daily basis we actually think the
long-term vision we can actually get to
the point where flying um in in these
types of aerial networks can be
competitive with driving your car with
owning a car in terms of like the
marginal cost of ownership it's not
going to happen right away it's not even
going to happen in the medium term but
we think in the long run that we can
actually make flying
in this type of a fashion kind of a
economically rational thing for most
people to do every day
despite the sleek renderings of swanky
rooftop teleports and city skylines
buzzing with ev tolls
the commercial case for urban air
mobility is still up in the air
putting pressure on the company's vine
for viability
given the complexities of the solution
the complexities of the regulation
we do not expect to see
a very diverse ecosystem in the long
term we rather expect to see
a few a handful of developers of
manufacturers working with a handful of
service providers
and that consolidation seems to already
be underway
in late 2020 uber handed off its
ambitious elevate project to joby the
current ev tall valuation king with
nearly 1 billion dollars to its name so
far
boeing and airbus seem to be stepping
back from their experiments as well
some of the smaller startups have
vanished entirely leaving behind expired
domain names and silent crunch base
profiles
so as the field narrows the technology
matures and the regulations are ironed
out
you may someday find that this perennial
sci-fi fantasy
could become another mundane option for
getting around
the way that we envision this to play
out is ultimately the customer whether
it's a citizen in the city or a visitor
to the city you know has their mobile
phone has a mobility need and he just
gets a choice of different
transportation modes each you know comes
with a price point with a uh
comfort point to it and and a
predictability point to it and then he
chooses whatever is the best format for
him and obviously we're working very
hard to make your choice as often as
possible
[Music]
printing in progress
please stand clear
printing
assembling navigation system
energizing flux capacitor
installing artificial intelligence
your vehicle is ready
[Music]
for a hundred years we've been making
vehicles pretty much the same way
the assembly line
and it's efficient a large modern
factory can roll out thousands of
vehicles per day
but it isn't very flexible when it comes
to changing designs very often
[Music]
here in knoxville tennessee a company
called local motors is taking a
different approach
have they discovered the way of the car
making future
that's what i'm here to find out
[Music]
so is this the biggest 3d printer in the
world
as far as i know yes as of this moment
this is the world's largest commercial
large-scale additive manufacturing
machine can you explain how something's
actually made with this machine yeah
certainly
whatever it is that you you want to make
what we do is put it into a program
that's the instruction set that tells
the machine what to do and where to go
and based on that pattern we deposit
material
and in a layer by layer fashion you
start building up your shape
[Music]
local motors prints the chassis of its
vehicles out of a composite material
that's about as hard as a traditional
metal car body once it cools
and then if you really want it to be
very precise then you can come back in
and you can machine it you can take that
material off and get those precise edges
those hard contours and shapes
about how long does something take to
make
something like a vehicle chassis takes
about nine hours
stick on a few non-3d printed items like
wheels and headlights and the result is
one of the company's sleek looking
all-electric cars
the company gets its vehicle designs
through a sort of crowdsourcing process
in which engineers from all around the
world submit designs and competition for
cash prizes and royalties on the
finished car
so if i had a design i wanted to bring
and have you guys print like how
detailed does that design need to be you
just need the basic cad model your
computer aided design and we can work
from there
we can take this one machine and we can
change what it produces very easily
because that's just done in a computer
file
when i hear 3d printer i usually think
about the makerbot style desktop
machines that were all the rage in the
early 2010s when it seemed like everyone
was going to have a 3d printer in their
house within a few years
in reality though the major advances in
adoption and 3d printing have been
happening behind the scenes
used for applications ranging from
building houses in developing countries
to printing living human tissue
it's morphed into a 10 billion dollar
industry that's projected to more than
triple by 2024
but back in 2014 when local motor ceo
jay rogers first started trying to 3d
print entire cars things were a little
different
3d printing had been used to make
individual car parts but printing an
entire car body was another question
entirely
there were far many more naysayers than
there were supporters people who said it
can't be done or it shouldn't be done
no one had ever done it
nothing to my knowledge had ever been
done at that scale right so it was less
about the fact that it was a car more
about the fact that it was larger and 3d
printed
faced with a daunting engineering
challenge local motors reached out to
oak ridge national laboratory a
knoxville based government facility that
was instrumental in the creation of the
first atomic bomb
they were developing giant 3d printers
and they agreed to help local motors
make the first 3d printed car ever
live at an international trade show in
full public view
we said let's 3d print the first vehicle
in the world and assemble it and drive
it off the show floor right there that
was the goal
it was very nervous making because we
were getting close by the time we went
to the show but we were still failing in
some of the prints and so we were very
nervous that we would get to the show
and fail
how did it go it was successful
[Applause]
and this is the result
lestrade
how you doing driving by the way i love
this it's pretty simple right man it's
like second nature
it's smooth i mean it's somewhere in
between a golf cart and like a dune
buggy you know i mean it's nimble you're
so low to the ground that you just feel
very stable yeah
we had limitations so like our roll bar
that's back here as you'll note it's a
little shorter than my head because the
printer wasn't at the time capable to go
up higher what would you say the top
speed is of this configuration i think
this configuration should be 25 miles an
hour i don't know what would you say
does it feel like we're zipping along i
feel like we could hit about 25 yeah it
feels about right
maybe on a downhill 30. yeah
the strategy proved that a 3d printed
car was possible
but as a car there wasn't much to it and
it's never really been commercialized
the company's first 3d printed
production vehicle the ollie is a bit
more interesting
ali is a electric connected self-driving
3d printed vehicle
it's a cute little box in japanese it
would be called a hako
and it is meant to driverlessly deliver
people to places around a campus
a few ollies have already made it out
into the world like here at national
harbor just outside washington dc
they can run completely autonomously on
a fixed route though a human still rides
along to take over when the ai can't
figure out exactly what to do
so right now are we in autonomous mode
no no we're in autonomous mode so right
now we're in a geofence fixed route kind
of environment in the future we could do
uh dynamic routing where people could
actually call the alley um it's just
similar to an uber or lyft
what happens if like someone steps into
the middle of the crosswalk or something
well
yeah so obviously if the vehicle
perceives the pedestrian or cyclist
stepping in the vehicle will stop
so for example right now it just saw
that vehicle and it gave it the
right-of-way right so it understands
what obstacles are there and then how to
avoid them
it's amazing how quickly it feels like
totally natural like i just don't even
think about it anymore you know you
haven't turned around the whole time
right have you checked the driver like
he's still awake doesn't matter right
yes
do you like driving i mean would you
miss it if it all became autonomous i
think there is a
set of people that will always want to
drive but i think in the future you will
have
vehicles that are allowed to be driven
on
certain tracks for specially licensed
and trained people and then the rest of
us will all
drive in a connected automated shared
mobility solution
whether you think that future sounds
amazing or appalling it's probably the
general direction things are headed
the trickier question is what role 3d
printing plays in that future
for local motors the main advantage is
that it makes developing and retooling
vehicles much faster than before
traditional manufacturing is five to
seven years from a decision to build a
vehicle to see the first product come
out we are 12 months total to a sellable
product so we are at a minimum we're
five times faster
that increased speed means local motors
could update or customize its vehicles
much more easily than a traditional car
maker can
in fact they already have a ton of ideas
for future designs for the ollie some of
which are pretty unorthodox like mobile
grocery stores mobile conference rooms
post offices and even a mobile podcast
studio
and locomotors isn't the only auto
company using 3d printing
it's been adopted by larger auto
manufacturers such as ford and bmw where
it's been used for prototyping new parts
and even creating discontinued parts for
classic cars
[Music]
it's come in particularly useful in
aviation too where companies like ge and
honeywell are using 3d printed parts to
reduce the weight of airplane engines
but before you get too excited 3d
printing isn't likely to replace
traditional factories anytime soon
there's still a major drawback
volume
what it doesn't do is things very
quickly so if i wanted to make 100 000
of something this probably wouldn't be
my process you'd want to you know maybe
scale and do something else
add in the time it takes to assemble the
rest of the vehicle and you're looking
at only about one ollie per day from
this factory
the company plans to boost production by
building dozens more of these so-called
micro factories all over the world
but for now they only have this one in
knoxville
[Music]
still there is an undeniable power and
the ability to make basically anything
you can imagine
in fact i've already started designing
my fantasy vehicle
so local motors when you're ready to
make me a flying car with afterburners
and let's say an espresso maker give me
a call
i'll be waiting
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
i think one of the things that you can
say about me is i never when i was broke
i didn't let my my bank account define
me and right when i'm not broke i'm not
gonna let my bank account to find me i
am you know i'll try to be my own person
and just my friends are my friends that
that never changed my pittsburgh friends
are still my my great friends you know
my college friends my rugby friends all
the different segments of my life
they're still my guys
what's going on what up tv not a thing
how you doing good man thanks for having
me man i appreciate you my pleasure
appreciate you coming through absolutely
um so to start it off uh
tell us who you are
oh my goodness um grew up in pittsburgh
pennsylvania um born in squirrel hill
moved to the south hills birdland um and
then mount lebanon and um
my dad did upholstery on cars my mom did
odd jobs just just a normal kid man that
just happened to
be have an aptitude for business from as
long as i can remember was was it one of
your dreams like as a kid like i know i
was in the backyard man my brother
was trying to be michael jordan and
scottie pippen uh i was mj of course but
uh like was it a dream of yours to own
an nba team no hell no
yeah i honestly it wasn't until i tried
to buy the mavs that even crossed my
mind really like yeah when i was a kid
you know i played sports not very well
but yeah i wanted to be earl of pearl
monroe i had to move and everything and
a baseball salem state university by the
way exactly exactly
i never really thought that i would ever
be in a position to own anything man i
just wanted to have a good life and try
to find my way to college so now
you know all these things that you've
done in life all this stuff that's been
a part of your journey tell us a little
bit about what that was like like what
it was like growing up and um in
pittsburgh you know my mom was really
young when she had me she was 20 and so
you know in hindsight i realized how
little my parents really knew right
because they were just young
but my dad would just get up and go to
work and he was he neither one of them
went to college and they were like you
guys i have two younger brothers brian
and jeff like you guys are going to
college and we're going to figure it out
because education is important
and you've got to find your own path and
he was always pushing me and both my
parents were pushing me to to be
independent
and
however it started i don't know from the
time i was nine ten years old i was
hustling i was i was one of those kids
that was always selling something yeah
yeah like i was selling baseball cards
right i would go buy baseball cards and
then i'd flip them right get as many you
know get good at flipping packages then
i'd go down to the park where we would
pick up play pick up or whatever there
would be this bench that was there and i
would just sit there and repackage um
baseball cards and i'd say okay there's
definitely one pittsburgh pirate in one
of these right you might get roberto
clemente you might get willy stargeon
and i'd mark him up and make some money
and you know and that's how i'd get
spending money and i remember one day my
dad was playing poker
i was like dad i need a new pair of
converse right and he's like i see those
you know those shoes on your feet they
still work right and i'm like yeah he's
like well when you have a job you can
buy whatever you want but until then
those shoes still work and i'm like dad
i can't get a job i'm 12 years old and
one of his poker buddies speaks up and
goes yeah i got a job for you i'm like
what he goes i've got these boxes of
garbage bags and you can go sell them
around the neighborhood and i'm like
cool like boxes and boxes of garbage
bags right so literally i would go to
our neighbors and i go
hi i'm your neighbor mark do you use
garbage bags you sound like a shark tank
yeah right yeah exactly and of course
everybody uses garbage bags never forget
they cost me three bucks for a box of a
hundred i would sell them for six bucks
and i would just take them to them every
couple weeks right whenever they needed
more garbage bags and i'm making 20
bucks a week which was like
big time i got my shoes and you know but
that taught me to be confident and that
taught me that i could sell and that
taught me that selling was helping not
convincing you know because once i
figured out that everybody needed
garbage bags then it really became
obvious to me that
if i can find things that people needed
right and wanted and i could do it a
better way than what they were doing it
then i could make some money and that's
kind of stayed with me i was just about
to say it's crazy how you was thinking
about that at 12 and everything you just
said basically translates to everything
you're basically doing now in life yeah
exactly i mean because that's what it's
all about i mean you know selling isn't
convincing somebody to do something they
don't want to do selling is
understanding what chris paul needs and
then finding a way to provide it in a
better way than what they're doing now
you make it sound way too easy but it's
not as hard as it sounds right but most
you know it's like basketball right
there's a lot of guys that maybe we're
more talented than you right right one
thing i know and respect about you and
the few times we've talked like you talk
about you know doing the work
right getting on synergy sports which i
was excited about because the company i
had helped get going right and invested
them and always watching the place
knowing the other teams plays you know
when they call them out so you know
what's going to happen being able to
guide business is the exact same way
most people don't put in the work
business is the exact same way you know
i have all these corny sayings practice
too you can't get it wrong how you do
anything is how you do everything yeah
yeah i just still to this day try to
remind myself of these things all the
time for you you started college in
pittsburgh yeah and then went to indiana
yeah why
when i was 16 i decided i wanted to take
college classes at night just to see if
i was as smart as i thought i was
and so so at 16 you were what uh junior
junior in high school yeah you just
started taking college yeah so i just
said what the hell right i'll just take
these classes and i took a psychology
class and did good in it and
then i wanted to um
take a business class at my high school
mount lebanon high school
and they wouldn't let me do that and so
i'm like
well then i'm just going to go to
college right so i dropped out of high
school didn't go back for my senior year
and went to the university of pittsburgh
but they didn't have a real business
school back then i decided i wanted to
go to business school saw a list of the
top 10 undergraduate business schools
and indiana was the cheapest and got in
and had never seen the campus didn't
visit none of that stuff just went sight
unseen and turned out okay
you graduated from indiana what was your
dream job
well i was i wanted to start my own
company at some level right so all
through indiana i had all kinds of side
hustles because i pretty much had to pay
for my own college and so whether it was
party promoting my freshman and
sophomore years to um having a chain
letter to pay for my junior year
to um
opening up a bar that was like the hot
spot on campus my senior year until we
got busted for letting all my friends in
because
i just turned 21 you know so i was a
hustler a bunch of my buddies had come
down to dallas
and they were like you got to come down
is that what got you to texas yeah yeah
a bunch of my buddies were down here and
they're like look the weather's good the
economy is really starting to hop um and
the women are hot i'm like i didn't hear
the first two i'm like i'm coming boom
right i'm going away three bedroom
apartments five other roommates so six
of us live in a three bedroom apartment
i was in last so i was the guy who
didn't have his own room didn't have his
own closet on the floor
couch right or some you know buddies
were out i'm taking their bed so that's
where i got started in dallas and i got
a job working as a bartender at night
and then finally got a job um
in the computer industry and that's
really where i realized okay i really
like these computers and i mean i have
an aptitude for it and this this is it
i'm going for it so when i say
broadcast.com yes i mean
[Laughter]
right
when it comes to crypto and blockchain
and stuff how do you feel about that i
think it's a guy they're a big part of
the future i really really do but i
think people are looking at the wrong
way
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world bloomberg
[Music]
so when i say broadcast.com what is that
menu
ching
[Laughter]
right yeah i don't think people realize
what it was all about though um because
it's been so long now i sold my first
company micro solutions in 1989 um 1990
i guess when it closed
and retired just took time off party
like a rock star
and would get together with one of my
indiana buddies todd wagner and one day
he's sitting down it's you know late
1994 early 95 and he's like look this
new internet thing there's got to be a
way that we can use it to listen to
indiana basketball because we're in
dallas and you know this is before
you could get it with directv or cable
or whatever right and i'm like okay let
me see if i can figure it out because my
first company i would write software
taught myself the right software did
networking wider so it was a perfect fit
to figure it out so i bought a packer
bell computer put into the second
bedroom my house connected a radio to it
and we just started working with
different software didn't write all the
software but wrote enough to get it up
and running next thing you know we
started this website called audionet
worked with the local radio station
kliff i set up
and a vcr an old school vcr next to
their radio station i would record it
take the vcr tapes encode it put it on
the server in the second better in my
house and then just email and go online
and tell as many people look if you want
to listen to dallas sports and stuff
come to the site called audionet.com
blew up immediately three years later it
turned into broadcast.com we added video
we went public it was the biggest i
first aip in the history of the stock
market at the time and we were youtube i
mean literally hundreds of internet
radio stations hundreds of radio
stations
tv stations you know streaming like we
went and got the rights to um north
carolina basketball we were showing
online michael jordan mixtapes once you
get that it's a wrap yeah right so we
would just we just blew up and then
yahoo came along and bought us and paid
us um
i think was 5.7 billion dollars in stock
not in cash so then i had to protect my
the stock that i got because you know
fortunately i did i did this thing
called hedging and it protected me when
the whole internet bubble burst and
that allowed me to turn it into cash and
then a couple weeks later i was trying
to buy the mavs yeah so on to that on to
that so all of the stuff that you were
doing in technology computers and
everything like that
why the mavericks well i was a season
ticket holder right but i've been going
to mavs games since i got to dallas um
but in the 90s they were really bad and
literally you could buy a ticket
upstairs and just walk down and sit in
the front row right because there was
nobody there and even though we were
awful it was the start of the 99 2000
season i was there with my girlfriend
now wife
and
the place wasn't sold out you know and
so you're a season ticket holder 99 2000
yeah right and where are your seats at
my seats are right by the mavs bench
where you sit
close closer yeah a little bit yeah two
rows back
i was into it right and then there was
nobody there and i remember
yeah there was nobody there right nobody
it was opening night and the place
wasn't sold out and this was in the old
reunion arena and i'm like i can do a
better job than this right then it hit
me ding ding ding now i could afford
this stuff right right right you know so
my my i talked to my ticket rep a guy
named mark who then connected me to mark
mcguire and mark aguirre was working for
ross perot jr who was the owner then and
he connected me together and the season
started like beginning november end of
october by january 4th um so only six
weeks later give or take
i owned the mavs
what yeah no no no no talent you rewind
you don't just sit at the game and then
six weeks later pretty much on the death
i like that and what's what's crazy for
me is around then i was 16 years old 16
17 years old and i'm a high school
basketball player and i
i'm telling you man like my senior year
in high school even like when i was a
freshman at wake like i loved everything
dirk yo yeah everything jerk was the bed
yeah i used to like turn my feet in on
my free throws you remember when dirk
used to shoot free throws like this yeah
a little knock kneed yeah yeah yeah i
used to do that for a little while what
not just so i could shoot like dirt and
i tell you even to sit here and have
this conversation is so crazy because i
i remember when you bought the team
and i saw you like this
right seriously i think at some point we
all thought that someone buying a team
or something had to have a suit on and
all this different type stuff and to see
you today the same way you weren't in i
think says a lot you've always genuinely
been a fan of not just your team but the
game and that's that's dope to see man
yeah i mean because it's for all of us
right yeah and i always say i don't own
the team i just handle the finances but
all mavs fans everywhere on the team
that's what makes basketball or all
sports right so much different than
traditional businesses look at apple
right
multi-trillion dollar market cap no
one's throwing a parade in cupertino
when they have you know a super quarter
right right right right there's not a
whole city that gets on fire right when
you're moving like when you guys you
know with the suns last year just coming
out of nowhere and bam getting into the
finals the whole city is on fire that's
a great point yeah
shark tank yeah
what was the pitch to you that got you
involved in shark tank um
it was like we're doing this this
business show right do you want to come
on as a guest
and i'd watch the show and i'm like okay
you know it was on abc
and it was bouncing around right it
wasn't on any one night and i'm thinking
all right i'm gonna go on and i'm just
gonna blow them up right because they're
not gonna see me coming and this is a
business show and it's okay right but i
don't think it's gonna last so i'm just
gonna this is you know prime time
network tv and i'm just gonna mess with
everybody so i get on there and just
tear them all up they had no idea what
was coming but all of a sudden you know
like it did in other countries shark
tank starts to take off and
you know what it from what it started as
me just having fun to what it's become
which is a way to educate families kids
about businesses and really get kids
excited about entrepreneurship
that's what got me really to stay with
the show we'd be locked in yeah we'd be
locked in it's the coolest thing because
like you said it's not just for adults
right like my whole family my parents my
wife my kids will be sitting there
watching you know and there are products
that we
buy now all the time that came from as
long as we're my deal
right right
but for you but for you you've heard
hundreds of pitches like maybe thousands
of pitches thousands of pitches in
trying to figure out all these different
deals or whatnot what would be your
biggest advice to an entrepreneur or
somebody trying to start a business well
you know first know your business right
i think people will always stop and say
well i want to start a business what
should i do and if you don't know you're
not ready right you know
you've got to
have something that you're good at and
if you're going to be if you're going to
do it you got to be the best at it
because i'll tell them look if i come in
and compete with you i'm going to kick
your ass are you ready to compete with
me yeah right and you've got to work
like there's someone working 24 hours a
day to take it away from you you have a
website that lists all your different
businesses mark cuban.com right right
yeah all your different businesses and
all cause
do you have like a separate company
that's just for like shark tape no right
no
no they're all i mean so i don't have
like a fund that i that invests in all
the different companies it's just me
making direct investments and all of
yeah but this is it's not just the money
it's the time oh yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot going on and
people help me yeah
the people who help me yeah it takes
some people a lot smarter than me to
make all this work right i've got a lot
of really really great people that are
um around that make me look smart so
when it comes to crypto and blockchain
and stuff how do you feel about that i
think it's a big part of the future
right i really really do but i think
people are looking at the wrong way
people get really amped up about um the
price of the currency cryptocurrencies
right the tokens and they think that's
really what crypto is but it's not
that's the noise right the signal is if
i were going to start a business how can
i use this new technology to give myself
a competitive advantage and disrupt an
industry and so you know to give you an
example
is nfts right everybody's all i amps
about nfts and you see guys with their
board api club all day long all day long
and it's a collectible just like
anything else but to me nfts are just a
proof of concept and an example of how
smart contracts work when you go through
the process of creating an nft one of
the things they always ask you is what's
your royalty rate
and so when i set one up for the first
time i'm like royalties right how the
hell does that work because there's no
other way to make money every time a
digital asset is resold you'll get paid
a royalty and then i'm thinking okay
well if it works for these nfts where
else can i use this stuff right what
other business applications can i use
right the nfts were just showing you
another way to do other things proof of
concept right proof of concept again
it's like basketball right basketball
right now is changing and technology
keeps on changing yeah right it went
from you know post up and all this
different types of the game changes it
changed it because the technology made
people smarter right you went from
synergy right to second spectrum yeah
right yeah and then the data is
different and now we're getting into
using computer vision and ai for pose
estimation all this is just technology
changing that comes back to biomechanics
yeah all the biomechanics but how do you
track the biomechanics right
i didn't see you
win championships i didn't see you win
big games but
i don't ever think i've seen you as
happy as you are when you're on those
videos with your kids i can get them to
do them every day twice a day i don't do
them i don't care how embarrassed i get
by them yeah it's fun right
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show first i'll be meeting chinese
artist and dissident ai weiwei and i'll
talk to the novelist and political
scientist elif shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
one of your recent hires in the past
couple years with cynthia yeah said
marshall yeah yeah marshall yeah she's a
machine i mean she's she's a force of
nature she's she's in she's amazing you
know we had some challenges um that we
went through three years ago and you
know i i hadn't been connected to the
business side of it i was always on the
basketball side
and some things went wrong and i had to
own up to him
i needed somebody who could come in that
understood how to turn the culture of an
organization around
and she has just been a superstar she
don't play either no she don't play yeah
yeah she says that all the time i don't
play yeah i don't play i don't play but
that's who she is and she changed the
culture she changed the organization you
know diversity inclusion is is a tough
topic
you know because a lot of people look at
it just being about a checklist
and what i've learned particularly from
her is
that it's not about checking the boxes
it's about being pragmatic and doing
business the right way because what i
learned from her is when when we bring
people from different communities that
opens doors into those communities right
and so like dallas has the sixth largest
indian population in the country
i didn't know that did not know that you
just said so you want to find people
from that community
to sell into that community you want to
find people of color who can connect
because
i can walk in there and people will look
like me can walk in there
going to have yep or have the same
understanding and she
she already knew that right she knew how
to not only understand it not only
recognize the impact but how to deliver
it and that's what makes her special and
she's just got that energy and that vibe
and that love that comes out of her
genuine yeah unbelievably genuine so i'd
have known you for a while mark and i
didn't even know that you you had had
kids until i seen you on tick-tock
i seen you
with your daughter man and tell you the
truth because i i've done a few of my
kids you know what i mean and i'm
telling you man i didn't see you win
championships i hadn't seen you win big
games but
i don't ever think i've seen you as
happy as you are when you're on those
videos with your kids i can get them to
do them every day twice a day i do i
don't care how embarrassed i get by them
yeah it's fun right i mean you know now
they're the joy of my life they're
everything and you know it took me a
while to realize that because like when
they're really really little
really appreciate it yeah but once they
became real people you know there's it's
just yeah there's just nothing better
and if if i had a choice between just
spending time with them it's like i tell
people the most precious word in the
dictionary for me is dad yeah when you
hear your kids call you dad yeah
there's only one way there's only three
people in the universe who could say
that to me and those are most important
all that we talked about you could see
you was into it but when i brought up
your kids
jumped out your seat jumped out your
seat and it's scary too right because
you know
you had you had to work your way up and
you know and it's your success in a lot
of respects but then it just terrifies
you you know because
your kids can't copy that same path
right you know as much as you know your
path and i know my path and it's not
going to be my kids path they've got to
find their own and it scares me because
i don't want them to grow up to be
entitled right you know i don't want
them to take everything for granted i
want them to feel something that you
have to work for to get it yeah and it's
you know but they ain't dumb
they ain't done they know exactly you
know who paid for the house and how you
know that's the challenge i think that a
lot of us face man and i'm just
uh grateful to sit down and talk to you
all these years man we're never talking
this long man so
thank you so much appreciate it yeah
absolutely
[Music]
so
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
part of what i love about business is
you get to build things from nothing i
don't have any investors all this is all
money in this is me just building
it's pretty much full service shadow
banking with nobody in charge
[Music]
wadar is a strategically important point
on the map of pakistan it sits very
close to iran actually on the very
southern coast
it's about a 10 hour drive west of
karachi but it's only about an hour
drive to iran the area is extremely poor
it's very arid it doesn't have enough
water
electricity has been
very spotty one of the most surprising
things about visiting gwadar is the high
degree of security
that is absolutely everywhere there are
armed guards that are required to escort
foreign visitors everywhere you go
because it is a contested region because
there have been
militant attacks in the past
despite all this gwadar is a key part of
the china-pakistan economic corridor
also known as cpec
the crown jewel of president xi
jinping's belt and road initiative
we will leave no stone unturned
in ensuring that cpec
and all the projects
under its umbrella are materialized in
time and in full
so far just one third of all cpec
projects have been completed in gwadar
none of them have been and the promised
improvements for local people like job
creation and better infrastructure have
not materialized
so what has china got to gain from
developing this seemingly obscure city
on the pakistani coast
we have seen this movie before
an outside power comes into pakistan it
spends heavily on big infrastructure
projects china's not the first to do it
right after pakistan became independent
in the late 1940s early 50s the u.s was
sending
advisors
into pakistan to help plants economy u.s
was doing
infrastructure projects there too
those early projects helped the us gain
pakistan as an ally against the soviet
union during the cold war
the u.s has provided about 80 billion
dollars in aid to pakistan since its
independence but overall the result is
disappointing
one of the recent attempts was in the
late 2000s as part of the us effort to
combat terrorism in afghanistan
the number one item on that aid package
was to build these
high visibility infrastructure projects
so there there are literally projects
that the united states tried to do or
pakistan proposed to the united states
um in the 2000s during that period that
have become belt and road projects
china is stepping into a gap which has
been left by retreating ambition from
the us
and finally
the belton road initiative is china's
president xi jinping's signature foreign
policy initiative
launched in
2013 it comprises an overland belt
stretching through china
central asia into europe
and a maritime road stretching around
southeast asia through the india ocean
and up past east africa so a benign way
of characterizing china's belton road
initiative would be infrastructure for
influence so when xi jinping announced
the belton road initiative
shortly afterwards china designated
pakistan as its showcase flagship
project so the china-pakistan economic
quarter was going to be the biggest and
most important showcase for the success
of the belton road
pakistan is in great need of
infrastructure development they wanted
to
create
a railway a highway
roads all kinds of economic development
that is intended to help pakistan
and it's meant to provide jobs uh 2.3
million jobs for pakistanis it's meant
to provide a 2.5 boost to
gdp growth
and china would gain economically as
well
cpec was intended to reduce oil and gas
routes from the middle east by thousands
of miles a way to cut over land into
western china instead of going around
southeast asia by ship
projects in pakistan also provide
chinese state-owned companies with an
additional market
chinese workers are brought to pakistan
to build infrastructure and then take
wages home
cpec is also strategically significant
for china and pakistan
china wants to strengthen this
relationship to counter their shared
rival india
cpec is both an instrument of chinese
power as well as a test of chinese power
if it succeeds
china will be demonstrating
that it's able to do what great powers
have not been able to do in pakistan
including the united states
which is why gwadar is so important it's
in pakistan's balochistan province an
area with serious electricity and water
shortages
balochistan province is actually
populated by people who are of baloch
origin they're a different ethnicity
they speak a different language from
the majority in power in uh in islamabad
and they feel as the poorest province in
pakistan they have not sufficiently
benefited from some of the
economic achievements that the rest of
pakistan has had
that area is quite contested by
the belgian liberation army the people
who feel that
even pakistani people have encroached
into their territory so quite a number
of people are still staging attacks and
they attacked
the biggest international hotel in
gwadar
shot up the lobby and killed i think
five people
but this unsettled city is where the
china-pakistan economic corridor is
supposed to lead to
authorities plan to develop gwadar into
an international port city
gwadar port has an interesting history
and an interesting location too it's
located in baluchistan
it's about 120 kilometers from iran
pakistan purchased this territory from
oman i think in the 1950s and so for a
long time pakistan has had on its agenda
trying to develop this area since the
70s it's wanted to build a port in
gwadar
actually approached the united states in
the 1970s and tried to convince the
nixon administration to pay for report
even offered naval access if the united
states was willing to pay for that
the u.s rejected pakistan's offer
concerned that the port would not be
commercially viable and would cause
geopolitical tension
but in the early 2000s a chinese company
was awarded the contract to build the
port and they completed phase one of
construction in 2006.
the port was then managed by a
singaporean government entity
in 2013 a chinese port operator took
over from the singaporeans
in 2015 china announced that it will
expand the port as part of the cpec
initiative but five years later little
has happened
when you look out at the port you can
see it has only three berths
and all of them were empty
and the only ship that was in the port
at the time
was a pakistan naval frigate
and so it indicated to me that the port
is not particularly operational for
commercial purposes and
a number of analysts have talked about
the strategic importance in a military
sense
if eventually china were able to use the
port of gwadar as a military base
you know no one would be surprised if
china did use it in that way i don't
think in the short term like it is set
up in djibouti where it has a permanent
base i think it's more likely to use it
as
almost like a sort of forward-based
resupply
option
something it can use when it wants to
other projects like building pakistan's
largest airport in gwadar and two
special economic zones have been delayed
a 19 kilometer highway linking the port
with the makran coastal highway in
balochistan is under construction too
most of the people who live there and
work there already are fishermen they
rely on access to the sea
the way that the highway express highway
from the port was originally proposed
would have cut off their sea access and
so that was a real point of contention
with the community there have been some
proposals to allow them an underpass
it's still a little bit unclear how that
is finally going to be resolved even if
those projects are eventually built
there are serious questions about who
will work there
there is a problem with manpower of
course in guadalajara it's a very small
city and so one proposal has been well
we'll just ship chinese workers in from
china and build lots of
fancy housing for them
the first chinese-built community in
pakistan a 500 million dollar
development spanning over 10 million
square feet with over 60 open spaces
that kind of proposal
is what makes a lot of the pakistani
local people quite upset
a guadal-based journalist expressed
concerns to bloomberg over projects like
this the journalist spoke anonymously
for fear of persecution from the
pakistan government these projects are
creating jobs but they're not really
creating jobs for the local people of
gwadar they're not against
economic prosperity but they're against
the development that leaves them behind
pakistan doesn't have the money to build
these projects it's gone to the imf for
its 13th bailout since the 1980s by
engaging in cpec projects the government
of pakistan has incurred more debts from
china
not only posing challenges for pakistan
but possibly the international community
if pakistan eventually defaults on its
debts
but cpec is still set to go on
even if most current projects haven't
been completed the two countries have
recently signed new projects worth 11
billion dollars
pakistan's prime minister said the
country's economic future is linked with
china
[Music]
it's hard to imagine how the
china-pakistan economic corridor is
going to be the game changer that the
pakistan government would like it to be
we're not seeing the economic growth or
benefit from the projects that were set
out we're supposed to have seen by now
we're not seeing the job creation
project delays accumulating debts
commercial viability these problems of
cpec are also typical of belton road
projects around the world
for china though it's never the narrow
accounting perspective that matters it's
the bigger strategic benefits as china's
dollars continue to flow as china's
concrete continues to pour china's
influence continues to increase
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
from the u.s china trade war
a controversial security law in hong
kong
building in the south china sea
projects
there is undeniably a cold war-like
battle for influence on all fronts
and that includes space
we're in a space race today
just as we were in the 1960s
and the stakes are even higher
although china hasn't come close to
achieving what the us has they're
catching up
since 2018 china has launched more
rockets into orbit than any other
country
in 2019 they became the first to land a
rover on the far side of the moon
and in 2020 china released the last
satellite in their global navigation
satellite system called baido china's
answer to the us-made gps
like china's big infrastructure projects
here on earth their goals are to get a
foothold in space technology that will
drive profit
make them independent from u.s
technology get an upper hand in military
operations and show superiority on the
world stage
[Music]
with joe biden in the white house
experts think space spending could slow
although the democratic party has stated
that it will continue the goal of
sending americans back to the moon and
beyond to mars
we are launching humans to the moon for
the first time since 1972
and that might not be a bad thing while
a cold war scenario has dangerous
political and economic implications a
race to the cosmos like any good rivalry
could be a huge benefit for space and
other industries
if you think that the u.s china
competition is going to be not just a
clash of strategies but a clash of
systems it's going to be a contest over
whether american-style liberal democracy
or chinese-style authoritarian
capitalism is best suited to the demands
of the 21st century then it's entirely
possible that you could see the united
states make investments in
infrastructure and education and
technological innovation and basic
research that it wouldn't otherwise make
as a result of that competition
in 1957 the soviet union shocked the
world by putting the first ever
satellite into space sputnik one
there is real military significance to
these launchings
the satellite's unanticipated success
brought on the american sputnik crisis
a period of public fear and anxiety in
western nations about the perceived
technological gap between the united
states and soviet union
and so the national defense education
act of 1957
is passed in response to sputnik and it
includes major investments in a variety
of intellectual pursuits that were
considered critical to staying ahead in
the cold war and so the rise of entire
industries like aerospace the rise of
entire
regions like silicon valley or orange
county
semiconductors the internet a variety of
other things that we associate with the
rise of the information age were
originally conceived as part of the
military industrial complex in the 1950s
and 1960s and let me say that our
scientists and engineers in offering
their services of government in this
field have been generous patriotic and
promised
and nowhere was government spending more
apparent and highly publicized as the
space race of the time
in the eisenhower years and then kennedy
years
the u.s started pouring money into the
space program by
i think mid 1960s the u.s was spending
about four percent of its total budget
on space
it was the largest percentage of the
budget spent on space in american
history
and the intense rivalry allowed for some
of the biggest accomplishments humanity
has ever seen
including the first living animal to
enter space by russia
the first man to enter space by russia
and the first probe to land on the moon
also russia
and so that led to a huge surge in u.s
spending on the space program which
culminated in 1969 with neil armstrong
and buzz aldrin stepping on the moon
the moon landing is considered a
conclusion to the space race and as u.s
soviet relations improved space spending
waned
[Music]
i think that one of the reasons that the
us has not been as focused on space is
because the end of the cold war
since the apollo program the nasa budget
has hovered around 0.5 to 1
but in the last few decades the world
has seen the rise of a new power china
while governed by an authoritarian
regime like the ussr was
china also has far more economic
strength and greater resources than the
soviet union ever did
and that worries the
u.s the president has already signed
into law the largest nasa budget since
the days of the apollo program
there is very much an ideological
challenge it's sort of a contest over
which sort of system democracy or
authoritarian capitalism
will win the day in the 21st century and
i think what american officials
fear is that the chinese will not be
content to
have second second-tier status in a
world that is led by the united states
and its allies
[Music]
but space isn't simply a show of
technological strength like it was
during the cold war
[Music]
the space industry is now worth an
estimated 345 billion dollars with
technology that we use every day
depending on it
like gps
china started launching an alternative
to the american system called baido in
2000. the recently completed version is
20 centimeters more accurate than gps by
some estimates
china's baido space programme
brings prestige and practical benefits
the prestige from announcing their
arrival as a power in space similar to
the prestige which the us achieved from
its first moon landing
the practical benefits both military and
commercial
if you want to target a missile or a
fast food delivery you need a gps system
with its bado system china has its own
gps capability in place and so
independence from u.s influence on that
key part of infrastructure in the
information economy
china even opened up the private space
industry in 2014 in the hope of
encouraging competitors to the us
private space industry
ispace was the first private company in
china to successfully launch a rocket
and satellite into orbit in 2019 and a
company called galaxy space plans to
launch 650 low earth orbit satellites
similar to spacex's starlink which will
give better faster internet access to
people all over the world
but it's not all about business
[Music]
i think that for president xi jinping
this chinese space program is hugely
important not just for all the practical
applications but also just for prestige
it's important for president xi to show
that china is a superpower superpowers
have space programs
[Music]
china will have to prove that they can
perform the kind of missions nasa has
done and possibly go even further like
china's recent moon rover chung er-4
although it was the third country to
land a rover on the moon it was the
first to land on the far side of the
moon and china's recently launched mars
rover isn't the first but it's the first
orbiter lander rover all-in-one mission
china even has a voyager-like mission in
its initial planning stages that will do
a flyby of neptune and then out to
explore interstellar space but more
importantly china will build its own
space station
which will serve as an essential tool
for tests and research in space
and offer an alternative to the
international space station
[Music]
when it comes to innovation
china will have some advantages when it
comes to
directing the entire resources of a
state or the entire resources of a
society
towards some particular technological
challenge ai for instance
but the cost of that is there's less of
an open
economic and intellectual ecosystem in
china than there is in the united states
there's more inherent dynamism in a
society where you have truly open
information flows and where innovation
is as much a bottom-up as it is a
top-down phenomenon and so that's not to
say that the united states is destined
to win the race for ai or 5g or any
other technology i think there's real
danger in a lot of these fields but if
the united states puts forth the energy
and puts forth the investment that's
necessary in these areas there's no
inherent reason that it can't succeed
because it is a democracy
and there are signs that china's space
programme is stumbling in 2020 a long
march 5b rocket scattered debris over
cote d'ivoire after an uncontrolled
re-entry of the rocket's core stage
this was the largest botch of its kind
in years
so the worry is that china is just not
that transparent when it comes to this
sort of thing so was this just a one-off
was this just something went wrong
or is this just an example of what might
be happening going forward
the competition may prove to be too much
china is up against not only a space
program with a long and decorated
history but one with more ambitious
missions than ever before the us is now
trying to beat china back to the moon to
build a lunar base harvest resources and
then use it as a stepping stone to get
to mars this time when we go to the moon
we're going to go to stay with the
purpose of learning how to live and work
on another world so we can take that
knowledge and information to mars
i think that the sense of urgency that
we're hearing from the trump
administration about the need to
accelerate the artemis program to get to
the moon by 2024 i think part of that is
because of the perceived threat from
china right so
in that sense i think that having china
as a more serious player in space could
potentially be good for for nasa good
for the american space program
other nasa projects include a mars
mission equipped with a mini helicopter
to fly on the surface of the red planet
another mini helicopter mission planned
for titan saturn's largest moon
and the launch of the james webb space
telescope an upgrade to the hubble space
telescope whose photographs changed our
understanding of the universe as we know
it
the ambitions of china and the us may
depend on how long their rivalry
continues if history is any lessen the
bigger the rivalry the further the two
space superpowers are likely to push
themselves
very cohesive the overall goal with
china's space program i think is to
match the united states china does not
want to be subordinate to the us on
earth and doesn't want to be
subordinated to the us in space right
now the plan is to try to narrow the gap
and so if you are looking at this from
an american strategic perspective the
concern would be that china may have a
jump
in the areas of high-tech innovation
that will be most important in terms of
powering
innovation and productivity during the
21st century and that can perhaps be
turned into
advantages on the battlefield i should
say that the jury is really still out in
terms of how effective china will be and
mastering innovation in these areas but
if china continues to lack the open
informational ecosystem that we've
typically associated with success and
innovation there may still be
significant obstacles to
maintaining the dynamism needed to spur
innovation over the long run
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shaffer
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
[Music]
tensions between the us and china have
been steadily escalating as they spar on
everything from democracy in hong kong
to the data security of tick tock
[Music]
but there's one place where a military
battle between the superpowers is most
likely to happen
the south china sea
what started as a territorial dispute
over rocks and reefs grew into clashes
over fishing and natural resources
now the south china sea is home to
escalating war games between two of the
world's largest militaries
i think we're getting to a point now
where confrontation is more likely
recent tensions have threatened to boil
over it used to be in the old days that
the americans were clearly the
superpower they could sail where they
wanted and nobody else could do anything
about it whereas now i think the chinese
are starting to think that maybe they
have the military power the weapons that
could actually threaten the americans
as joe biden comes into office this is
an issue that's not going to get any
easier to solve because china sees it as
part of its very core strategic interest
to control that territory that's not
going to change whoever is in the white
house
we're at a kind of dangerous phase at
the moment and
looks set to continue
so how did an east asian dispute over a
group of small islands become a
significant flashpoint for u.s china
relations
[Music]
the south china sea encompasses 1.4
million square miles making it almost
one and a half times bigger than the
mediterranean sea it's a key commercial
gateway that sees one-third of the
world's maritime shipping pass through
it every year accounting for more than
three trillion dollars in trade
beneath the surface the maritime life is
vital to the diets and economies of the
surrounding nations
around 12 percent of the global fish
catch comes from these waters which also
hosts more than half of the world's
fishing vessels
even further down beneath the seabed is
the promise of natural gas and crude oil
reserves
the exact amount is disputed with both
the u.s and china giving vastly
different estimates
the u.s estimates that the sea holds
about 190 trillion cubic feet of natural
gas and 11 billion barrels of oil
south china sea it's a strategic
crossroads really it links on one side
the pacific and the other side the
indian ocean and then north to china and
south to australia huge amounts of world
trade go through huge amounts of oil
most of the things that we you know we
buy in the shops that come out of china
japan taiwan all travel through the
south china sea
for decades china and neighboring
southeast asian nations have disputed
territorial claims within the area
largely centred around two groups of
islands
the spratly islands in the south and the
paracel islands in the north
it's a point of contention because these
are two kinds of disputes there are
disputes about the islands who owns them
but they overlap with disputes about
what you can do in the sea whose rules
apply and they also overlap with this
great power competition between china
and the us so it's this intersection of
these three layers of disputes that's
what makes the situation so dangerous
brunei malaysia the philippines taiwan
and vietnam all have claims in the
region but it's china's claims that are
the most contentious
china claimed more than 80 of the south
china sea referring to a map from 1947
that shows a u-shaped line looping down
to a point about 1 100 miles or 1800
kilometers south of its hainan island
china's claim in the south china sea
emerged between 1907 and 1947 in those
40 years and it really emerged in the
context of china
struggling against foreign powers in the
first half of the 20th century
against japan and then later against
france and then against japan again
during the second world war
it became an emotional question it
became a time when china wanted to stand
up against the world and one way of
doing that was by staking a claim to
territory
but beijing didn't start actively
asserting this claim until later in the
20th century
it's really when oil gets discovered in
certain parts of south china sea in the
late 1960s early 1970s that's when it
starts to heat up a bit more and you
start to see more of the islands being
occupied philippines moves in in the 70s
the vietnamese also do the same thing
and then the malaysians get in the game
the chinese
government doesn't make its first
occupations actually physically you know
planting the flag in the spratly islands
until 1988 so they come very late to the
game at that point in the years that
followed nations jostled among
themselves for control of the islands
but since the mid-1990s the occupation
of most parts of the spratly and paracel
islands hadn't changed significantly
but as china's position on the world
stage grew so too did their activity in
the region
in the chinese telling of of how this
spat began
china says you know back in the early
2000s china and the southeast asian
nations who also have claims there got
along fine and what really sparked off
kicked off the conflict was when
during the early days of the obama
administration they had this
pivot to asia
and so when the us did this pivot to
asia it sort of encouraged a lot of the
southeast asian nations to start
exerting their claims in the south china
sea to start building on islands that
they had occupied and so then china by
beijing's telling felt compelled to do
the same and to do it
uh to a greater degree
i think there have been
two major changing points in in recent
years so there's the 2008 financial
crisis
when the american economy goes into a
nosedive you have the same time you have
the beijing olympics when china suddenly
appears on the world stage and you get a
new confidence in china that maybe their
way is is superior to the american way
of running the world and i think that
then leads into the
selection of president xi in 2012 by the
communist party as their party leader
china's once in a decade transition of
power was completed earlier today xi
jinping head of the chinese communist
party has just been elected president of
china in a near unanimous vote before
she becomes a party leader in 2012 you
have you noticed in the south china sea
different bits of the the state you know
the the coast guard the the navy the
fishing protection the um the police
whatever all following different
policies from 2013 onwards once she's in
power you see much more centralized
control and that's in 2013 when you
start to see china building these
massive artificial islands in the
spratly islands with huge military bases
on
we continue our look this morning on
what china does not want you to see the
united states says the superpower is
reclaiming land in the south china sea
china has begun this campaign of
building islands in south china sea
taking reefs and rocks and building on
top of that with sand and filling in the
water and on top of that land they've
built
airstrips
they put missiles in they put in
installments where military personnel
can be there full time
beijing transformed the disputed reefs
and rocks by reclaiming 670 acres of
land from the sea to create islands with
administrative buildings hospitals and
sport complexes
there's also runways that can land
fighter jets and are equipped with
defensive systems radar antennae and
radio systems which are intended to
monitor the area around them china's use
of the islands in this way prevents
other countries developing resources and
that directly breaches the united
nations convention on the law of the sea
also known as unklos
unklos was established in 1982 and it
states that a country can have a
territorial zone of 12 nautical miles
off its coast a further 12 nautical
miles where it has limited controls and
an exclusive economic zone of 200
nautical miles
china argues that the paracel and
spratly islands are part of its
territory and therefore they own
anything within those exclusive economic
zones be it fish or natural resources
and it's been enforcing this in
increasingly hostile ways
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafak
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
china's general
military philosophy is something called
active defense and the idea is to appear
to be non-threatening and to be
defensive
but to
create situations where you lure the
opponent into making a move which then
allows you to respond in force and in
full i'm warning you again leave
immediately for you health fair forward
is availability for all the consequences
so what it's doing now is using these
islands as a means of projecting power
so it's successfully intimidated vietnam
and stopped it developing its offshore
oil and gas reserves it's done the same
thing to the philippines it's tried to
do the same thing with malaysia but with
less success
effect
has established a kind of
a block on the other countries
developing their maritime resources i
suppose the next thing that might happen
will be that then china might try and
use its force to develop resources which
doesn't have any claim to under the
in 2016 an international tribunal in the
hague ruled that the paracel and
spratleys were rocks rather than islands
and therefore would not get the benefits
of eez
the ruling also stated that there was no
legal basis for china's claims
and what that meant was that suddenly
the value of the disputed islands became
much less in theory because it meant you
couldn't claim huge amounts of resources
oil and gas and fish from around them
however china has refused to recognize
this ruling
and the reason is obvious is that it
actually diminishes
the value of these disputed islands and
makes the
the case for the surrounding countries
vietnam malaysia philippines brunei
much much stronger for the resources for
the oil and the gas and the fish
diplomats in china and asean countries
have turned their attention to an
earlier legally binding document in the
hope of a resolution the asean nations
and china said to have reached an
agreement to begin negotiations on a
code of conduct in the south china sea
unfortunately the long-term outlook is
not good the fact is that you have
a negotiation process between asean and
china that is not really going very well
they're trying to establish a code of
conduct that would set some parameters
for how business is conducted in south
china sea at the same time however they
don't actually address the dispute at
all
so
no dispute resolution mechanisms are
really being negotiated seriously at
this time what's perhaps more concerning
is the ever-evolving china u.s
competition dynamic which is becoming
more aggressive in nature the us's
response in the south china sea has been
mainly
driven
from its sort of overall strategic
interests because the south china sea
connects america's west coast from
california to the indian ocean and to
the middle east and so they said it's a
vital strategic corridor for them you
know for civilian shipping but also
military shipping to go through
during the obama administration the
issue was very contentious already and
so when trump came in what really
happened was not that the the conflict
arose but the way that the u.s
government began to pursue its strategy
became much more aggressive became much
more proactive and abrasive that's why
the situation in the south china sea has
become much more dangerous
a u.s presence has been increasing in
the region since 2012. over the years
administrations have weighed in on
arguments over resources but haven't
taken sides in the territorial disputes
until now beijing doesn't respect the
fundamental democratic values or those
enshrined in the asean charter previous
years we've seen a lot of
positive language from
regional partners who wish to make room
for china as a global superpower but
china's come on a little hard the u.s
has issued one of its strongest warnings
against china over beijing's illegal
territorial claims in the south china
sea it's not china's maritime empire the
united states is prepared to do
the things necessary to assist them in
protecting their valid legal claims
[Music]
expansion of the chinese navy has become
one of the latest concerns for u.s and
asean nations beijing's anti-ship
ballistic missiles are also known as
carrier killers a department of defense
report suggests that china may be the
first ever to attach this category of
weapon to a warship
there's a
good reason to think that a lot of
china's activities in the south china
sea in terms of building up its bases
are done with a possible invasion of
taiwan in mind
they're thinking if there was ever an
invasion an attempt to forcibly you know
bring taiwan into the people's republic
of china that the united states would
try and defend taiwan and having these
islands there
with missiles already on them and
runways and so forth would be a way of
keeping the americans at bay it's also i
think part of trying to create a a
bastion a hiding place for their
ballistic missile submarines there and a
way of just keeping the americans away
from their southern coast
both china and the us regard the south
china sea as pretty
crucial
to their overall strategic interests
which means they're going to struggle
hard
the escalation of military activities in
the south china sea even in the midst of
a pandemic has many onlookers concerned
a war of words on twitter and state tv
has transformed into warships and
military drills that could be the start
of a new cold war
in the final waning days of the trump
administration you've seen a slew of
measures taken and i think a lot of
those measures have been taken to try
and prevent joe biden's administration
from coming in and undoing a lot of what
president trump had put into place
during his time in office
based on what we've heard from the biden
administration it does seem that the
strategy will be to work more closely
with allies if the biden administration
is able to form a united front as it
comes to the south china sea i think two
things could happen
uh if it becomes a an alliance against
china i think you will see the chinese
become more aggressive and pushing back
on that the alternative would be some
sort of more inclusive
uh alliance that that wants to welcome
china into the fold and if that is
something that happens i think you can
see a much more benign resolution to the
problem
obviously there are a lot of things
going on in the united states i don't
think the south china sea is
particularly high on joe biden's
priority list at the moment
but i think in the future in the next
couple of years that is what will start
to develop
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident my way away
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
imagine if the internet took hold in
china imagine how freedom would spread
unrestricted internet access is a source
of strength that country has some of the
toughest internet restrictions in the
world government in china is tightening
up on internet restrictions it says
because of the number of anonymous
postings that poke fun at the government
so you think they're ultimately going to
be on the right side of history the
chinese government obviously i am a 100
for sure because nobody can stop this
technology revolution
[Music]
it's 1987 in west germany and a
university professor has just got an
email it contains one short sentence
across the great wall we can reach every
corner of the world he's just received
the first email from china china is
embracing the reform and opening up
policies and the internet and
transparency of information is part of
that policy
but it isn't until 1994 that the
internet becomes available to the public
under the presidency of zhang min
like many of his compatriots zhang is
deeply influenced by the work of alvin
toffler an american writer whose book
future shock predicts a super industrial
revolution brought about by the
moderation and regulation of technology
[Music]
combine facts to make new knowledge at
such high speed that we cannot absorb
[Music]
but computers are expensive and hardly
anyone owns one so the internet cafe is
born it costs around 25 yuan or three
dollars for an hour in the early days
internet speed was really slow and
having a personal computer was a luxury
most of the people who frequent internet
cafes were the more young tech savvy
generations and they would go to play
games and chat with your friends
anonymously online
in 1995 a former english teacher called
jack ma heads to the us on business
while he's there he does a web search
for the word beer and there are no
results about china he returns home and
starts in online yellow pages
you don't make any money you've got
extraordinary claims and yet you make
nothing
that's internet
by 1999 the company tencent releases
oicq and jack ma creates alibaba
it's the millennium and the unveiling of
the golden shield project which includes
a new surveillance system made up of
content filtering firewalls
the system becomes known around the
world as the great firewall of china
the government also employs an army of
people that actively send out social
posts to shape conversations online
these people became known as the 50 cent
party the joke being that they would
earn 50 cents every time they sent it
out a social media post
it only takes a couple more years for
china to overtake the us and have the
world's most internet users
fast forward and it's 2012 xi jinping is
elected general secretary of the
communist party with a vision of cyber
sovereignty protecting the country's
internet from foreign influence
[Music]
notable restrictions include winnie the
pooh because of comparisons made to xi
jinping and the letter m
the west might think of chinese
entertainment users as being horribly
miserable because they can access
information freely but the truth can't
be more different china's younger
generations are perfectly happy living
inside the firewall where they can use
the domestic apps that are screened
there really is a disconnect between
china's younger internet users and the
rest of the world because of the great
firewall
it doesn't take long for controversial
new laws which ensure cyber security to
appear these grant the government
unprecedented access to foreign
companies including their hardware and
sensitive user data
in 2018 freedom house named china as the
worst country in the world for online
freedom but china soon starts exporting
its take on the internet to countries
like vietnam uganda and tanzania
in 1987 when that email was sent from
china to west germany it said across the
great wall we can reach every corner of
the world
it looks quite ironic right now because
we have a great wall that literally
screams and monitors everything the
vision that early internet founders had
is very different from china's internet
landscape today
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
ceremony
in the past decade no politician has
probably been more influential in
shifting china's climate policy than
shia jinhua
as china's lead negotiator at the united
nations climate change conferences he's
been critical to forging climate
agreements on the international stage
now he's a special adviser to china's
environmental ministry and the head of a
leading institute for climate and
sustainability research
a study done by that institute
contributed to china's decision to be
carbon neutral by 2060.
so how is china going to achieve its
carbon neutrality goals in time and what
role will this climate veteran continue
to play
[Music]
after working for china's environmental
protection ministry for almost a decade
shia was appointed as its head in 1993.
during cs tenor at the environmental
protection ministry a management system
for major air and water pollutants were
put in place and in addition
environmental targets started to be
included in china's five-year plans
these blueprints for economic and social
development
which had previously been very focused
on economic growth
he resigned in 2005 after a series of
chemical plant explosions in china's
g-lim province
the explosions were caused by the
improper storage of dangerous chemicals
and left six dead and dozens injured
a local river was also polluted by
leaked chemicals and tens of thousands
of residents had to be evacuated
his resignation came as the
environmental agency criticized local
officials for covering up the accident
and for this blind pursuit of economic
development which damaged china's
environment
but the resignation appeared to be only
a blip in his career and as cia later
assumed the role of vice chairman of the
national development and reform
commission
at the time the ndrc china's top
economic planner was responsible for
making environmental policy social
continued to have a leading role in
china's climate strategies
in 2007 shir was appointed as china's
lead climate negotiator at the un
climate change conferences by then four
decades of breakneck economic growth had
turned china into the world's biggest
carbon emitter
steadily though the country's stance has
shifted from defending its right to emit
to promoting low carbon development
[Music]
foreign
in china's policy making system it's
difficult to point to the role of the
individual person but we know that sia
played quite an important role in
proposing ambitious climate targets for
china which were eventually adopted by
the country's top leaders
so the advantages that sia had is that
he is very well versed in sort of the
party structure and the party priorities
and as well as international climate
priorities so he knows how to translate
the international pressures into better
chinese policies
[Music]
so sia is known as a very candid tough
negotiator in international climate
talks uh at the durban talks in 2011 a
video sia repeatedly banging a table
over what he believed were hypocritical
demands by developed countries was
widely broadcast in china
and yet his counterparts continued to
speak to a sense of humor and his
general likability
foreign
has a personal commitment to fight for
change after traveling to parts of the
world affected by the climate crisis
is
[Music]
in 2017
received a 2.5 million dollar award for
his efforts to tackle climate change he
donated the money to his alma mater
ching hwa university hoping to encourage
the next generation of climate leaders
he's now the head of the university's
institute of climate change and
sustainable development and his team's
research has helped set china's goal to
become carbon neutral by 2060
we are already seeing some suggestions
for how to make this happen so one
climate institute that works with cs
institute at xinhua has laid out a plan
of increasing renewable and nuclear
energy and completely phasing out coal
power
the plan entails a very gradual
transition over the next 15 years
with a rapid acceleration after 2035 so
under this particular plan coal-fired
electricity would be eliminated by 2050
and china's energy mix would undergo a
dramatic transformation
we've also seen these estimates that
something like 15 trillion dollars will
need to be invested over the next 30
years to meet these targets
[Music]
from
tensions between the us and china have
been rising in recent years and the u.s
government has withdrawn from the paris
agreement but shir is convinced there's
no time to lose
foreign
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
the white picket fence space for
entertaining acres of land to call your
own these were characteristics of the
american dream home but is it still a
dream worth chasing
[Music]
should you buy a home or rent we're here
at the white house at six woods lane in
east hampton long island you could own
this place for the list price of 12.5
million dollars with a 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage at 3.991
interest you'd pay nearly 47 000 a month
and that's not including closing costs
home ownership insurance or property
taxes now this kind of place might be a
little pricey for you but the same
principles apply at much lower levels
when you're considering whether to rent
or buy a home now before i break
something in here let's get back to the
studio
[Applause]
to buy or not to buy
that is the question
we pulled our youtube audience and they
had a lot to say one person said owning
a house should not be thought of as an
investment more like something between
an asset and a liability someone else
shared a pretty common sentiment these
days that student loans would prevent
them from ever buying a home another
said abolish private property altogether
but okay a majority of you think
ownership is the way to go and who can
blame them people think of buying a home
as part of the american dream the driver
of middle class wealth a sound
investment vehicle renting a place is
less romantic
throwing money away every month on a
place to rest your head and keep your
stuff but that calculus is changing to
help us run down the reasons why you may
want to rent and not buy i spoke to
financial planner roger ma
so can you tell me why renting is not
throwing your money away
well i think the flip side is why is
buying not wasting money and i think
that's a myth that when you buy a lot of
your money is building equity but that's
just not the case your monthly payment
and the upfront and the back end costs
of buying are wasted money as well sure
you've got mortgage interest homeowners
insurance property taxes potentially
homeowners association fees yeah not to
mention the the huge closing costs on
the front end and the back
end you don't plan to stay in the same
area for at least five years it probably
makes more sense to rent and that's
because of those
large closing costs right you need to
give your home
um a sufficient amount of time to
potentially increase in value i feel
like the generation now growing is maybe
more likely to be on the move definitely
between the ages of 22 and 40 the
average person changes jobs every one to
two years so they're they're changing a
fair amount so i think having the
flexibility to change jobs could be
reasons to rent instead of buying right
and that's okay
there's no shame in renting and if you
look around the united states depending
on where you live it might actually be
more affordable atom data solutions
publishes a yearly affordability index
of buying versus renting and in most
places 59 percent to be exact real
estate prices are outpacing rentals in
fact in all 18 of the most populous
counties in america it's more affordable
to rent than buy let's be real for a lot
of people the choice of renting versus
buying may not even be yours especially
if you're young i talked to bloomberg
reporter patrick clark about the unique
problems facing potential homebuyers
let's talk about the unique uh
hindrances that maybe new home buyers
might face uh there's not enough homes
they can afford right sure that would be
a big problem at the very most basic
there's an affordability gap a decade
after the foreclosure crisis
we're still building homes not just of
where they were at the peak bubble
madness but still below the number of
new homes that we were adding in like
the mid 90s the construction that is
happening has been skewed towards the
high end that is sort of pressured on
the other side by maybe age
people growing older and maybe not
moving out of their homes there's two
different ways you could get listings or
you could build new homes or you can
have
homes that were already occupied right
hit the market and there's some question
of whether people want to stay in their
own homes and quote unquote age and
place
[Music]
older people staying in their homes
longer is an issue right so there's some
gridlock in the housing market this
generation is now saddled with more um
more kind of burdens than previously was
the case like way more there's like more
than 1.5 trillion dollars of student
loan debt outstanding
yikes the deck is certainly stacked
against this generation
but that long-standing elusive goal of
homeownership seems so tempting all in
all i'd have to put it this way if you
have your heart set on home ownership
nobody's going to stand in your way
but you probably don't need to sweat it
too much either if you don't
that was probably expensive
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident by way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
are you self-employed
freelancing
do you have a side hustle
all of these are various types of
independent contracting that together
make up what's become known as the gig
economy
three in ten americans work a gig job of
some kind or another and for many
freelancing is synonymous with freedom
but freedom isn't free there's a lot of
instability that comes with the gig
economy it's a hustle it's a grind you
don't have that safety net of a salaried
job basically
working from paycheck's paycheck this is
good money and we're here to help you
run the business of you
okay so the gig economy is a broad topic
so let's separate it into two sections
there's the career freelancer and the
side hustler and let's start with side
hustling because i'm a humble video
producer and i could use some extra
scratch but will i get in trouble with
my company for doing that i wish there
was somebody i could talk to about this
hey uh
you gotta say i can help you out with
this who are you my name is mark kohler
i'm just sitting over here reading my
own book on the very topic you're
talking about oh yeah sure
will i get in trouble with my company if
i want to start a side hustle generally
not unless you're going to try to start
a small business in your industry nine
times out of ten you're going to be fine
you can go out and do whatever you want
once you are a side hustler you're
basically a small business yeah yeah a
lot of people don't realize if i'm just
even driving for uber you're getting a
1099 baby that's a small business let's
take advantage of it and the tax
write-offs could be phenomenal yeah sure
tell me about this well under the new
tax cuts and jobs actors we got what's
called the 20
pass-through we've got cell phone home
office computers electronics travel auto
all these little things that you might
be paying for anyway i call them
personal conversion expenses so what
happens if my side hustle becomes so
successful that uh you know it's cutting
into all my time well congratulations
now you've graduated to career
freelancer you're a full-time business
owner it's better to quit your job now
and make more money at home
you know what
i quit
[Music]
wait a second
was that a good idea
what about my vacation time my 401k my
health insurance and that discounted gym
membership i never signed up for
freelancing seems like a lot more work
than a staff job mostly because you have
to do everything yourself
i'm gonna need some more guidance before
i call myself a career freelancer
and what better place to seek advice
than the freelancers union so let's head
to their hq and talk to executive
director caitlin pierce
let's say i just became a career
freelancer what can i do to feel as
secure as i did as a staffer you know
when people are thinking about whether
or not to become a freelancer i always
say before you make that leap think
about a couple of things one is you know
what is your plan for earning enough
income not just to support yourself but
also to take on the additional costs of
managing your tax burden paying for your
own health and benefits and having a
savings plan for retirement should i be
hiring somebody to
do my taxes for me short answer yes one
of the things all freelancers need
especially if they're doing this
full-time is someone that can help you
understand what you can deduct for your
business um and make sure that you've
done your taxes properly so you don't
end up with a liability at the end of
the year could you give me a few
financial tips that help freelancers
remain secure first of all every
freelancer needs to have a good contract
that they've worked with a lawyer and
that they understand that's going to
protect their work and make sure they
get paid on time secondly you should
have a system by which you are
automatically setting aside 30 of your
income into taxes as soon as it comes in
before you can touch it and if you can
also setting aside income in short-term
and long-term savings the third thing i
think is that you should really set
aside 10 of your time for long-term
planning and that should include
business building activities like client
prospecting networking uh investing in
training or upskilling and it's really
important for you to have a vision for
where you're going think about where you
want to be in five years financially and
professionally and be
making steps towards working towards
those goals
so that should get all you freelancers
and side hustlers off on the right foot
as for me
i'm gonna go beg for my cushy staff job
back
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillions etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
ah retirement i could spend every day
just like this relaxing playing golf
spending time with family
but like most of you i can't retire
right now or really anytime soon
work
work work
so even if we can't retire right now
there are more than a few people who
made their early retirement dreams come
true no lottery ticket or well-timed
crypto investment required those people
are part of a community called fire
that's financial independence retire
early fire devotees combine high savings
rates minimalist living and investing
with low cost index funds to reach
retirement in relatively short periods
of time
i talked to a guy named bryce lung who
along with his wife christy retired in
their early 30s and never looked back
we were given the same prescriptive
script that everybody that our parents
gave us for how to live get a job buy a
house go into debt get a mortgage spend
the next 25 years paying off and then
maybe when you're 65 then you can retire
with a pension the old rule book that
they played with simply doesn't apply
for us anymore so how long was your
journey once you began nine years after
we started working we retired my wife
was 31 i was 32 at the time and we said
goodbye to our jobs forever and we've
been traveling ever since it's actually
based not on your age but how much money
you have saved up versus how much money
you need to spend to maintain your
lifestyle so the rule that we use in the
fire community is called the four
percent rule how much you have saved up
versus how much that you need to spend
if it's four percent of it then that you
can retire safely and never need to work
again why is that number four percent an
academic study called the trinity study
in which they kind of back tested
um like all of the stock market history
like going back like hundreds of years
four percent is the amount that it's
safe to withdraw in that uh you won't
run out of money over like a traditional
retirement period how did you change
your lifestyles so that
uh you would live more frugally there
was not so much a sacrifice of lifestyle
that got us here it was avoiding the
landmines that so many people step on
the commonly accepted personal finance
thing of like you have to cut back until
it's painful no no going out no no
eating out and no drinking coffees and
this kind of stuff we didn't do any of
that kind of stuff because the biggest
line items in a person's life is housing
transportation and food and if you get
those three right then the rest of it
almost doesn't even matter
but even if you can't retire at 31 like
bryce did there might still be some
alterations to your savings or spending
that you can make to retire at a more
traditional age bloomberg reporter
suzanne wooley is going to tell us how
to plan for that more traditional
retirement and the annoyances that we
must overcome to get there should people
be scared about retiring
isn't everyone scared about retiring
it's this so big a prospect and it's
also uncertain and i think
people get sort of terrified by the idea
of like what is my number
like do i need a million do i need two
million like who knows and i think that
can put people into paralysis a lot of
people don't even know
how much they spend each month
so you know just knowing what your
budget is gives you a sense of like what
you need to live on what mistakes are
people making uh as they plan for
retirement one mistake people might make
is not planning for contingencies you
know you have like a point when you want
to retire like some people say oh i want
to retire when i'm 62 or 65. well great
but you know life might not go your way
you might be laid off there might be
some sort of ageism you might get sick
and not be able to work so it's sort of
when you're retirement planning you need
to think through like how would i
live if i had if i was laid off you know
five years earlier than i anticipated
and also you need to have some sort of
like emergency fund maybe like buckets
one is for short term and it's just cash
like a year's living expenses if you can
do that you know the middle one is maybe
in
bonds and short term investments and you
know the other part can be aggressive
the other bucket is more aggressive
really long term like
10 or 20 years
so if you want to get your fire dream
started go ahead and make it happen as
for me i'm gonna do this for a few more
hours then get back to work
turn the camera off
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where is
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillions etf
masterchef only on quick take
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
hey it's henry so this is the last
episode of our season and
it turns out we have some extra money in
the budget and i want to spend that
money on myself so for this episode
we're going to figure out how a person
in this case me
can spend money to increase their own
happiness now i know what you're
thinking money can't buy happiness and
you're right
sort of
studies have found that while having
more money greatly affects the happiness
for people living in poverty once
someone earns around seventy five
thousand dollars a year the amount of
happiness they get from additional funds
flattens out so someone who makes on
average two hundred thousand dollars a
year isn't necessarily that much happier
than somebody who makes a middle class
like me
so it's kind of unbelievable to hear
that you know me doubling my salary
wouldn't make me any happier but while
more money doesn't necessarily mean more
happiness how we spend our money does
and like any good reporter i did a
google search and watched a ted talk on
happiness by this man dr robert
waldinger he's the director of the
harvard study of adult development a
study that started in 1938 and continues
until this day making it possibly the
longest study of human happiness ever to
have been conducted
we found that many of the things we
expect to predict well-being do like
taking care of yourself taking care of
your health not smoking not abusing
alcohol okay exercising but the surprise
was
that
the quality of our relationships with
other people actually keeps us healthier
and keeps us alive longer
so we looked at their cholesterol we
looked at their blood pressure at age 50
and we looked at their marital
satisfaction and what we found was that
their marital satisfaction was by far
the strongest predictor of what they
were going to be like when they were 80.
marital happiest marriages at 50
predicted
better health and happiness at age 80.
but to be able to predict across 30
years that's a big deal that begins to
get at causation so relationships it's
like it's like exercise in a way
you don't just
do it one week and then you're done
right that relationships have to be
tended to so your marriage your
friendships they take work they take
constant attention over time or they
wither away
so
how can i buy good relationships
well you can't
but
that
is a question you should ask of the
researchers who actually study this
luckily these researchers also had ted
talks and have been focusing on that
very question how spending our money
affects our happiness the reason why i
believe it's actually very interesting
to study spending is because it's so
ubiquitous like we all spend and we all
actually have a lot of control over our
spending we are going to spend some of
our money because we have to and are we
really thinking about spending it in
ways that might actually make us happy
and if yes what can we learn as
researchers to help people so there's a
lot of methodology and findings that
come from research done by people like
sandra and michael but i wanted to boil
down some of the biggest takeaways first
off and this shouldn't come as a
surprise but spend money on building
social relationships so there is built
into our close relationships this
element of reciprocity of giving back
and forth what we're trying to do in our
research is say you can do more of it
actually so it's probably not useful to
give someone five dollars and say will
you be a closer friend of mine because
that's not how it works but it does work
to say hey i really like you and i'd
like to take you out to lunch so if you
buy coffee maybe you might want to kind
of spend it on buying a coffee for
yourself and your friend because we know
that if you spend it on someone else you
also gain greater happiness the next big
point is to spend more money on
experiences and less on things
tom gilovich and his colleagues at
cornell for about a decade now have been
doing research showing that
on average buying stuff for yourself
doesn't do much for your happiness
but buying experiences seems to make us
happier what we see when when it comes
to actually buying material goods versus
experiences is that when we buy our
second watch for example we might get
the spike in happiness but at some point
this actually this effect of happiness
goes away and to some extent we might
even regret at some point spending
investing that much money whereas if we
have experiences we kind of go to a
concert there's this effect of
anticipated happiness so we look forward
to going to the concert for two weeks
even like building up to the experience
and then after the experience we can
always go back to it so we have a memory
of the experience we might even share it
with friends come back to it every once
in a while and then when we get together
for for a fun night and finally if
you've been thinking i do want that
apple watch and i know it would make me
happy then good buy it you should know
what makes you happy if people manage to
spend their money in a way that is
aligned with their own psychological
needs and preferences as reflected by
their personality the debt seems to be
making people happier if i'm an
extrovert i might be better off spending
my money on
going out with friends kind of having a
very social time spending it on exciting
stuff versus like a friend of mine who's
probably more introverted what they
could do instead is spend it on things
that improve their their quality me time
so to say the first thing that we
recommend that people do is literally do
an audit of your spending and and what's
important to you is completely up to you
so i can't say these are the things that
should be important to you in life but
you know the things that are important
to you in life and typically when you
look at your spending in this way you
say wow i should really shift some money
from that big category over to this big
category
so to recap the big takeaways in order
to spend money to get happiness first
off know yourself are you an introvert
an extrovert how do you want to spend
your money second use your money to
build social relationships and third put
an emphasis on experiences over things
so if i were to analyze myself for my
money if i'm getting the best return i
am a person who loves my family and i
love sharing experiences with them
around food so i'm thinking i will spend
that extra budget money
you know for the purposes of the show
to take my mom with me to italy and we
have some fantastic meals what are we
looking at yeah
so it turns out we got like 35 dollars
and 20 cents left in the budget um
so
hey mom
do you want to go to the olive garden
tonight
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios they have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident my way way
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick
[Music]
hi my name is dan and i'm here in spain
to discover the land the food the people
and their passion through wine
as well as how the land and the wine
work together
i love land
i love wine
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
destination aragon
aragon is a land marked by history by
the ebro river by the pyrenees and by
the wine
we're in the north of spain almost on
the border with france in one of the
greatest areas of the country
i share this land with a great friend of
mine from work the incredible john
john and i have worked together and have
always understood each other well
we love talking eating and drinking i
think aragon is going to be the perfect
destination to share
aragon has four main winemaking areas
each with its own character
so john this is exciting to
be coming up to our first uh vineyard oh
i can't wait
and the d.o is called
i think that's right we are in borja the
first place we're going to is a vineyard
called
alto moncayo and i think mancayo is one
of these hills or mountains around here
okay and alto means top or tall so a
tall monkayo right okay okay
well actually that's a good analogy
because here's something i'm going to
tell you
but two of their wines got a hundred
points from robert parker at a place
that made two 100 point wines yeah 100
point wines are mythical they're like
unicorns
don't exist no
so hurry up
let's get there
and let's have some 100.1 let's go
thank you guys for having us here today
this is our first vineyard that we're
visiting in the aragon region can you
tell us a little bit about the area
where we're at and the types of grapes
that you grow here and just a little bit
about your your vineyard
bueno brazil
one of the reasons i'm so excited to be
here is that
you guys
were able to make a 100 point wine it's
a
mythical moment
no one
does this and you did
back i believe in 2007 2009 your
granasha got 100 points from
i would love to know what that was like
where were you and what were you doing
when you found out that you had gotten
100 points and who did you call who did
you notify
you
especially
tell me about what it must have been
like to what it must have felt like to
try to chase
after that great award
[Music]
so this is our first
visit to this area and you're the first
vineyard we're visiting and obviously
we're going to visit some more vineyards
but what are some other things within
the aragon region that we have to see
[Music]
[Applause]
it's
aragon is a place steeped in history and
that is evident in its villages
terrafona it's one of the most
outstanding mudejar settings of aragon
[Music]
there is another village that we must
visit sos del rey cathalico and is so
named because the king fernando catholic
was born here
this village is located in an area
called the five villages the earliest
information from this town is from the
year 211 bc
this is this is such a big big part of
spain aragon is
ginormous it is but did i tell you where
we're going no
so i was reading this article where they
rank
the beauty of the little villages in
spain yeah and there's a list of 30 of
them
supposedly 10 of them are in an arab wow
[Music]
alcazar is in the region of so montano
and has a spectacular environment it has
many details that make it unique
[Music]
the wine tradition of this territory is
clearly evident
proof of this is in the traditional
wineries and family members of the
villages
located in the mountains well preserved
until today
the winemaking tradition here is more
than eight centuries old
and of course the verwela monastery has
been the key piece in the history of
wine in aragon
the monks of the monastery of verwela
were great promoters and cultivators of
the grape variety garnacha
[Music]
you ever figure how much how long this
took to build
from verwela we go to the monastery de
piedra an impressive place
in it there is a monastery from the 13th
century and a historical garden park
from the 19th century with innumerable
waterfalls and an exuberant flora
the gardens in nature here are as
impressive as the history the truth is
that between nature and history i'm not
sure which one wins
one of the best things about this region
is that there is generational renewal
young people have returned to the fields
we cannot leave campo de borja without
getting to know bodegas aragonesis
this winery is a cooperative of many
farmers
this is the first winery in spain to
market the wines of their farmers
and today produces more than 20 million
bottles
debbie thank you for having us here
today um can you tell us a little bit
about where we are and what your role is
here okay so first thank you to you for
visiting us and we are in moderatas it
was the the first limited company
created in spain to market the wines of
a cooperative
so david
how does a cooperative differ from a
like a smaller independent type of of
winery okay so what we have
wine here so
let's
let's try it so you will see thank you i
can explain you also there were a lot of
growers in the cooperative
they didn't have the means to to work
properly the the grapes but we have
people the wine makers we call it land
winemakers who are working whole year
with them we own thousand five hundred
hectares of old vines we're not over 40
years old is that what's considered old
40 years and older there's not
really a rule in our case we consider
that
for a vine
40 years start to be
old actually some growers not here but
in some other regions when the vineyards
reach the age of 40
some they cut that's why we say i'm glad
they don't do that to people
you had 40.
you're done
you see a lot of young people coming
into the wine business and especially
bringing up vineyards and working in the
fields
or is it an older type of industry
in the last
six seven years a lot of young growers
had come back to town really yes so
there are around 400
growers in the town
and the whole population is 800 so you
know that means that everybody have a
smaller or bigger plot of vineyards some
some actors they have a very good
education and they have even university
studies and the thing is that some of
them they moved to the city to try to
change the way of living
but
well we had this big crisis in in spain
and so they decided to come back but
they realized that it was a steady job
sure a good job a way of living is there
innovation in wine making compared to
let's say 50 years ago i mean are these
younger people using different
processes or are they doing things in
the traditional way the good thing of
these young people is that they bring
new ideas
new challenges so
yeah of course nothing to do the way
we work now the vineyards than 50 years
ago so david you're on the business side
of the the wine industry and one of the
things you must think about is how do we
get millennials or younger people
drinking wine right the more that
younger folks consume wine the better it
is for the industry so what are you
doing or what do you see for trends to
get young people
interested in wine i read the other day
that 40 percent
of the young people between 18 and 30
years old in spain they never tried a
glass of wine
wow 40
so that's shocking yeah yeah hands they
don't know what's missing
so
that's
a very hard job for us
to cheer them up to to drink wine
you know we are
we're heading to
ferragota and and
i am
not all that familiar with that city and
and what's there and what's available
for us to do do you have some
recommendations for us on on what to see
uh when we're in theragotha okay so when
in tarawatha you cannot miss
the basilic of el pilar okay which is
actually the second largest basilic in
the world after vatican in the world in
the world after vatican
and of course to drink wine and to eat
own tapas you have to go el tubo in the
old part of the town
no not at all thank you thank you and
thank you for the wine it was wonderful
cheers
[Music]
we will follow david's recommendation
and we will try local wines in altubo in
the center of theragosa
we are going to discover it with some of
the locals our ambassadors on this trip
and of course you have to try the
spanish omelet which they call tortilla
what do we do what do we have to see how
do we really experience el tubo la
question solo tomaruinos or comedo is
[Music]
ah
we are going to another of the wineries
in aragon karanena
karanyana is located in the ebro valley
it is comprised of 16 000 hectares of
vineyards
the soil here is unique in that it is
made up mainly of stone and they have a
term
crafted in stone which is used to
describe their wines
the wines are also influenced by a dry
wind of this area called thierso which
blows from the north helping regulate
the vineyards and prevent them from pest
and disease
crafted in stone
what does that mean and why is that
unique to this this region the stones
together with the
this kind of wind that you experience
today that is called thiertho those are
the main factors that gives the
character and the
powerful to the this wine so that's why
so sierra that's not a word for win win
is vienta biento right so that you
actually named the win because it's
always here it's always here and it's
typical of this area so
i know that there has been a
a past issue with moths coming in
and
breeding and their larva getting into
the grapes and making the grapes rotten
i hear you've got an interesting
approach to this called sexual confusion
uh how would explain that what what
it's peaked by interest i've never heard
of sexually confused grapes
well the grapes are not confused what
we're trying is to confuse the the road
when the larvae these butterflies eat
the grapes in the summer we can have
this rottenness so what we do is to
create with pheromones of the female a
whole extension
that smells like the female so the male
cannot find the female so there is no
next generation of rod so we avoid the
the plaque those poor guys they're out
there looking for girls that don't exist
go to why
discord you make a confuse also you're
not not finding the
the right partner and you're not coming
next generation man
it's pheromones
and and this must be uh
good news obviously for the health of
the grape well it's good news for the
health of the grapes and for the
environment because what we're doing
when you use pesticides you cannot
select
exactly who you're killing and you might
kill some our insects so we have
recovered a lot of birds coming back to
the to the vine so the the growers are
telling us that they are listening again
to birds when they are working on the
field so sexual confusion is a good
thing it sounds like it is
do
do all the cooperatives um undertake
this process do you work together on
that or is it just one whole territory
is working with that i mean we are not
the first ones using uh the pheromones
but we're the biggest area in spain
using this technique because being
cooperative has helped to come together
and so cooperating is easy to do for us
a follow-up to that
how do you feel america is doing in
embracing
spanish wines what do you think a
spanish wine is doing in america the
american
consumer is driven a lot by it by the
type of grape he wants to
to to try and to and to drink and
karnataka has started to be something
special in in the states when i drive
around i see little villages
not
big cities so you're doing these big
things
in these and from these villages that
are that are smaller tell us about
the people here the people from
canadiana
is like
the
the soils from canadiana in the the
first impression is like a stone
more or less it's very hard very
enclosed
but they are
friendly
very very
loyal
that sounds like boston
no it doesn't
sure friendly and loyal he said after
after you get to know them oh after you
get to right well first we're cold we're
closed we don't want to talk to anybody
once you get to know us we're your best
friends we love you you're welcome but
it takes a little while i'm going to ask
you a very unfair question i want you to
tell me each of you like the what is the
one thing that you love best about
aragon
for me the the food is amazing is
spectacular yes
i think
you cannot leave aragon without this
discovering goya
actually his hometown is nearby here
yeah
okay well another thing that you can to
find out the the aragon character is
is one of the biggest
dessert in in in europe is los monegros
has been a defensive line in all the in
all the history of uh wars in through
spain where ocean well spent really bad
time and then to finish up with a high
spirit and drink up some garnacha from
aragon we can do those
well thank you thank you for having us
on the recommendations
[Music]
let's go for anna's recommendation
fuente todos is about 30 kilometers away
from caranina
here we can visit the house in which
francisco de goya was born in 1746
he was one of the greatest geniuses of
the painting world and essential
painters of spanish
so rosa can you sum up for us who who
was goya um
universal
[Music]
his works can be found in many places
including the el palar his first
commission where he had studied drawing
since he was 13 years old
goya was the most important european
artist of his time and the one who
exerted most influence in the later
evolution of painting since his last
works are considered precursors of
impressionism his paintings are
prominently displayed in the prado in
madrid and his presence is still felt in
this area today
the food in aragon is reason enough to
visit it is an agricultural and
livestock land that has been producing
top quality products for generations
from the tarewell ham to the saffron
that some say is the best in the world
but if there is a king product in aragon
it is the black truffle
aragon sets the prices nationally for
being the first world producer and today
we are going to look for it
we are going to discover the gastronomy
of aragon with one of the greatest
experts in the area carmelo bosque
he is one of the star chefs in the area
and has had a michelin ranked restaurant
for many years
be
we are in the kitchen with a
a michelin star three-time chef i am
freaking out
[Laughter]
it's the biggest piece of celery i've
ever seen
wow
you can taste almonds right away i'll
bring that back
we're going to get more products
[Music]
is
okay
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
wow
i don't want to get in the way of that
it was fantastic absolutely fantastic
we are going to the biggest desert in
europe los manegros
it is a sparsely populated area of spain
where only 7.6 people per kilometer live
in 1937 george orwell arrived in spain
with the task of covering the spanish
civil war that took place in 1936
so we are in the aragon front line and
now we are standing on the republican
side
and what is very nice from here is that
if you look right there outside on the
other hill we can see the fastest
positions
over there yeah over there on that
how long were they fighting in this
position oh the work was long here like
almost two years holy for three years
yeah and they kept firing shots back and
forth between the sides yeah but
actually not all the time because the
weapons were super old so they were not
strong
so they looked they just stared at each
other yeah sometimes they were just
insulting each other microphones
that's real really really yeah yeah
that's real
was fighting in this position yeah and
here here animal farm makes a lot of
sense to me now yeah actually a lot of
his experiences here are reflected and
he is right yeah that that makes sense
yeah so we're looking out from where
george orwell was looking yeah exactly
insulting the other side
i bet he had the best insults because he
was an author right
[Laughter]
[Music]
take this
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
i know we're going to say castilla
yeah between the monegros and the
pyrenees there is the salmontano in
huesca
san montano has led aragon in the total
innovation process of the production and
marketing of wine exploded in terms of
the
wine culture and tourism and
oh my goodness this is so beautiful
we are in the castilla valley
this is the quietest place that we have
in our land
it's 40 kilometers to the south from the
pyrenees to the border with france
the pyrenees the
mountains cut here the
cool
wind to the north and this is very good
place to grow vines
we were driving here
in this beautiful country just
stunning how beautiful somatano is
i um
and we were discussing winemaking and we
said it's a you know a little bit
science a little bit art would you agree
i mean are you
are you are you doing things differently
to blend to create different flavors are
you growing different grapes all over
well
the places is amazing to work because we
can try here different things but small
plots small parcels
give you uh
different wines think about it if you
have a hill we have in fact
four expressions of wine it's a
different orientation yeah
if you are able to blend it
the wine will be of course richer than
more complex and return
what part of the wine making process do
you think is the most artistic or
creative is it
planting the vines is it blending the
wines is it in the process
in all process because we have in now in
uh
the rural world i mean that ferrari is
the expression of alan
but in this case the artists of the
windmaker
need to respect that the deterrent gives
to the wine this is the expression of
the wine and of course the blend
different plots and different
expressions but after that
don't change a lot the wine with the
aging in oak
and in this case it's very important the
condition of each year the weather
because
change a bit the wine this is not a wine
for the global market it's a wine for a
few or few people
that's what i want to do you won an
award
like
the best wine in
by who how tell us about this award
the best wine of um in international
wine challenge from london
the best
wine red wine of spain the best grenada
of the world the best wow
fifty thousand
uh wines were tasty fifty thousand
thousand you were numerono
i would like to introduce you
my friend nathan matthew i'm danny
hunter
how is a
lunch in the vineyards that
people use usually
serious put it right on the coast he's
at uh at 10 o'clock right we're a little
late that workers of the over there
[Music]
please
aragon is a place known worldwide for
its mountains
let's check out the sierra de guara in
the province of weska
this place is a pilgrimage point for
mountain lovers from all corners of
spain and the world
[Music]
you is regret it or forget it i just
like to thank everybody for making it
[Music]
the captain's gonna set your hearts on
fire
[Music]
i'm saying we should
intertwine
[Music]
i got how to do it
to your desire the captain's going to
say
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm guessing when we get to the top of
this hill
that there's gonna be we're gonna be
able to see over this whole valley
you wanna listen to some music
[Music]
let's go to the westernmost part of
aragon kalatayud
the wines here are soft and with good
balance between alcohol and acidity
[Music]
bodega san alejandro is a good example
from this region yolanda is one of the
few women in spain that manages a
company in the sector and this is
noticed in every little detail
her work has earned her deep respect
from the farmers in the area
can you help me understand what the
difference is in luth did i say did i
say that right first of all because the
my spanish is
a lot of people have problems to
pronounce it because they used to say
catalyte but it's called okay so i got
it right so help me understand the
difference in this region versus other
regions in aragon in turn i think that
kala tayut is in a very privileged
location it's one of the highest one in
spain not not even in aragon but in
spain
working with grenache we are up to 1100
meters
feet or something like that
sometimes we lose half of the production
so that's a big risk and also we have to
do everything by hand
so yolanda how do you handle the risk it
seems really risky to grow grapes in
this region do you take out an insurance
policy on the
vines or do you just live with it
we just live with it i mean when you're
born here you understand that it has to
be like that
we have 210 growers but not all of them
are just focus on
vines they really know how is the risk
so they want to diversify it and that's
why they have other productions when
you're growing this variety in these
special locations you can demonstrate
that you can get very nice concentration
very beautiful color and you can put it
in the barrel and still keep the fruit
but it only happens if it's all veneers
low production and so on you're
suffering all during the whole year but
at the end we have the results
speaking of the structure of the wine
how would it taste different here
than perhaps from
borja you can talk about the same
variety but the wines are completely of
different profile wines in kaladaya
youth can be more fruity they are very
mineral because we have a lot of slates
a lot of balsamic because we are in the
mountains
and very very concentrate i propose you
if you if you like the the experience of
being winemaker for a day so here we are
in our winemaker for a day lab
so but before here is our one of our
wine makers family
uh he's going to help us to do this
activity but before blending the wines i
think that we have to test your senses
okay okay so i'm gonna use this because
i don't want you to see anything at all
okay you can put it on all right you
don't see anything no not at all
you only have to tell us if you're
drinking a white wine or a red wine this
one first and
here you have okay this is the glass
yeah you can smell it i wanna see if you
can do it just by the smell
i think this is white now we go for next
and you tell me if it's white
or red also just a second
here you have it okay okay okay
and you guess
no no no that was red this is white this
is white
or you change your mind stop it
you're confusing me
i don't know
um if
you want to see him
can
one more test
delicious
okay you take it out this is red
yeah very good
so now we're gonna test your scents but
in this case it's not gonna be this the
eyes it's gonna be the nose okay so
you have to put this in your nose
you will not smell anything
and i'm gonna talk really funny
do you look gorgeous
okay this is the candy i choose
you only have to say the flavor
some kind of a berry berry maybe are you
sure no but which kind of berry
strawberry strawberry that's my guess
yeah i think you're right because look
at the paper red strawberry very good
yeah because normally people used to to
talk about the flavor of a strawberry
but the strawberry is not a flavor it's
a smell so if you're not using your nose
it's difficult right can i take this off
yeah sure
wow it changed completely now it's
exactly that yeah
so after tasting your senses now it's
time to blend here we have four
different wines
then you have to blend as you want
four wines two of them is garnacha and
the other two are siva
you're completing it
will be the one telling which one is the
the winner
it's very important to remember the
amount of wine that you are using
do we have pencils we don't have pencils
to take notes but good point yes
if not because
i might create the greatest line and
he'll say do that again and i'll be like
[Music]
this is my option
are you sure i am sure
occupational hazard
yeah
i got the thumbs up
no no no no it's a it's a bit different
between the wines yeah because i think
that you are using much more shira
correct and you are using much more
garnacha
of course we are not doing garnet
my option
is
[Laughter]
we are going to meet one of the best
performers of the hota yolanda larpa
la hota in aragon is the equivalent of
flamenco and andalucia
presented
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
yes
to finish understanding aragon we must
have a global perspective
let's do this with fernando mora a newly
appointed master of wine we are going to
valdejalon in the center of the wine
regions that we have already seen
congratulations yeah so i understand you
just got the award recently like in the
last week or two no no no it was just
just two days ago yesterday two days ago
i returned yesterday with my my title
you have the title now yeah yeah i have
it yeah yeah i bring it to show you here
one moment
so look at this oh my god at the end
i got it
we gotta get
let's show my one of my top vineyards
for us this is a very special vineyard
of macaveo and garnacha tinta can you
help me understand what the difference
is between a master of wine and a master
sommelier okay the program consists only
in exams some of them are blind tasting
you need to find the place and the grape
and how the wine is made and the vintage
and the other part is to to do exams
about beautiful terminology business of
wise so a bit of everything a master one
is a person who
or they are wine makers or people
involved in the trade or journalists or
consultants it seems like a very
prestigious
now that we understand what it is what
does this mean to you ah for me a lot of
things imagine that so i am an engineer
and i used to do windmills for power
generation so this is like a challenge
so i have transformed my life from an
industrial
guy to a wine guy
we have much better customers at the
moment otherwise has more recognition
and also we have learned to how to make
better wine because if you taste 1200
wines per year that kind of things open
you the mind and you create your own
thing wow wow what was your biggest
challenge in obtaining the master of
wine
for me like like a dream i started
making wine at home in a bathtub
yeah not the grapes
that's not very healthy but i use it i
did in the wine in a plastic bucket yeah
and i used to put the plastic bucket in
the tube with water and ice outside to
control the temperature
for me it's not a matter of money it's
more the passion and you wake up every
morning
and you say yes
so fernando one of the things i
understand from the exams that you do is
a blind taste testing of 36 different
wines yeah and i'm assuming
that they're from all over the world
how does aragon and the wines from this
region
fit in the global market from a
reputation and and quality perspective
yeah we can go to dinner together i can
bring some wines some garnachas from the
different parts of aragon
and we can can see if if you find the
differences as i did that would be yeah
that'd be great thank
it is time to test our knowledge of wine
hey hey hey louie good to see you how
are you
we had a great day great i have a second
surprise for tonight so he is the best
family of spain 2017. hey i'm dan you
know what he's from aragon
really yeah let's taste that garnachas
and see if you can be masters of white
after one time right
so
let's play
so i have five glasses all of them are
garnacha one is from carinena one is
from calata youth from campo de borja
from so montano and also from the region
that we have been this morning where we
and we are making wine vale
okay
so instead of tasting separately what we
are going is to taste all together and
we are trying to find aromatics and the
differences
and after that we will guess which
region is in each glass so let's start
with the glass number one
wait wait fernando i can you give us
some guidance on like what regions have
certain
qualities yeah okay let's start with
cariena
the ones usually are more in the red
fruit
with medium acidity and with a touch of
oak
a calata youth is the highest in
altitude so also red fruit and spices
style
and with higher acidity okay okay
so while the halon is
in the middle of both and usually the
styles are a bit fresher the wines are a
bit more crunchy crunchy yeah yeah so so
montano usually the garnachas are a bit
more awkward okay and capoeira the more
trendy ones now in cambodia are more in
the red spectrum with some balsamics and
touch of oak right now i can
point to the water as clear as a choice
you got the first one the first one
so let's start with the first glass
do you pick more the red or the black
fruit oh my gosh spices and you i think
vanilla i don't know what it is but i
want to drink it right oh my goodness
damn oh definitely more peppery
it's a bit mineral this is so cool
but have you seen the diversity if you
change the soil or if you change the
altitude definitely change the aroma
like smoked bacon
i felt like this was was from borja
and then this was from somatano
i agree with you
are you changed are you are you sorry
but i've been coming around no i'm
waiting on the balsamic on number two
that is that is that cool thank you yes
okay not bad
well one is one is okay the second one
is oh you got me there i knew it tasted
okay very nice yeah
now we think we said someone said
that's what i thought
okay oh cool
next one we thought
you thought that it was a frontone i
thought it was just actually
okay cool number five is
okay
canadienal how you did that
was absolutely fascinating at the end
garnacha as he say is a terror
translator an aragon show one of the
best
spectrums of garments in the world let's
do a toast no let's do it okay
so
far
thank you thank you
i will be back
no question
it's saying drink me
[Music]
aragon is rich immense in landscape and
agriculture its wines are a reflection
of its people
spain is an amazing place
it is an impressive country its wines
have made me discover the richness of
its landscape and the joy of its people
spain is immense in all of its aspects
spain you are addictive
once you experience it you are hooked
just like your wines
adios spain hello friends
[Music]
foreign
pull it anything
[Music]
[Applause]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elise shafak
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
i'm here in the maraca suite which is
the famous
underwater suite here at the conrad
maldives
so this suite is 40 000
plus plus per night that is to say
it starts at forty thousand dollars but
with that you get a chef
you get a personal butler and there's an
exercise room there's all kinds of stuff
you get with it but yeah
forty thousand dollars a night if you
wanna sleep under here the suite is
absolutely insane i mean look at it
so you got a little sitting room here so
you just chill out
watch the fish
oh my favorite part
is here
so this toilet situation is pretty
insane and my favorite thing is when you
get close to it
it opens automatically look at that
this is your view
while you do your business under the sea
and then
the stairway going all the way up
so the structure itself
was designed by an architect named ahmed
saleem and morocca means coral in the
native language of the maldives which is
diveki
so it's named after the coral reef that
it sits upon
i mean this is just
peak luxury
it is huge and spacious
you've got a spare forty thousand
dollars this doesn't seem like a bad way
to spend it
[Music]
[Applause]
so etha is the underwater restaurant of
the maldives it was the first of its
kind and it's made by the same people
that did the maraca suite so it's pretty
cool you get to eat lunch with a bunch
of fish swimming over your head so uh
let's go check it out
[Music]
yeah you have to have a reservation to
get in it's also a fixed price menu so
you get seven courses and they just
start feeding you
a little face towel when i got in which
i always love it
smells really nice nice and cool
okay so this is the first course here it
is a snow crab and hamachi salad i don't
see any snow crabs around so hopefully
we're not
offending anybody
[Music]
for one person it came to 252
i wanted to get a glass of white wine
and the waiter said that it was a
hundred and fifty dollars i passed on
the glass of wine and just stuck with
still water and they still got me for 45
for prices in the maldives whatever you
think it's going to be it's going to be
more
right thank you
[Music]
bees are everywhere
all but unnoticed as they fly from
flower to flower
they've existed much longer than man
but over the last 8 000 years man and
bee have become partners
[Music]
in 2006 reports came out of america that
millions of bees had disappeared from
their hives
it sounds like a science fiction horror
film
but it's not
since the mid-1990s beekeepers have been
reporting extraordinary losses
everywhere in the industrialized world
bees are dying
and beekeepers don't know what to do
scientists from many disciplines have
mobilized to confront this global
problem
in the last four years what have they
learned
can science provide an explanation
a cure
or a solution
[Music]
is it too late to save this tiny
creature from extinction
why should we care
[Music]
so
each year beekeepers everywhere perform
the same spring ritual
on a sunny day they opened their hives
to see how their bees survived the
rigors of winter
over the last four years this ritual has
become a nightmare
in europe and the americas beekeepers
find losses of 30 to 80 percent
and no one knows why
[Music]
it's more than just my income
it's uh
these are my girls my bees so i hate to
see you know i feel like i let them down
some because you know
obviously we didn't do things right here
possibly we could have done more for
them to save them so
it's uh it's sad for sure
like thousands of other beekeepers ben
hogan will have no honey harvest this
summer
but it's not the loss of honey that has
scientists like bernard vassiere at the
french national institute for
agricultural research devoting countless
hours to studying bees
bees are fundamental to the human food
chain
most of our food crops are pollinated by
bees
and that includes almost every fruit
vegetable oil and nut
[Music]
importance
services
don't
[Music]
seeking nectar at the heart of the
flower bees inadvertently transfer
pollen to the female organ of the plant
the elaborate beauty of flowers has not
evolved simply for our pleasure
it serves to attract pollinators and
signals a food source for bees
with fewer bees crops become less
productive
orchards less fruitful
and scientists are asking what's the
fewest bees we can get away with and
still have a workable agriculture
it's a question no one would have
thought to ask just a few years ago
but there was a global crisis in the
making the agricultural demand for
pollinators is growing much more quickly
than the supply
in 2006 the danger became clear
maladies swept through american apiaries
bees simply started disappearing
leaving empty hives
scientists named the phenomenon colony
collapse disorder
ccd
alarm by the sudden threat to the
national agricultural economy the us
congress called on beekeepers and
scientists to explain the deadly malady
for a moment anyway the bees had a voice
in congress
may berenbaum spoke for the ccd
scientific task force
even before ccd we estimated if honeybee
numbers continue to decline at the rates
documented from 1989 to 1996 managed
honeybees in the united states will
cease to exist by 2035.
colony collapse disorder is an unusual
phenomenon characterized by the sudden
massive disappearance of the majority of
workers in a honeybee colony leaving
behind viable brood or larvae a small
contingent of nurse bees and a healthy
queen and abundant food supplies
colony collapse disorder progressed
inexorably from state to state
everywhere the same scenario
abandoned brood abandoned honey
no corpses around the hives
urgency mounted as a total of 35 states
were affected
[Music]
scientists suspected a new pathogen
perhaps the newly introduced or mutated
virus
one of the early discoveries was a new
virus israeli acute paralysis virus
which had never been described before in
america
and that got a lot of attention and in
that initial screening there was a
relationship that we still see between
that virus and ccd
the breakthrough promised to cure a
magic bullet but hope was short-lived
as a complete explanatory factor israeli
acute paralysis virus really fell short
a few
months after that report was released
when other investigators went into their
freezers pulled out specimens and
demonstrated that iapv has been in the
u.s since at least 2002 which antidates
the appearance of colony collapse
disorder
a dead end
and scientists have had to ask
themselves if this phenomenon might not
have a single cause
is it a convergence of several factors
or is there one primary cause that
weakens bees allowing pathogens to take
a heavy toll for now it rests just a
sudden disappearance of bees
cause unknown
pesticides have been in vogue virus
diseases have been invoked cell
telephones have been in in vogue ufos
have been invoked all sorts of
sort of things some of them sensible
some of them just cockamamie but
nonetheless we really don't know what
uh what initiates it
the mystery only deepened as reports
came in of colony collapse around the
world
massive bee deaths in south america
in taiwan in china in india
five million bees reported disappeared
in just 48 hours in croatia
and all over the rest of europe millions
of unexplained deaths
but is it a single illness
without a recognized cause it's
impossible to say
summer in provence is a sun-drenched
paradise for bees and beekeepers
but there's trouble in paradise
even here bee populations have been
steadily and quietly declining for more
than 60 years
everywhere in the world
declines in bee populations have
followed the development of industrial
agriculture
[Music]
the post-war world demanded food for a
hungry population
and in the name of efficiency and
productivity
chemicals and machines were turned to a
war against nature
government policies transformed the
landscape to serve the needs of modern
agriculture
hedgerows were plowed under fields
enlarged and leveled
technicians replaced farmers as
agricultural specialists
and beekeepers faced a new challenge as
every insect was chased from every
flowering crop
um
foreign
in the night when the bees are in their
hives shawn and remy brune move their
colonies
at 16 hours of grueling work two million
bees moved over 200 kilometers
from the komark to the lavender fields
of provence
despite heavy stress on the bees they
have to do it twice a year now both to
protect their bees from insecticides and
to bring them to fresh flowers
[Applause]
but there is yet another threat for the
bruins to deal with
in the 1980s a new pest arrived in
france destroying bee colonies and
beekeepers
[Music]
was first seen among bee colonies in
asia
over the last 30 years a worldwide
market in queens and specially bred bees
has spread varroa into nearly every
honeybee colony in europe africa and the
americas
varroa is a parasitic blood-sucking mite
it's very small it's only about two
millimeters in diameter and it fixes
onto the bee's body like a crab laos and
it bites the bee and sucks its blood
and in the process of doing that it
infects the bee with any viruses that it
happens to be carrying so the overall
effect on a bee colony is it weakens the
bees and they tend to get viruses
and in particular the queen who lives a
lot longer than the other bees she tends
to be badly affected
fighting varroa is trying to kill a bug
on a bug
it's hard to find a chemical to kill the
mite and not harm the bee
over time the chemicals lodge in the wax
diffusing a constant low dosage of
pesticide
and in a cruel and vicious circle the
mites become resistant and the bees
weaken
but without chemicals
the colony dies
and so the introduction of varroa mite
into the country in the 1980s had a real
effect
on the ability of viruses to get
transmitted from colony to colony and so
that's probably what's killing most of
the colonies we usually blame varroa
mite but it's probably the viruses that
the varroa mites are are mediating
on west de la france the colonies resist
over
[Music]
bees with this remarkable trait of
resistance managed to control the
population of varroa mites by killing
infected poopy and ejecting them from
the colony
it's a real form of social cooperation
but how do these resistant honey bees
differ from those millions dying from
varroa
dr lacan sent samples to gene robinson
leader of the team that sequenced the
honey bee genome in 2006
my colleague eve leconte in france has
identified some honeybees some strains
of honeybees that are more resistant to
varroa than other strains
he sent samples of those strains to my
laboratory and we analyzed their gene
activity using the microwave technique
to see if we might get some clues about
the basis for the resistance
we were very pleasantly surprised to see
that the main differences between the
strains that are more resistant to
varroa compared to those that are more
susceptible the main differences had to
do with activity in genes associated
with behavior
varroa resistance is a collective rather
than individual form of immunity it's
called hygienic behavior
compared to other insects that have been
sequenced honeybees have fewer genes for
immunity and detoxification
the individual is by nature weak in the
face of pathogens and poisons
but incredibly a strong genetic
disposition for social cooperation can
compensate in part for this weakness in
individual honeybees genes
the genes suggest that the resistant
strains may be more sensitive to uh some
odors associated with the presence of
varroa that kind of information can lead
to improvements in breeding strategies
to be able to breed more resistant
honeybees
but is it really quite so easy as it
sounds
artificial insemination is more suited
to the laboratory than the apiary
the tibor zebos senior and junior are
commercial queen breeders and with bees
dying everywhere business is good
scientists all over the world they are
talking about yuck we want to breed bees
resistant to the mites or some of them
are tolerant to the might but how can we
get that breeding a bee that's resistant
to varroa mites is like breeding sheep
that are resistant to wolves yeah it may
be possible but it's extremely difficult
and we are not sure how the bees have an
incredible reproductive potential and as
long as we can maximize it we can stay
ahead of a lot of its problems but it's
a constant effort
[Music]
the life of the colony depends on the
queen
there's only one she's the mother of
every bee in the hive
workers feed and groom her day and night
and encourage her to lay up to 2000 eggs
per day
she gives off a chemical signal a
pheromone that calms and coordinates the
workers
should her pheromone weaken or should
she stop laying the workers will raise a
new queen
a queenless colony is doomed
the art of the breeder is to trick the
worker bees into thinking they need a
new queen
there's one in each cage
we do that because if they could access
each other
they'd fight
the queens are worth between 20 and 30
each depending on the amount that the
customer buys uh if they buy uh over a
hundred queens here they're twenty
dollars each so this box would be worth
two thousand eighty dollars to the
beekeeper
you could make 104 hives with this one
box
the market determines the character of
honeybees
beekeepers favor bees that are gentle
and productive and that's what breeders
try to deliver
in north america just a few hundred
breeders supply the hundreds of
thousands of queens bought and sold on
the continent each year
the result is an increasingly uniform
bee population
made worse by the fact that honeybees
are not native to north america they
were imported by colonists in the 17th
century
all the bees share a limited gene pool
anytime you have a lack of diversity the
population is more likely to be
susceptible to diseases or to to
problems and so we do think that that is
potentially one of the things that could
be contributing we don't think it's the
cause of ccd or of the decline of
honeybees but as far as honeybees go it
could be one of the weaknesses in in our
population of honeybees
if bees around the world are weak in the
face of disease it's largely to demand
trying to breed the perfect bee can
eliminate traits bees need in order to
adapt to a changing environment
long before men appeared bees were
adapting to local conditions on their
own tuning themselves to their regions
tough black bees from northern latitudes
learned to store more honey in a shorter
time to survive a long winter
the aggressive native black bee has
learned to live in this harsh scottish
climate through thousands of generations
of adaptation
in willie robson has adapted his
beekeeping to their needs
my father taught beekeeping in the 50s
and i remember my father saying well
we'll start away and those that die good
riddance
and from then on we've worked on on that
principle that if they didn't manage to
survive the winter
then that was a good that was a good way
to be
and our aim which is we what we've
achieved is to have total natural
resistance to all the known diseases of
bees
as varroa progresses we'll have to hope
they start to become resistant to that
as well
and that probably will occur not in my
lifetime but within the next 50 years
the bees are well able to adapt
to these sort of things
using traditional methods willie robson
has become one of the largest honey
producers in scotland
the foundation of his philosophy is a
simple trust in nature
i think as soon as you start breeding
them
pure
for docility
honey production
you breed out a whole lot of other
necessary qualities
and that brings in itself trouble yeah
once you breathe out that the disease
resistant element
uh you never recover that never never
recovers you then you
then you you're required to put in
chemicals to control the disease
there's only a very fine line that you
can take
when meddling with nature
before you get into trouble you know and
the trouble costs you 10 times as much
as you would think
you know
trouble gets in trouble with anything
any living thing is is
a real headache you know
in an ideal world willie robson would be
a model
but it's too late
if beekeepers everywhere adopted total
natural resistance most of their bees
would die
without this large-scale force of
pollinators the entire agricultural
economy would collapse
actually
[Music]
agriculture developed over centuries in
an environment with a diversity of
pollinators
the domestic honeybee is just one of
many bees that visit crops
there are at least 19 000 species of
wild bees on the planet
but they're disappearing too
all right this is a small one
so we've got over 30 species of bees in
my backyard and that's without me
spending much time looking for them
is a little sweat bee
declines in wild bees have been
documented since 1992
but no one knows the original
populations
different species of bumblebees that
used to be fairly common have just gone
through the floor some of them we can
still find in out of the way places you
know high mountains in colorado or in
northern bc
but we can't find them in places where
sometimes they made up 30 percent of the
bees you'd find somewhere now they're
completely gone
lawrence packer runs the largest wild
bee lab in the world
[Music]
wild bee's responsible for pollinating
most of the wild flowers out there and
so imagine what would happen if all of a
sudden the reproduction of wild flowers
stopped there'd be no fruit and berries
to feed the birds there'd be no
nuts and berries to feed the beers the
squirrels will be in trouble the whole
terrestrial ecosystem as we know it
would be very different if all of a
sudden all the bees disappeared
some wild bees are very specialized
pollinators
they might seek food from a single
flowering plant
and if the bee disappears
so does the flower
you see it all the way up there
in gap
foreign
[Music]
wild bees don't have varroa
they don't have viruses in common with
honeybees
but something is killing both
populations
in the impact of lost pollinators goes
far beyond the human diet
for paul ehrlich a founder of the
science of co-evolution bees have the
task of keeping the world alive
it's very scary
to see bees and other pollinators not
doing well because they are what are
sometimes called mobile links they move
around and connect things in nature when
the things that connect things in nature
aren't doing well that's not a great
sign
one of the most important aspects of how
evolution works of how we get the
organisms that populate our planet that
support our lives and that of course
evolution created us
is not just
uh evolution operating under the
pressures created by the physical
environment that is by cold or uh winds
or something up but of course other
organisms create selection pressures so
that for example uh
plants and bees have evolved together
over over time so that the bees get
their nourishment from the plants and
the plants get their sex from the bees
these kinds of co-evolutionary complexes
are among the most important aspects of
the whole process of evolution
it's not just bees and flowers that
evolve together
co-evolution is a web
and it includes one creature that has a
critical impact on every living thing
man
for the first time in history the scale
of the activities of the human system
finally are impinging in a big way on
the natural system and that's why for
the first time in human history we have
the threat of a collapse of a global
civilization others we may go down the
drain in part because of the bees
[Music]
there is a place where all the elements
of collapse have been carefully prepared
a place engineered beyond nature
where monoculture has replaced
biodiversity
it's an ecology totally dependent on the
whim of man
[Music]
it's called the central valley of
california
at the end of february
when every flower of 700 000 acres of
blooming almond trees
needs pollination
[Music]
over 36 billion bees are needed
it's the world's largest seasonal animal
migration
without bees wind pollination produces
about forty pounds of nuts per acre
with bee pollination they produce three
thousand pounds per acre
sixty times more
eighty percent of the world's almonds
grow here
if you look at almonds in california
that's the biggest story there is
right now
half of the colonies in the country get
moved to california for the almond
pollination
by 2012 we expected 86 of present-day
number
colonies to move into california for
pollination now if the number of
colonies decreases at the present rate
that every colony in the country
conceivably would need to be in
california for pollination
you know almonds makes more money for
the california economy than grapes and
wine do and so there is that need that
real need for those bees
how do almond growers get the bees they
need
they place a call to a cramped and
cluttered office on a side street in
bakersfield california where joe trainer
has spent 40 years putting beekeepers
and orchard owners together
joe traynor is a bee broker
oh yeah frank yeah when i first started
in the 1960s there was enough bees in
california to take care of the entire
acreage
which was about a hundred thousand at
that time and
the rental fees were bees at that time
was about three dollars a colony but
since the acreage expanded 650 000
bearing acres now
there's not enough bees in california to
handle that so we get bees from all over
the united states and
it's the transportation cost of
bringing those bees out to california
has driven the price up it's it's in the
anywhere from 130 to almost 200 dollars
rental feeding out
joe traynor promises beekeepers a good
price for the rental of their hives
and promises growers strong hives for
efficient pollination
my job is to put the bee in prosperity's
path
my job is to identify where she will do
best so i have to kind of think like a
bee
i have to think about the resources
available and
and
in pollination work it's it's a contract
so i'm guided by
revenue enhancing the revenue
like you can hear it can you hear it
for john miller the sound of bees is the
sound of money
and we're looking for flight we're
looking for
i want to see what the dancing ladies
are doing here
here look at this blossom right here see
this guy he just opened and the pollen
grains are on the right on the flat into
the flowering parts
this guy is yesterday's blossom and it's
all set see the difference between this
and this
the pollen's been forged and gathered
and
and stirred up by the honeybee as she
rummages around on the blossom
john miller is one of a handful of
industrial beekeepers who keep their
bees in perpetual motion
traveling thousands of miles to
pollinate crops all over the country
some years we do better in the
pollination business we'll make an
income off the almonds
some of the bees then go to washington
state for the apples
so we have opportunity to get two
earnings centers but the apples don't
pay nearly as good as the almonds
then we go to the honey production in
north dakota well some years it's dry
and some years it's wet and some years
it's warm and some years it's not so
worm it's farming and you roll the dice
every year
you've got to be comfortable with a lot
of risk it's farming you know some years
are good and some years
are terrible
but even a good year can be terrible for
the bees
there are stresses of moving
reorientation
sudden changes in diet and climate
infestations medications the bees have
no chance to adapt
we have to push these hives and we know
it you know it's the middle of winter
out here and we're trying to get those
hives to where they're just busting with
bees
because they then have the strength the
numbers the capability to launch a big
flight
into a big concentration of flowers
because these trees all bloom at the
same time
bingo
baby
a migrant beekeeper can make 75 of his
income in just three weeks of almond
pollination
but to do so means pushing his bees
without limit
as we're maintaining the hives when we
find a hive that's substandard or the
queen is failing or missing
we
find the old queen we kill her
and add brood or eggs from another hive
add a new queen to that hive so we don't
lose it
with over 600 million bees ron spears is
one of the largest beekeepers in the
world
maybe seven to ten years ago you could
pretty much get two seasons out of them
with the miticides that we're putting in
the hives the constant movement of the
hives and the long season that the queen
continues to lay you know up to 10 or
even 11 months in some cases the queens
just get wore out they it's it's stock
just like horses or cattle or anything
else and and they lose their ability to
lay
um you know the 1500 2000 eggs that they
need need to lay every day to sustain a
strong colony of bees
she's up against the screen facing them
she cannot survive without worker bees
around her
ron spears buys queens from hawaii
seven to eight thousand per year
with industrial pollination the
honeybee's intimate relationship with
place and season is irrevocably broken
the vast monocultures they pollinate our
ephemeral and artificial landscapes
[Music]
even in the midst of plenty bees can die
of starvation
in a natural environment many plants
flower at the same time providing a rich
variety of pollens with many nutrients
but here
bees have little choice
[Music]
there is but a single pollen
monoculture of the scale is frequent
these days in american
farming is
possible it's a problem especially if
there's micronutrients that are at low
levels or
absent from that particular diet of the
visa pollen of the bees there can be
deficiencies
and so that requires a whole new
management scheme of feeding
good quality
protein fat vitamins minerals
that's a whole new
way of managing colonies we're becoming
more and more like
a pig farmer a chicken farmer
in that we're supplying
the diet
to the animals we're not really just
turning these animals loose into the
wild and and expecting them to pick up
adequate nutrition we're now having to
think more like
a normal livestock
person
this is a hive that's already been
treated and this is a nutritional patty
this is a bag of menthol and this is
thailand which is an antibiotic
what pretends to be science at the
service of the bee
is really science at the service of a
system that works bees to death
if the bees have to be fed and medicated
it's because they've been brought into
an environment they can never adapt to
they've been tricked their instincts
used against them
you have to feed them to stimulate them
to get them to strength if you don't
stimulate them prior to the bloom coming
on then they aren't strong enough by the
time the bloom does come on they get
strong towards the end of the bloom but
not at the beginning of the bloom
it's just a totally different
type of beekeeping and i don't hold it
against them that is the nature of the
business and every step that's taken
along that line
invites trouble i wouldn't like to be
involved
it's not beekeeping
it's just a minefield
sad really
all the scorches of the bee are
assembled here
parasites and viruses abound
the rhythm of the seasons has been
broken
the earth is saturated with pesticides
and fungicides and chemical fertilizers
it's a hell for bees
it was among large migrant beekeepers
that colony collapse disorder first
appeared
aggressive management in a terribly
degraded environment are among the
interacting factors many scientists
point to as likely causes
beekeepers know that colonies can simply
lose morale
and die
[Music]
i can't do without the almonds
financially
but i think this place is it's toxic
it's just amazing that they can take
those extremes and still be alive
[Music]
the central valley of california is a
landscape so extreme as to almost seem
another planet
but bees live a nightmare in much more
familiar landscapes like the gently
rolling hills of southwest germany
[Music]
in may 2008 in baden-wurttemberg
machines planting corn seeds raised a
cloud of dust from the dry earth the
dust carried pesticide scraped off the
treated seeds
it settled on apple blossoms and
flowering canola fields over an area of
125 miles
11 500 honeybee colonies destroyed
330 million bees
mines from a free mines to the beanie
christoph koch is one of 700 beekeepers
affected
he lost 70 percent of his bees
the culprit was poncho pro a pesticide
based on the activation clothianadin
it earns 237 million euros per year for
the german chemical giant bayer
pancho pro is painted on the seeds of
corn rather than sprayed on the growing
plant
the treatment was recommended by the
regional minister of agriculture
peter hawk
this uh insecticide is
everything seemed very clear a simple
accident
but in the analysis by the national
laboratory
bees showed doses of clothianatin
well below the official lethal level
uh
you know
our
residue was found in wax and pollen
and the german food safety authority
took the extraordinary precautionary
step of suspending permission for poncho
pro seed treatment on corn and canola
bayer compensated beekeepers 2 million
euros for their losses without admitting
fault
nothing more was heard about the
unexpected findings in the toxology lab
but on the other side of the border
french beekeepers are certain that this
new family of pesticides do kill bees
and not just by accident
starting in 1994 french beekeepers found
their bees dying and disappearing around
the sunflower bloom
honey harvest dropped by 60 percent
something had changed
that same year bayer introduced a new
systemic pesticide for sunflowers and
corn
gaucho it would become its best-selling
pesticide ever worth 556 million euros
per year
beekeepers fought to have the product
banned
the battle rage for years
gaucho is a neonicotinoid systemic
pesticide like pancho pro
a small dose is painted on the seeds and
spreads through the body of the plant as
it grows
bayer claimed that the product had no
effect on bees the active agent
immaculate didn't contaminate pollen or
nectar
[Music]
but french researchers found toxic
residue in sunflower nectar and pollen
and in lab studies doses as small as
three parts per billion affected the
bees
faced with contradictions the ministry
of agriculture suspended gaucho on the
principle of precaution
republic
dispute pesticides
absolutely
news
and nectar are not the only plant
products contaminated by treatment with
neonicotinoids
in 2009 italian researchers found that
corn grown from treated seeds exudes a
lethal dose of pesticide ingredient
water
a sort of sap
the drops can be up to a thousand times
more toxic than the dosage found in
nectar
bees that drink the water die in a few
minutes
bear counters that there is no proof
that bees come in contact with gutation
water in the wild
and they claim the laboratory
experiments no matter how spectacular
cannot reproduce what happens in the
field
french toxicologist luke belzons was on
the scientific committee that studied
the effects of gaucho
he's been testing the latest generations
of pesticides for over 15 years
he's made the disturbing discovery that
neonicotinoids induce different effects
at different dosages
even extremely low repeated exposure can
have strong unexpected effects
with these insecticides there is no safe
dose
[Music]
sublethal intoxication causes nervous
disorders loss of memory or temporary
paralysis
catastrophic for honeybees and wild bees
alike
is sub-lethal insecticide poisoning the
root cause of disappearing bees
mary ann frazier's long series of field
studies showed that bees are
continuously exposed to many
agricultural chemicals
and it's not just adult bees that are
affected
so the struggle in the beginning was are
these things out there to monitor are
the bee are the pesticides there and are
they getting into the hive into the bees
food into the wax where the bees are
developing
that was our original question that
question's been answered yes they are
there they are getting into the hive in
some pollen samples we found as many as
31 different pesticides on average we
find six pesticides per pollen sample
it turns out honeybees are quite good
monitors of the environment they pretty
much pick up everything that's out there
and while we think we put these things
out there and they go away
obviously that's not the case
the honey bee genome revealed that just
as bees are weak in immunity genes they
are weak in detoxification genes they
have few defenses against pesticides
the interactions of different chemicals
found in the environment are a danger of
unknown dimension for bees everywhere
both wild and domestic
we have the evidence that these
pesticides the beginning evidence that
show that these pesticides in
combination have a synergistic toxic
effect so two or three pesticides they
have together in a pollen
diet for the bees have an additive
there's an additive effect of those
pesticides but we're finding that these
things particularly some fungicides and
pesticides can synergize meaning that
they can be much much more toxic when
they're added together than either of
these two things are on their own or
additively
in the fall of 2009 at apomondia the
world b congress
the role of pesticides remained
controversial
but in the corridors news was
circulating about a breakthrough study
demonstrating a new type of synergy
the author was jeff pettis of the united
states department of agriculture his
co-author dennis van engelsdorp
we exposed whole colonies to very low
levels of neonicotinoids in this case
and then challenge bees from those
colonies with no sema a pathogen the gut
pathogen and we saw an increase
even if we fed the
pesticide at very low levels we saw an
increase in nocema levels in direct
response to the low level feeding of
neonicotinoids as compared to the ones
who fed normal protein you measured that
effect at levels that you could not
detect the pesticides and so that brings
up the question if if it's having an
effect at that low doses we wouldn't
have discovered it in our study because
it was below the limit of detection the
only reason we knew the bees
had exposure was because we exposed them
otherwise you would never have known
they were exposed the take-home message
is that interactions may be the key
so in this case we're we're we're
manipulating one pesticide and one
pathogen and we clearly see the
interaction
the conclusions of pettis and van
engelsdorf were confirmed in a lab study
by french researchers evelycant and luke
belzons published in december 2009.
even at indetectable levels
neonicotinoid pesticides weaken be
immunity
if this is the final answer to worldwide
bee deaths then the elimination or
reduction of neonicotinoids
might save the bees
[Music]
or is it too late
how can pesticides that poison at
indetectable levels be quantified or
controlled
how can their elimination be confirmed
industrial agriculture requires billions
of bees
but bees can't live in the environments
that industrial agriculture produces
what choice is there and who will make
the choice
for the moment the answer is simple
disposable bees
but science and industry are already
working on the future looking ahead to a
world without bees
it's possible to identify
forms of genes that would confer
specific sorts of advantages
and then
use
genetic engineering to
put those forms of genes
into bees now of course this is a very
young science
number one and number two
we have to be very careful with this
approach because we know
that
any gene has multiple functions
there is no gene that just does one
thing
the tools are there to produce bees that
will be more productive in our
agricultural situations but we need to
proceed very carefully
there are possibilities for
technological solutions for some
mechanical means of providing
pollination services there may be
even robotic bees design if you go far
enough in the future
so i think we have not really exploited
the technological possibilities we
really have neglected pollination
services and i think both biola
biologically and technology
many many options are open to us and
they just
require development
ah
[Music]
hey
one of the biggest problems we face in
the world is that in my view and that of
a lot of other scientists we've gone
down some wrong roads in our
agricultural technology particularly in
over-intensification and spreading very
uniform genetically uniform crops over
too much of the planet and not looking
at the genetic diversity of crops and
over-using artificial fertilizers and
pesticides
in ways that have just made our problems
worse the biggest ecological damage done
by humanity overall is through
agriculture
miners once carried a caged canary when
they descended into the earth
the death of the bird warned the miners
that the atmosphere was dangerous
bees are much more sensitive to
environmental poisons than humans they
too act as environmental sentinels
[Music]
in the mines when the canary died the
miners evacuated
today beekeepers and their bees are
fleeing into cities to escape famine and
disease
[Music]
on my father's grave
as bees flee him
with laid the treasure the minute swing
the way by pleasure these were the words
of robert birds
as bees flee him
with laid the treasure the minutes
winged their way with pleasure
that was a reference to
bees being used for as a therapeutic
uh
medicine
for old people and people who were
recuperating and they sat and watched
the bees
and the bees worked all day and the
people were
happy just sitting watching them
and the bees didn't sting them because
there were cottage hives they were in
the gardens you know so they were used
to people you know
i mean the country the most beautiful
countryside
not only am i looking after bees but i'm
interacting with
people in the countryside so it's it's
all about community really
and a countryside community and beating
people like shepherds and farmers and
landowners and that
as i say a way of life and i'm the
beekeeper
and they have all their jobs as too
and it would be a great
pity if all those things eventually
collapsed and
went away
there's the queen look isn't that
wonderful
it's right
doesn't like the exposure you know
lovely queen there
foreign
[Music]
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news you'll get
insight into limitless possibilities
knowledge and inspiration to feed your
ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident my way away
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elise shafak
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quicktake
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillian's etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where is
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillions etf
masterchef only on quick take
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
me
this way
[Music]
so
kwazulu-natal south africa
a province of fused with history
and beauty
boasting two unesco world heritage sites
kwazulu-natal is known around the world
as the kingdom of the zulu
at the heart of the province lies the
country's busiest port city
durbin
named one of the new seven wonder cities
of the world
enlisted amongst the most popular
tourist destinations and top ten cities
to visit by the new york times
over 1.45 million people come to durban
each year to soak up the sea
and the sun
[Music]
and in the townships that surround the
city
the history and spirits of great men
like mahatma gandhi
john dewey
and nelson mandela continue to live on
in 1904 mahatma gandhi established the
phoenix settlement encapsulating his
vision for a community based on
self-reliance
90 years later in 1994
nelson mandela cast his first vote at
uslange school a few miles away in south
africa's first democratic election
[Music]
it is the realization
of offer hopes and dreams
that
we have cherished over decades
after voting madiba walked up to the
grave of john dube the first president
of the african national congress
and the first black person to found a
school in south africa
i have come to report mr president
he said
that south africa is now
free
[Music]
more than 20 years into democracy
townships like inanda may be neither
truly free nor self-reliant
but the true spirit of dubai
gandhi and mandela
peace and hope
is being manifested in the townships in
a surprising and extraordinary way
my name is zoela kevlavas i'm 22 years
old
i was born here by my mom transferred to
newcastle
my father
passed away
there is a cranny
but i support myself performing
it's hard
sometimes i call my mom and tell i need
some money even though she's not working
at the moment
my mom gets the money from the grant for
my other brothers and sisters
it's so difficult because i'm an artist
i love dancing acting
friends and neighbors don't understand
what i'm doing they start saying things
like you're not serious in life not
going to get anywhere you're not going
to make it
not accepting you as who you are
like everybody else i do have dreams
to make my life so much better
to make success in my life
you see around this place it's so hard
i have a hope someday that
i will
just change it
i know i'll make it
i'll make it
[Applause]
my name
is i'm 24 years old
and i live in kombucha with c-section
my mom and dad found out that they were
hiv-positive it was 206
so i was doing grade 9.
before they got tested my mom got really
really sick and we took her to doctors
traditional healers but she was worse
after she got her result it didn't mean
anything that time until
i saw her the day that
my grandpa and my grandmother
chased her away from the house at
g-section
that's where i finally thought being
positive it's a serious matter because
now
she got herself kicked out on the house
and seeing her cry
over the road through the bastard in the
bar still crying
is that another pain
yeah
i started dancing when i was seven years
old i loved dancing but when i'm in
teacher i made a promise to my granny in
jobeck
that i would stop dancing and focus on
my studies i would never ever ever dance
in job
i tried not to dance but when i got some
job just got myself on stage in dance
[Music]
i didn't tell my grandness i was going
into chiamachiga i was dancing on tv
it was hard for me because i told my
grandness i want top dancing but people
believe in me when i'm on stage
i never had respect from people
then i got from dancing
when she saw me on tv
she shouted in me and said stuff
i don't feel good being treated like an
outsider by your own family
when i got back to my mom in derby i
told myself i owe myself a try
because this is what i love
dance for me
it's been a therapy to express my
feelings
to express the pain that i've
experienced in my home
[Music]
my life was all over i was more relying
on
people i meet than people i have
trying to please people rather than
doing what i want for myself
and i've been trying to start a new life
but i'm still stuck
my name is
i'm 31 years old i live with commercial
i'll stay alone because my mother she
got a stroke so i have to work but i
just love singing
one of my friends took me to a mambasa
auditions i didn't know i was pregnant
at that time
i went to peter
i was happy
from september everything just turned
down
my mom put it so on a leg
and they have to cut a leg and then i
have to struggle because i don't earn
any money for now
then i have a behavior on the other side
everything started to be tough
the only person who helped me it's
manjabulo's mom
every end of the month she comes here
with the food
if in job will i have some money it's
helping paying my rent
if i get a hundred dollars buy
electricity with it
it is so hard
here in the township
we are in a new south africa but we are
still struggling
i've got these children that i have to
look for my sister's children and my
children and myself and to pay bills
electricity to buy food to make them go
to school
i'm working in the movie industry but i
never actually succeeded to all i've
tried to do
it's very hard when you're not working
my sister's son he's having grant
because his mentality is able
that's the only thing that is helping us
but it's not enough
it's never enough
my son freedom was involved in accidents
before he can start school he was
injured in his head
life is not
easy for us my brother is taking a lot
of stress
2006 everything went wrong
a father of my kids passed and all my
kids were involved in the
accident he lectured my left leg my head
was very bad
freedom fortunately he could help
because everybody was injured he was
only one who was better
kenny was there working in jawba making
that feeling blood diamond and he was an
accident there
his knee it was broken so kenny had to
come back he couldn't work and we both
was at home and we couldn't do nothing
for ourselves
unable to support himself and his family
kenneth lost his confidence and he lost
hope
but then another tragedy struck
gift passed on
that is very painful to lose a kid
[Music]
the doctor find that the reason why
the kids were sick is because of
starvation
he was my son it's my second bone he was
our light
part of me died that day
it was so difficult
i was lost for so many years
it took me time
to find
myself again and
just
be happy and not feel guilty
tabitha asks for his brother is
he never understands why does his
brother get to be in heaven
every time when i look at my son i feel
like he's incomplete
they taught me how to survive life
and how to be a mother
for months when he passed i would just
lay in my bed
sometimes i could even feel him there
it was so painful
it was hard on my uncle it shattered
everyone just tore us apart
the night before he passed he just got
up turned in the music and he laid there
on the floor
and everyone sort of knew that it was
his way of saying stop being sad i'm
okay
i'm fine i can handle this
and he did
i miss him every day
having nobody to help
oh that is very hard
it affected the whole family
we are still cliffing
my life as a musician it's been
fluctuating
in musical career it's a tough industry
i started at natal technicon doing
classical guitar i couldn't finish due
to the lack of the funds
i went to join formula brass band where
i was playing a second trumpet and i was
also involved in this zanussi event
i learned a lot from these guys
from there i went to join gibson canton
godfather of the township theater
sarafina took me abroad and it was
exciting
[Music]
there's a lot of bad stuff around my
community
and some people stole my trumpet
that brought me down and i was scared i
said what's happening in my life
in order to keep living i did try to be
involved in a property business like to
buy land build houses and say
i was on my own i had no funds so i
couldn't go further
i started only one house which is not
even finished till today
i'm unemployed
but i have a family to support
sometimes i want to lose hope
i lost respect from the community
and i worry i will lose the respect of
my kids
life is very tough for our family
i am not giving up hope
i tell myself that my dream which is
making music is still on
my name is kumar
i live at um zenyatta in ananda
i'm like a self-employed person who is a
lighting technician but there's no jobs
it's very difficult for now to live
to support my wife and kids
my first boy was supposed to go and
start great art
and the only money is a child support
grant which does nothing when it comes
to schooling the children
sometimes if you are a father of the
family it's very bad other children have
new clothes and some toys and you know
that you've got only money for food
since those money is not enough
people are relying on me
so that makes you stressed
quasi's family has lived on the
outskirts of ananda near durban for
generations and are well regarded by the
chief and community in the area
but in 2007 his struggle with
unemployment forced quasi to send his
wife and children to live with his
wife's parents
i can't even manage to support them
but it's not nice to live apart with
your family and your kids
sometimes you get a call you don't have
money for a doctor no medical aid
nothing it's not right
i also wish to live a nice life having
my nice house nice car it was my dream
when i was at school
instead it gets more worse than before
you don't have a way forward because of
the hard life
and i'm struggling
[Music]
yoga can change this place
change people's mindset
and we can see a better neighborhood
yoga can make life better
[Applause]
[Music]
the word yoga in sanskrit means union
the union of mind body and spirit
it is known as one of the oldest
holistic health care systems and today
over 20 million people practice yoga
just in the united states alone
by 2013 yoga was a 27 billion dollar
industry
[Music]
yoga is obviously body mind and spirit
so that's the best thing you can do i
kind of go off and on from it but that's
what you always come back to because
it's the best for you
all about being gentle with yourself
and acceptance
of what it is at the moment
i am a big meditator i just think it's
everything it's brought everything into
my life that i've wanted and it's gotten
rid of a lot of
negative things that i haven't wanted in
my life i like the fact that there's
always a 10-minute period at the end
where you're lying down and relaxing and
stretching that part sees me through the
difficult bits
the popularity of yoga in the western
world was driven by a host of
celebrities who embraced the practice
some as a passing trend and others as a
deep and lifelong spiritual and physical
way of
life but in the townships of south
africa
the idea of yoga has only just begun
[Music]
the history of yoga dates back to the
industry's body civilization in india
five thousand or more years ago
but it was only with the upnishads
gnostic texts that expounded the hidden
teaching about the ultimate unity of all
things that pre-classical yoga came to
be
the period of classical yoga that
followed alludes to the eight-fold yoga
taught by patanjali in his yoga sutras
potentially yoga sutras were an early
series of teachings which were written
down around about 2500 years ago
this period of time was also around
about the time of the buddha
so the buddhist teaching is related to
tanjali's yoga sutras
all of these teachings that were written
down were previously oral traditions
passed on from one teacher to another
student through the generations and it
seemed that patanjali's yoga sutras
became a kind of a collection
those 196
verses say that what we see is
illusion there is a way to see through
and see reality
buddha famously said that
life is suffering which really means
suffering is inevitable
because even if you achieve some kind of
joy or happiness or success then
somewhere in the near future you will
also experience dissatisfaction
what they're suggesting in the sutras is
that there's a place that we can go to
beyond all that which is a place of
bliss and connection and this is what
people call yoga
patanjali believed that yoga brought
about the separation of matter and
spirit and restored the spirit to its
absolute purest form
the body was not considered that
important
but it was only after the parliament of
religions held in chicago in 1893
when swami viva kananda spoke of the
common theme of universality
and then established the vedanta society
of new york in 1894
that modern yoga is believed to have
been born i am proud to belong to a
religion which has taught the world both
tolerance and universal acceptance the
world was becoming open to different
ways of thinking and viewing spiritual
life
vivi canada was just one of several
lineages of yoga passing on their
message
some of them managed to connect outside
of india
vivekananda opened the door for other
yoga masters from india including
yogananda and became known as the father
of yoga in the west
early in the 19th century there was also
a culture of physical fitness and health
developing in the west
so yoga somehow got mixed up with this
around the 60s 70s it really took off
when you do the yoga practices
it's nurturing the body nurturing the
physical being on many different levels
it's something that develops more energy
and then that energy can be utilized in
positive ways
sometimes yoga is just sitting and
practicing meditation
[Music]
and in that you feel less
separate from the person in front of you
you feel connected
[Music]
i'm so excited about this project but
i'm also incredibly nervous
it's so important in the townships
because the people there live such
stressed lives
i think yoga can transform aspects of
the community yoga can transform some
people
generally can really make a difference
yoga brings joy
it helps people to loosen up and when
you open up your body you open up your
heart
and when you open up your heart you
release negative emotions
and if people can become happier and
more peaceful
life becomes better for everyone
apart from bringing health to your body
yoga helps us to heal on mental and
emotional levels too
and i think that's also such an
important thing
that mindfulness
we create the world with the mind
on our yoga mat we learn kindness and
non-violence towards ourselves
people become more aware that they have
choices
and the choice isn't so much in the
circumstances in fact the circumstances
won't change but it's how you react to
them
and then you see the world differently
so then your world changes
this is why the township yogi project
has invited a few students in the
townships to come and start their
teacher training
they will learn about yoga and then take
it out into their communities
they need to know exactly what yoga is
they need to know anatomy and physiology
and there's also the whole zulu cultural
aspect we need to make sure the
communication is clear
so it's a very different experience
teaching them
i am feeling very happy to be here to be
a trainee as a yorker teacher
[Music]
here in rural areas and in township
there is no new yorker
it wasn't exposed to me
but after i get an explanation of what
is yorker i realized that i must join
i need new yorker to help my body and
also it will quench rest that i've got
sometimes in my mind i'm thinking about
not working
and also battling it because there is
nothing at the end of the month
yoka will heal all that
i want to do yoga because
they focusing on their energy together
and i feel like yoga is going to help me
with my emotions
when i'm thinking a lot i feel my head
is so heavy
when they're doing those handstands i
think my blood is gonna blow like that
and i will feel relaxed
i feel like when i'm doing yoga i'm
gonna be flexible i'm gonna be able to
work at school i'm gonna be able to be
on stage doing what i love most
it's gonna relax my world
[Music]
i know about joker before
for me doing yoga is my mind my part and
my soul
it makes me believe more in myself
it takes down all the hatred and it
makes me focus in whatever i'm doing
it brings discipline
it makes you put yourself together
but that's why i told myself i should
join the class and teach yoga just to
pass this to other people
i always
wanted beautiful things like yoga to
come into the township
[Music]
i wanted to be introduced to teachers
who's going to further my dreams
i wanted to be a yoga teacher to teach
the children and bring about peace to
our community
kyogre will have a serious impact for
the township
i am scared at the same time excited
that is going to happen
i'm so excited
when i first heard about the project i
thought this is what has to happen
you'll see all the hardship in their
lives on the faces
become aware of the noises around you
in the end they let go and in the end
you have them in your shavasana and your
resting pose and you see the softness
and you see
the effect that yoga has on you in them
as well
[Music]
that first i go at the yoga class once a
week to build my body so i can be a
flexible dancer
by going there it has changed me a lot
joining the teachers course i found that
there are many things that i can achieve
now we came to understanding what yoga
does
yoga it cleans your body and it calms
you down
[Music]
it's not about stretching myself being
flexible now
i've learned how to live healthy
that's what we tend to like as a youth
what we eat affects how we think
and how we feel and how much energy we
have
most importantly how we treat people
i believe that yoga can change mindsets
kids can think for themselves able to
know what they want
able to know the soul
the youth today are born into legacy of
violence
and a lot of terror
it's a mental struggle that people face
in these disadvantaged areas
a lot of family values are lost
and our generation is looking for love
and values in destructive places
they're not thriving
they are shut down mentally and
spiritually and there's no love
the youth that are exposed to yoga it's
an opportunity just to listen to their
thoughts
to be in touch with their body
to just look at themselves as they are
yoga gives us that opportunity to face
our pain
the more you uncover your pain
that is powerful to transform a person
there has to be a place where
we truly connect
yoga does that
[Music]
it will change me
now
but taking yoga into townships of south
africa was always going to have its
challenges
how do you make people understand the
benefits of yoga when most of them
don't know what it is
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident my way way and i'll talk to
the novelist and political scientist
elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quicktake
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
ioca but i don't know what it is exactly
what you can get
[Music]
the sun
me
the township yogi project met with
resistance and suspicion especially
among church leaders
classes offered to two aid support
programs run through churches were
turned down
don't understand what does yoga do that
is the disadvantage that we have
because yoga originated in india
people say now you're becoming indian
so we try to explain to them that it's
nothing to do with religion
i've never
encountered resistance from any
religious group to yoga
until i came to south africa it's only
in south africa it's not worldwide the
rest of the world is very open to yoga
within their religious framework most
places
i consider myself a good christian i was
raised in a catholic family
and i feel no
conflict at all
in fact i have people who practice with
me who are muslim christian jewish
atheist
whatever your religious belief i don't
see any conflict there with yoga because
of yoga increases connection with other
people so there's more likelihood that
you're going to feel more open-hearted
more charitable all these principles are
in the yoga
sutras and i really feel that it's
one of the biggest mistakes of
some of the churches trying to assist
their community to go in the right way
and to try and find god
it's politics
some of the leaders of the churches
are skeptical about yoga
they do not welcome us because they
think
yoga it's a religion
some of them they welcome us
with warm hands
but they are same christians
[Music]
the catholic church supports the
township yogi project because it's doing
people good
people in townships
who don't have work
who have aids
who have tuberculosis
need to change their reality
they can't change their
external reality so that is something
that needs to happen within people
and i think that the philosophy behind
yoga as well as the exercise
does their souls an enormous amount of
good
in as far as churches don't support
these sort of projects because they feel
that their religion is being encroached
upon
the church has a very deep spirituality
of meditation
and being at peace
and yoga is a means of finding your
center
a religion has a great deal to do with
the tradition in which it evolved and
developed
far more important is our personal
spirituality
spirituality is a lot larger than a
particular religion
meditation is a tool
to be able to deepen
your spirituality
and every human being has a different
spirituality
[Music]
the religion you belong to
will give you the framework within which
you can be
safe
about where you're going because it's
easy to get lost
on these paths of self-discovery and
enlightenment
i cannot believe that god
will one day ask you
to what religion did you belong
but i can well imagine him asking you
what did you do
with the spirit i gave you to grow
yourself to become closer to me
so
yoga is not a
religion but it can be a path to a
deeper spirituality
maybe within the context of being a
catholic
buddhist
it may be in the context of an atheist
who's searching
yoga is like a meditation and we do
meditation on a daily basis
i don't see any conflict because it goes
hand in hand
especially when we are in a quiet moment
[Music]
you gain physically and also you gain
spiritual you get the inner peace
it goes together
it's like when you inhale
your belly rises
even if you overload it in mind when you
come out of the yoga
you feel just fine
yoga helps a lot to our sisters
sister juliana was having a frozen
shoulder
since she started yoga she's much better
sister solange now can move in her
wheelchair and help herself to bed
instead of calling someone to help her
we're happy
to be helped
to get healthy
and 82 years
i couldn't walk because of my legs it's
painful and splat
after doing yoga i can move a little bit
my hands were not able to move well now
i move do something not big things but i
can move and do something when they ask
me to help
i can do in yoga everywhere
in my wheelchair
i can do
[Music]
it resistance to yoga has not been
restricted to fear or ignorance in a
religious context or to white teachers
coming into black areas
the township yogi teachers themselves
encountered many impediments and
challenges from people living in their
own communities
we have come across problems
most of the ngos when they come they
give handouts and food and clothing
but we're coming to give them something
to do with their lives
we come to them just to keep their hand
up in a yoga way
because it builds who you are
it broadens your mind
it makes you accept who you are
it makes you think what can you do to go
and get those things that you want
rather than asking for handouts
it opens a lot of opportunities if you
are somebody who's optimistic about life
being a yoga teacher
at first it was a challenge
township has always been brought to you
hey what you made of
it's about how would i use that to my
own advantage
it's rare to get some opportunity
i want to make a township become
one people
out of many people
yoga
it's something that everybody needs
[Music]
there's so much negativity out there
these days
there's so much confusion and so much
tension
[Music]
and when we learn to see these things
for what they actually are then we can
start to say do i need to accept that do
i need to take it into my life do i need
to take it on
by doing yoga you de-stress the body and
you learn to deal with life as it is
here and now
you learn to become quiet inside and you
can be in the place of the greatest
chaos and still find that inner peace
i may live in this place but my mind
isn't living here
one of the biggest challenges being
faced in the townships is tb
in 2012 south africa was reported to
have the second highest rate of new
tuberculosis cases in the world
and the highest rate of drug resistant
tv in africa
i had a problem for breaking down
because of having tb i was seriously
sick
i went to have medication for tb
just as we started the teacher training
quasi was diagnosed with tb
he still came for a little while and he
was really ill
he started taking his medication and the
side effects of the medication were
horrendous
his energy levels became absolutely zero
he had terrible pain and numbness in his
feet and legs
he would sit in the sun with a blanket
around him and shivering and he'll be
able to do a little bit of yoga and no
more
i have to break maybe for about two
months until i was sick
on the that month i went back to yoga
continued doing yoga while i was doing
medication
when he came back we started giving him
pranayama to do just natural breathing
and then we started teaching him full
yogic breathing
he was able to do more and more and
within three or four weeks he was no
longer having to sit out
he started putting on weight again
now you can't even believe that he was
ever sick because he really looks so
strong and he shines
a study in the international journal of
current research on the average recovery
time of tuberculosis patients in the
northern region of ghana reported a
median recovery time of 22 weeks
but other studies of tb cases like
quasis have shown improvements in lung
function in only eight weeks
proving that there is a complementary
role for yoga in the management of
pulmonary tuberculosis
yoga really help our tb client
it helps their breathing
it does help tp recovery
doing yoga with medication for tb makes
me a speedy recovery in my life
but quasi's battled tb not only affected
him physically
emotionally and psychologically it took
a tremendous toll on him and he is still
unable to talk openly about his dark
time in his life
because he just doesn't want to remember
the community didn't speak well about
him at that time there's a whole stigma
when you're sick
he went through physical pain and so
much emotional and mental trauma
i think of all of them he has grown the
most
and really embraced the yoga to such a
deep place because of his experience
with it
even though he was hiv negative quasi
was still demeaned because of people's
perception of his tb symptoms and the
stigma surrounding age that still exists
in townships all over south africa today
south africa is reported to have the
largest population in the world living
with hiv aids and a 2010 study by the
south african department of health
records the highest hiv prevalence in
kwazulu-natal
for the township yogi project the
biggest question was whether yoga could
help people in township communities
ravaged by the effects of hiv and aids
[Music]
growing up with pain and anger
living without my mom and knowing that
she's positive
it didn't make sense
i didn't understand anything
[Music]
now i know what hiv is and what it does
to people
[Music]
after my parents told me they were in
hiv policy
i always told myself that i will never
ever ever do an hiv test
[Music]
all of my results came back positive and
came the same treatment that my mother
called
[Music]
i always thought that would destroy me
doctor said we all need to do the test
and for my baby's sake i had to do and
after finding out that the nature of his
positive i don't know how to feel
you have that disappointment
being a mother was wonderful but when my
baby got sick i became very stressed out
we went to a clinic to do the hiv test
the test tangible
and then his blood just come out
positive
i was so scared
and then they test me
my blood default
they said we have to take eliza test
we wait about seven days
how many
okay when i got my second result i
became positive
and i was so afraid maybe i'm gonna die
i feel like my dreams my goals
everything i wait for disappear
i was so depressed
i never ate
bank school
and don't have anyone to tell
if you are positive people around the
township
they take you like you have ebola
they take you like you're an animal
something that i'm not ready to face
right now
i'm not ready to disclose around here
i'm not ready to disclose to my family
even my mother ago she's a traditional
person she will never understand that
i'm hiv positive
i'm a break winner at home i'm the one
who support them the only thing they get
at home it's my mom's grand
so i can't just tell them another
trouble
i feel like
i'm alone
i still need to live my life but to live
life with the secret it's gonna be hard
for me
i was feeling maybe i'm gonna lose
lucando i'm gonna let him alone suffer
because when i'm not here i don't think
another person would take care of my
baby as i did
no one's gonna love him is i do
a few months after finding out their own
hiv status inju bullo and sabatelli were
forced to face more heartbreaking news
dutando
also tested hiv positive
foreign they all passed
so
now we only have punjab
in no lieutenant
so things are not going very well
but if we are living
oh
[Music]
when i see him put his hand down in his
leg up and said oh my gosh how can i do
this
but he will teach me the yoga
when i started at 8th class
i told myself
i need to be part of these people i need
to be like family
so i wouldn't feel scared
i will also be affected in somehow
because people in a situation like that
need to give them love and make them
feel
like they are normal people
it was challenging at the beginning
but as the time goes on i have the love
of it
and i think it worked
since we started working with them
i think they sold light in their lives
they would see that there are some
people who are caring for them just like
everybody else
the biggest problem is hiv and aids and
tb
sometimes you can't treat a patient
physically you can even treat
spiritually
some they commit suicide if they are
positive
the problem stays on my shoulder
i know you can help us a lot
just take the breath in and out
most of south africa's social issues
feed off each other
hiv aids can lead to unemployment
poverty can lead to violence and crime
but poverty in south africa has also
manifested in a new drug called wunga
which is ravaging township communities
countrywide hiv and 8 is affecting a lot
you see funerals every week
it's so bad to see people they know
infected
kids here that are infected some of them
they lose hope
they start longer just to forget that
they do have hiv and eight
every street around here
you will find someone that is into a
woman
it's a drug that's have actually taken
over
in our
neighborhood
the wound is all over here charges all
over the place there's no place that you
can go without arc
it resulted in high crime rates here and
a high rate of drop out of school
these youth end up phone snatching house
breaking
the uncontrollable yeah it's
uncontrollable
consisting of third grade heroin and a
combination of chemicals the drug has
resulted in many thousands of people
becoming users and in countless
deaths
also known as sugars
wonga is unique to south africa and is
leading to negative physical economic
social and psychological ramifications
that affect not only the individual but
the families and the wider community as
well
i was marked on my way to work by the
youngsters
i lost my available staff but i thank
god that i didn't lose my life
i wanted to let it go but it keeps on
coming
no more
[Music]
i'm 33 years old
i live here
for my
i thought i was still smoking much one
but the other guys they confused me for
womba
they look like they're old and like they
are street kids
they start to stealing things from their
family
i feel like something's running your
stomach here they're not feeling more
right you wanna get escaped
i ended up selling things
from my home
small things like rings watch
cities
and then my mother found out that i was
i was hooked on young
they tried many things to get me out of
home but it doesn't matter what people
say is up to you
[Music]
you know when you are smoking water even
if get tired of you
they have dreams to fulfill goals to
achieve
but when you doing longer you think of
it you stop thinking about your dreams
their goal
you can see that they think their life
it has come to an end
i finished standards in
around 2000
then i went to unisa 2001 i enrolled for
llp degree
i did two years there
and then
i consulted
now i do not do i don't have a job
sometimes i go to my mother's garden
go in and clean up and then put some
water on some seeds
and then sometimes he give me money
so sometimes i go to scrapyard to sell
some all day same so i could get one
right now i just want to quit soon
i'm trying to reduce the the way i used
to smoke
i wanna quit
i'm trying to yeah it's difficult
aside from petty crime to support their
drug habit wonga addicts have been
robbing hiv patients in the townships of
their life-saving anti-retroviral drugs
which they falsely believe enhances the
rush
in which they combine with detergent
powder and rat poison to make up the
drug
[Music]
the old grannies
they are the victims of these drug abuse
so we bring them to come and do yoga
yeah
yoga just gives them that peace of mind
it's giving them
that mental strength
just cuts them from my unbearable
suffering that they
yoga keeps them strong
but that hour
it's like a golden hour to them
it's just a great thing to do
[Music]
in the community there's no
infrastructure that you can keep the
youth busy with
and we don't have role models something
to avoid the jobs
in the township kids are suffering
they are stranded
they don't know what to do
they need to be taken care of
there's not enough activities for them
they don't have skills they don't have
realization like yoga that will totally
change
their mindset
and give them health
and hope
you are dealing with the youth who are
emotionally abused who are physically
abused
the youth that he doesn't have hope they
will ever have a future they become sick
others that are
smoking using trucks some committing
suicide
so if the york i can go around the
township
people with benefit families will
benefit it doesn't even choose that you
are old or younger so every port will
benefit from yoga
wunga addicts often need more than yoga
in isolation to overcome their addiction
practicing yoga is an excellent
complement to conventional chemical
dependency treatment
a 12-step program and the eight-fold
path of yoga both emphasize truth
meditation surrendering to a higher
power and developing self-awareness
while healing body mind and spirit
effective interventions for those who
are addicted to wounga has become a high
priority in south africa
the government has set out plans to
build more drug rehabilitation centers
across the country
and introduce community-based programs
to reach rural and informal settlement
areas and it is through programs like
these that the township yogi project is
trying to help change the lives of
woonga addicts
my name
is i started the
in 2012.
i was working on a penicha company in
now quit because of bunga
i lied to them as i got knocked by the
car
then they give me an environment from
i got that money
only thing i applied to hunger when the
money finished
then i decided to roll people just take
their phone all the money and i'm really
making messed up by the family because i
stole things from my mother from my
brothers
just to buy their woonga
they tried my life for us
[Music]
i know inside i need to change myself
that's why i went to
rehab
[Music]
what i like about yoga it helped me to
focus it helped me to
concentrate on what we're doing
after class i feel very free
[Music]
the stress that forced me to smoke
is getting released
i feeling that doing yoga
where i understand myself
now i'm feeling very excited i feel like
i can be the father for my child the
last thing
is about maybe three years
i'm hoping that they're gonna get the
job
maybe they will give me a chance
[Music]
yoga is very important for my recovery
because i'm free
foreign
[Music]
i used to set up my body to gay people
and take the money and go and smoke
my females don't want me anymore which
makes me feel so sad
[Music]
first time i know about yoga here they
helped me very much and it's made me
forget about stressing about my females
it changed our youth and make everybody
that lives around them suffer
a philosophy of yoga can change their
mind
[Music]
our dance routine is showing that there
are a lot of people doing drugs because
they are stressed and doesn't care about
life anymore
their yoga spirit will touch
and change the situation
refreshing the mind the soul and the
body
that person becomes aware of the life of
the surroundings
of the living
i'm going to use dance to teach people
about yoga
how yoga helps people
and how it affects people
with dancers
now we came to understanding what yoga
does it's not about dance anymore it's
about the bigger picture
maybe then we'll be able to
change bad influences on people
they share things about their life they
share worries about what is coming
tomorrow or how they deal with problems
how they feel connected since they're
doing yoga
the impact of yoga goes much
further than i've ever thought
maybe this is the only time in the week
that you can really let go so relax
when i first came i felt the peace
[Music]
township living is cars people are
talking laughing everything is noisy
i don't feel safe
i guess difference peacefully
i can think straight now
to change my life
before it wasn't easy our neighbors they
weren't happy with us because we were
from c-section we couldn't even walk
there
and the kids couldn't stay there they
want nothing to do with us
we've tried so many times to make peace
with them
but as the yoga started they started to
let their children to go to yoga
that was given to us
then as the time goes they see us in a
different way
we've got peace now it's a very nice
feeling
all the streets now the kids they go to
yoga
i think it's the spirit of yoga works a
lot for us in the family and started to
work for others
it opened their minds
their hearts as well
[Music]
before we came here in our school to
introduce in the yoga
we caught so many problems
as some learners they don't
know how to read and write
so many learners they're dropping and
then learners that failed to come to
school
after us when they came here
we see the learners they called learning
periods
they started liking to come to school
because they know now they've got
something that they can do
they like new yorker
when they get this opportunity to work
with zoe they start being happy
really help these learners they don't
know how to read and write
it's a release
in their mind their yoga make them to
think quickly
they think differently to the others
that don't know yoga
[Music]
it's helped us as teachers to teach
these learners that they're doing yoga
they work with us proper we benefit from
yoga
it's help
here in the school
[Music]
if people start telling you how the yoga
they're doing in the last year really
changes their attitude towards neighbors
who are fighting with them or towards
family disputes that they have
that yoga brings a certain peace to
their lives and that is reflecting in
their
surrounding already then i'm really
touched and i'm really grateful to be
part of the project because i think it's
amazing what you can do
studies show that people who practice
yoga develop more compassion and find it
easier to forgive
[Music]
they can express themselves more
creatively through words music and art
[Music]
yoga teaches non-violence
kindness and patience
and builds personal strength
centeredness
and
fulfillment
one of the main things that jericho does
is it teaches you who you are because on
your mat is just you and your body you
and your breath and it brings you into a
center
we learn so much about ourselves
yoga it's calms a person it clears your
mind
it's giving you a space in your mind
where you can become creative deep down
in your soul
you tend to find your spirit
[Music]
find your inner self
i'm still in the process of developing
who i am
dance took me somewhere but yoga
uplifted me took me to another level
going into a teacher's training
open up my mind and see the world in a
different view
feel like i'm somebody's mentor i feel
like i'm a robot or somehow especially
in schools
that love it support the smile
that you get from kids it makes me feel
like i'm some part of the big thing
sharing yoga in my township
teaching people seeing people doing
amazing things with their bodies
seeing people
changing their minds
it's been amazing
so being a yoga teacher
it's like i may change suman sunshine
and
abandon
yoga
foreign
a lot of things has been changed
my soul has been changed also my
thinking
and my behavior
i had a passion for also being a yoga
teacher
now i can open the yoga class in my
community have my own studio for yoka so
that the yoka will be forever
the sign of change
my occasionally
it has not been so easy
i had to collect myself in order to be
ready for doing yoga
now i've reclaimed my strength
so when we fall and then we have to pick
ourselves up and go forward
as a teacher i feel so excited
i feel grateful
the yoga is like the foundation of
whatever you want to do in your life
it's been my dream
it's been a great journey
with my uncle and my siblings
yoga helped a lot
my uncle always felt like he
disappointed us he never did enough but
he did more than enough
[Music]
my uncle learned to live day by day
it wasn't easy
he dealt with his anger
he taught them how to deal with their
feelings how to
channel their emotions
how to allow themselves to feel that
pain and go through it and
survive after it
how to change the negative that hurts
the disappointment into something
greater and bigger in the direction
my brother can see life differently now
before we wanted to give up all the time
[Music]
but since yo got me understands life
better now
yoga unlocked my confidence
i'm stronger in my mind
what i couldn't do all these years
i am doing it now
i am a teacher
i am happy
i am free
from this
township yoga it's something special
it seemed to be
at the beginning of my journey in life
we're not where we were before we're not
where we want to be but we're somewhere
heading towards the right direction
[Music]
yoga is going to help me to feel free to
tell people
to make people understand that if you
are hiv positive you are not an animal
you're just a person like everyone else
i'm still scared for lieutenant because
he's hiv positive he's still young
but i'm still gonna keep my goals as
they are
my blood's gonna flow the way i want it
to flow
in my emotions as well
i'm gonna start where
i ended
the township yogi project is not
claiming that yoga alone changes
communities
many factors contribute to improved
well-being including government and
non-governmental intervention programs
but through the township yogi project
people are changing
through yoga
people's lives are changing
i've been changing
most of my life and change it's
important especially good change
by influencing one person you can
influence a whole nation
in my yoga journey i started teaching
that's where i got to understand how we
differ
and why we do
what we do
before i'm shot some bad person
i'm more calm now cause of yoga
[Music]
there are a lot of things that i've
learned along the way under different
teachers
in jivananda then capital
then india
then i went to start the organization in
namibia
[Music]
i love to teach primary children
you dealing with their soul their mind
the stress
and the stories
if you groom young children
they going to grow
to be
wise adults doing wise decisions
in future i see a big change in our
township
i think it will be an exciting journey
for us trying to change what is
happening around in our township
[Music]
they can feel the change
experience what yoga is
because i've seen the change
[Music]
foreign
sound cheap yogi
it has changed me a lot
and it will continue to change me
[Music]
so if i get the opportunity to do yoga i
will do it
with up and down
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging
optional you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafak
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick tape
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quicktake
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak this is emma barnett meets on
bloomberg quick take
[Music]
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
they're ready yup go for it
welcome to the 26th annual fury ice park
competition
[Music]
because of kobit we had to do it
virtually
double your power well done
ladies and gentlemen
i'm shooting for first place this is
really exceptional climbing
peer pressure made me do it there's
nothing else like it in the state of
colorado here's the tip of the box let's
go
in the end that's why we climb
[Music]
for the past 25 years elite ice climbers
from all around the world descend on the
tiny town of uray in southwestern
colorado to compete in the annual euray
ice festival and competition
and it draws more than 3 000 fans who
come to witness the best of the best
ascend to the top
[Music]
[Applause]
but with the pandemic raging on 2021 is
now a year of reckoning for the world of
competitive ice climbing
[Music]
despite the fact that virtually every
ice climbing competition around the
world has been cancelled the folks
behind euray's ice competition are on a
mission to move forward and reimagine
this year's event
welcome to the 26th annual fury ice park
festival and competition it means a lot
to me
and to the town and to the yuri park
staff and board that were able to do
this
my name is peter o'neil i'm the
executive director of the yuri ice park
[Music]
and this year because of covid in order
to operate and run an ice festival
we had to do it virtually
it's a unique opportunity to showcase
dairy ice park the state of colorado the
city of urae to the rest of the world
through through the festival
for the first time in euray's
competition history the finals will be
live streamed in fact it's one of only a
few ice competitions even scheduled this
year
first and foremost
we want this to be
a safe event so the world is going to be
watching i want to set a good example
that we can do this safely
but doing it safely also means the usual
3 000 strong crowd won't be allowed
you can't have um friends or family with
you
to watch it's it's just a hard no
spectator's rule
the whole area will be closed
the group here can spectate yeah
try to spread out and like not be a
group of like 10 people in front of a
camera
but yeah
oh that's me
besides being safe the competition must
go on not only to keep the sport alive
in 2021 but also to keep the town of
urae alive
[Applause]
the ice park is to the town of uray as
the ski hill is
to the town of telluride quite literally
of the uray
winter economy comes from the ice park
the area ice park in one sense is the
heart of the uray winter economy
more than a hundred years before the ice
competition the town of uray was known
for another notable livelihood
yuray is located in southwest colorado
in the san juan mountains and they're
some of the most epic mountains in
colorado
uray is a mountain mining town it was
founded on october 2nd 1876 by miners
that were looking for silver and gold
during the boom the history here is
pretty steep in mining and then it
changed to tourism after the mining boom
busted right before the first world war
miners were here originally to try to
get under the mountains most people come
here now to get on top of our mountains
and on top of those mountains is some of
the best ice climbing in the world
thanks to the creation of the array ice
park i like to refer to the erie ice
park as the epicenter of ice climbing in
north america
the big steel pipe that you see running
through the park it's called the
penstock has water running through it
that drives the hydroelectric power
plant back in the mid 90s there were
leaks that ripped down the uncapable
river gorge and formed large pillars of
ice and some locals thought wow let's do
something with this and the urais park
was born
and one of those locals was bill witt
that was one of the founders of the uray
ice park
i moved here from long beach california
and uh i moved here specifically to ice
climb that's a good place to live and
i've been here ever since
back in 1991 bill partnered with gary
wilde and eric jacobson to connect hoses
and shower heads to the holes in the
pipeline in order to create ice flows
when we first started this
the town couldn't have thought we were
crazier now it's kind of come around
where people are actually moving here
because the ice park
the uray ice fest was started 26 years
ago by jeff lowe a legendary mountaineer
rock climber ice climber it was his idea
to really celebrate the sport of ice
climbing when it was very much in its
infancy
with that eventually came a competition
that jeff lowe put out eventually they
would bolt a new line each year and the
competitors had no idea what it was and
this would attract all the best climbers
from all around the world and now it's
the most well-known ice festival in the
world
this is a real jewel in the crown there
is nothing else like it in the state of
colorado in the winter
[Music]
[Applause]
with the 2021 virtual ice competition
just one week out the park's ice farmers
get to work prepping the competition
route called mighty aphrodite ice
farming there's probably no job
description
in an hr manual called ice farming but
it's literally about diverting water
in
pipes through sprinkler heads and
turning the water on at night and you
get
huge
huge cliffs and icicles of ice that
people can climb
i'm xander bianchi and i'm an ice farmer
farming ice for the competition you know
the competition is focused really in
specific zone mighty aphrodite we do
farm ice at the top
and it's fairly straightforward
it tends to form in the same way each
year as long as we put water on
the apex of that prow oftentimes we have
to go down and groom it we create too
much ice and there's a giant curtain so
we'll go down and kind of groom the
curtain back
[Music]
with farming underway it's time to prep
and set the competition route
and leading the charge this year is a
veteran competitor
marcus garcia
my name is marcus garcia and this year
i'm the head route setter yeah i've been
ice climbing or climbing in general for
30 years and i've been a ua competitor
for the last 15 years
i have never set the route for the yuri
ice comp i've always been a competitor
so the process for setting this
competition is you really got to
want to know who you're setting for
maybe this is their first competition so
my role is to really make sure it's fun
and and inviting competition but also at
the same time creating a unique
challenge as like we go into qualifiers
so we actually get more of the elite
athletes into the final category
new this year to the
structure is the extension of the diving
board is what we're calling that and it
just adds some more steepness creativity
and the ability to
make a little more dynamic moves feet
cutting
creates a lot of spectator friendly
movement
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show first i'll be meeting chinese
artist and dissident ai weiwei and i'll
talk to the novelist and political
scientist elif shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
[Applause]
the festival has always drawn top
climbers from all over the world like
five-time world cup winner and last
year's champion maxine tomilov from
russia
but with covert restrictions in place
all over the world
the 2021 ice fest competitors all live
in the us
and with 46 men and women competing this
is one of the biggest fields ever in
ura's history
[Music]
and on the first day of qualifying
grounds the field of 46 is ready to
compete
[Music]
only eight men and eight women will make
it to the finals i'm really excited yeah
first the women are up and it's rookie
cake or tonica kicking in they're ready
yup
all right you grab your tools
start climbing
i have been climbing for about 14 years
i have never competed at the yuri ice
fest before
peer pressure made me do it
pretty much just all the people on the
ice coop team
told me i had to
in this competition i'm most nervous
about not
getting past the rock section hopefully
i make it to finals but there's going to
be a really strong group of women
competing this year
a total of 13 women are competing
including top contenders catalina
shirley
angela limbach
beth goralski lauren chartel and corey
bouhay who's making her second
appearance in the ice fest
she's ready
my name is corey buhay and i'm a member
of the us world cup team and the ice
coop team
i've been ice climbing competitively for
about three years now i've only competed
in the 2019 euray ice fest and i placed
third for women for me getting onto the
tower is the most challenging part i've
never made it to the tequila shop but i
hear that there's one on top
[Music]
[Applause]
but without the typical crowd of 3000
competitors cheer each other on
and with covert rules in place this
year's fest looks nothing like last
year's
if you can imagine this area around here
with thousands of people you know 40
booths with demo gear it would be a
super spread or crowded event so there
are no spectators this year
next 33 men start their qualifying
climbs and veteran tyler kempny is
hoping this is his year
i'm tyler kepney i'm part of the us ice
climbing team i started ice climbing in
2013. i competed in the world cup last
year got 11th in china and then it
placed 19th in korea i've competed in
uri twice i got fifth in 2018 third in
2020 this year of course i'm shooting
for first place
my strategy is to honestly keep calm i
can get really excited and when you do
get too excited that's when you make
mistakes and whoever makes the least
mistakes wins is kind of like what it's
going to be
[Applause]
other top contenders this year include
cody stevenson
kevin lindelof
wesley fowler
and liam foster
my name's liam foster and i'm a member
of the u.s ice climbing team i've been
climbing for like five or six years the
first year that i did the ui ice fest i
think i was the youngest ever to compete
strategy for this comp is just to go
have fun in the end that's why we climb
i think cody wes and and keenan probably
have the best chance this year i always
want to beat tyler but he always wants
to beat me and that's why it's so much
fun
[Applause]
but one of the youngest competitors
blazing trails in the sport is 16 year
old keenan griscom
i have been part of the usa ice climbing
team for four years i'll be the youngest
competitor in yura this year
i'm currently 16 but i've been climbing
my whole life my dad's a rock and ice
climber so he started me rock climbing
when i could walk this will be my third
year competing in the uriad ice
competition when i first competed in ura
i was
13. i think i got 16th place i barely
made it to the structure
i really want to get through the rock
and natural section faster so i have
more time to like sort out the top with
marcus garcia setting this year he's a
really good setter he's also a big
mentor and coach to me so i'm really
looking forward to see what he said
that's really tough say who's the most
competitive liam foster tyler kempny
myself like we're all gonna be really
gunning for the top three positions
tyler better not be holding some secrets
yo you got secrets
[Applause]
after two days of outstanding qualifying
rounds
[Music]
for the women we saw some spectacular
performances including world cup climber
corey buhay who is consistently top
notch giving her the number one
qualifying spot going into the finals
newcomers keiko tanaka roz reynolds and
spartan champion nicole miracle came out
of the gate with strong climbs
unfortunately nicole had an early fall
on the second route
bumping her right to the finals
qualifying position the women's final
lineup is completed by lauren chartel
beth goralski angela limbach catalina
shirley and lindsey hastings
sixteen-year-old keenan griscom is
undoubtedly one of the most notable
stories to come out of the men's
competition
he topped out both routes with
incredible times in addition to tyler
kempny kevin lindler and cody stevenson
for the men all eight finalists are or
have been world cup climbers including
liam foster thomas airline jj and andrew
lam who rounds out the field of
finalists
[Applause]
i topped the roof so i'm locked in for
finals tomorrow i'm really excited okay
i was able to talk did it pretty smooth
and tomorrow you'll be in the finals
that's the plan you have a strategy for
tomorrow
uh just keep it chill don't overthink it
all right
a lot of the finalists for this year's
competition have been training at one of
the most unique climbing facilities in
the world
located six hours northeast of uray in
boulder colorado
this is the ice coop we open in august
2019. so the ice coop being this little
garage gym is actually state of the art
training facility
go to the big blue jug on the other side
of this thing
there you go
this is the first dedicated dry cooling
gym in the world we have different types
of plywood to kick into to help
replicate different structures and
plywoods in the world we have holds from
russia korea
switzerland france just for us to train
on so that we can be better prepared for
the world cup competitions and
international competitions the people
that are training in here definitely
have an advantage at a competition like
your a
[Music]
[Applause]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
shirt
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident my way away
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick shake
[Music]
months in the making and after four days
of competition it's finally time for the
2021 euray ice fest finals
with just hours to go before the first
ever livestream competition begins the
production crew is doing final checks to
make sure there are no glitches
we've got seven cameras set up for now
we throw in an eighth beauty camera to
show you the natural beauty of colorado
we've got mics planted all over the
place so we can hear all the action
everything's hardwired so hopefully no
signal interruptions
the signal to broadcast the finals live
takes a production truck and hours of
microphone and camera checks
after the competition route is set
it's show time
thank you for joining us here at 26th
edition of the array ice festival ready
for the finals of this prestigious elite
mix climbing competition
so there is our first athlete it's
lindsey hastings 28 years old ladies
will have 10 minutes to climb this route
here we go
it will be interesting to see if the
snow continues today how it affects this
portion of the route as you can tell
it's starting to accumulate some
while i'm broadcasting live from my home
in the bay area my colleague vince
anderson is broadcasting live from the
rescue barn in the ice park
all these competitors
tune their equipment very specifically
to their own preferences
some of them
may even take some of the front teeth
that help grip the ice off a little bit
next climate will be cat shirley
when i talk about adversity this
competition has really faced it all
was questionable whether it would go
ahead or not for a long time but the
organizers have been motivated
throughout oh and there she goes great
effort from cat shirley
as the rest of the ladies tackle the
course
catches the tip of the box great effort
oh and there she goes
corey buhay 27 years old into
[Applause]
[Music]
who defends her number one standing
throughout the competition
taking home the gold
with angela lim back in second
catalina shirley and third and rookie k
coltanika in fourth place
i was uh pumped out of my gourd that
some of those steep moves are pretty
challenging um honestly it was just a
blast
after marcus resets the route it's time
for the men to begin
right into the ice
thomas caroline briefly held the lead
until kevin lindelof and cody stevenson
surpassed his high point
really solid effort with the 17 year old
then tyler kempny came out strong but
made a questionable move
oh
watch out watch out
silent
that's true
that's it maybe he's been given the
benefit of the doubt because he didn't
make progression that's uh up to the
judges to interpret that was the move we
needed to see right there figure four
to come back and see if he can take the
first place
and keenan griscom gave him a room for
his money
really showing us what he's made of
right now
oh he's off
he's off
but he hasn't talked which means he will
be in second place behind tyler kempny
of course there is contention about
tyler kentny's top there was the out of
bounds moment where he placed his tool
on that red line let's watch again
that's the left hand in the out of
bounds zone and there's the right hand
movement that looks like the judge's
ruling has said that tyler company did
advance off that outbound zone so eighth
place very sad for tyler kempny and then
the podiums a bronze medal for cody
stevenson a silver medal for kevin
lindelof and a gold medal for 16 year
old keenan
absolutely incredible men's final
for keenan the award ceremony was a
little bittersweet
how'd it feel to win
fell
not quite earned
i feel like tyler kepney should be in
the first place um i'm very excited to
have taken the win these are sick i've
been following this competition for
years and competed for my first time two
years ago and never thought that i would
be able to win like some of the ladies
competing today or have been my heroes
for years so um like i still feel a
little bit just like i got lucky
but the first live stream was more than
luck it was a huge success reaching more
than 200 million households worldwide
potentially setting a new precedent for
ice climbing competitions for years to
come what makes euras so amazing is that
it has really pushed the sport forward
you hear so many people say urey changed
my life in a way that i pushed myself in
a way i've never
done before and these are people that
are like this could be their first time
ice climbing it could be a competitor so
it's really grown in that sport and the
next step is hosting a world cup so the
next step is what we're looking for
thousands of people come to the ice test
every year if and when cobit is gone and
we can operate at quote-unquote normal
ice fest next year i'm willing to bet
that it's going to be
a sea of people coming here
to experience the uranus park in person
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice going to come from we're
looking for portfolios that have less
risk than the market but that perform
better you are building a portfolio it's
much like you know cooking a meal and
etfs i just think make investing just so
convenient and easy trillian's etf
masterchef only on quick take
you will shed light on dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news
you'll get insight into limitless
possibilities knowledge and inspiration
to feed your ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett and i'm a
journalist and presenter
this is my new show emma barnett meets
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei
and i'll talk to the novelist and
political scientist elif shafat
tune in to watch those who shape our
world explain how the world shapes us
this is emma barnett meats on bloomberg
quick tape
[Music]
but also we do our four affirmations
and so i'd like to guys y'all know what
to do
number one
number two
number three
and number four
[Music]
the time has come for us to stop looking
for others outside our community
to rebuild those communities
we must raise up supermen and women to
take back our communities and provide
them with direction and vision
no one's going to do it for us
we've got to do it
three homicides in one weekend are
keeping kansas city missouri police busy
tonight
there was some poverty maps of kansas
city and you could trace the higher
levels of poverty straight down troost
avenue this was just done last year
police say 31 year old darnell pearson
was murdered outside his apartment
building
people believe
that
the closer you get to truce the more
violent life becomes
last night's deadly shooting of one of
his employees and also a friend crushed
his good intention it's amazing it's
like two different cultures or are
living side by side one is successful
the other not so successful
[Music]
disinvestment means that there's a gap
if you want to gain on and close that
gap you have to do extraordinary things
[Music]
just as police were called to that
shooting last night
i'm tired of the robberies i'm tired of
kids getting chased home
people trying to pick them up off school
bus i can't take my kid i have to take
them to the bus stop
[Music]
the struggle that's happened within our
culture and within our american history
regarding racism and prejudice is well
known but there are certain cities that
sort of highlight this more than others
kansas city being one of them we suffer
from hyper segregation
troost has always had
the stigma
of being a dividing line in fact when i
was running for mayor i used to say that
people treated truce like some form of
demilitarized zone
when you have a demilitarized zone it's
where two
opposite armies
have decided this is where we're going
to have a truce at
and so
usually the demilitarized zone is very
barren
[Music]
[Applause]
hi um
i wanted to um ask a question about
crime i'm a
true believer in the actual true story i
was also born and raised here as well
and
i chose to be on truth i didn't end up
there
i opened barbershop 67 at 3402 troost
i
wanted to open
a business within the urban core
specifically in an area that was
underserved but on november 16 things
just
they just changed for the you know for
the worse
a business owner hoping to breathe new
life into an east side neighborhood is
now mourning the loss of his employee
and friend people
come into your life and they are there
for a long time and they make a huge
impact and sometimes they come into your
lives
and they're there for a short period of
time and they have just as powerful an
impact although police have not released
his name craig says it was joe jackson
who had only worked there a month
craig hasn't given up on the area he's
keeping his business open
[Applause]
[Music]
because of what happened on that night
as a business owner you have to make
some tough life choices so
when those dollars
dry up
it
it can deliver
a
serious blow
and
to make a business decision
as difficult as it was
um
i decided that closing the business was
was really all i could do
[Music]
i do believe that we have to you know
look at crime and specifically crime in
in like areas where it is the you know
highest as a
severe problem okay
okay uh does anybody have comments on
that yeah i do
there is a distrust of police and
citizen that has existed in this city
for quite some time
fortunately there is a police chief who
is doing everything that he can to break
that down and so am i
i agree with you craig
but stopping crime isn't something that
you do with the snap of a finger and is
multifactorial and you're not going to
stop the crime until you address the
root problems of the crime and we have
done a poor job not just here but in
every other city in this country of
addressing the root causes of crime
we're going to have this problem until
it becomes a city-wide problem
and until we embrace this as one city
and not just say well it's them folks
it isn't them folks we live in one city
and until we embrace that concept
uh we're going to continue to have
bigger challenges than that
i grew up in kansas city
and i went through the public schools of
kansas city which is why my heart bleeds
when i think about
where we are now
i remember 31st and truce had a look
much like brookside
with lots of
little individually owned shops but then
some big anchors as well and it was a
vibrant area
[Music]
the teens in the 20s one of our great
local heroes is jc nichols who was the
head of the real estate board in the
nation but started here in kansas city
and he had
planned the one of the first
shopping malls an outside mall called
the plaza the country club plaza which
was based on seville spain it was
beautiful spot still is
but what people are unaware of is sort
of the dark side was that
he also had come up with this idea of
racially restrictive neighborhood
associations
and so these um
neighborhood associations had that they
could only have in their association or
homeowners association people of the
white race
[Music]
trust was not always that way it was
originally
a trail that
wove back and forth along this area to
the missouri river where the osage
people would take their canoes to the
missouri river
[Music]
my ears took heed to our corner today
motor cars and buses heard but as mind
from heart began to pray
echoes of distant times emerged
soldad dushan and osage trails
weaving and leaving their footprints
soft
oak leaves swishing by the tails of
gentle deer on route to trough
balanced peaceful and serene each moving
at their pace
man and beast flora fowl all could sense
a kind of grace
until the wheels of iron broke the
silence of the ancient place
huh
so
[Music]
that land became prime real estate so in
the 1880s what they had developed
eventually became known as millionaires
row
so that by around 1910 1915 this corner
ended up becoming like a business
district
until by 1922 there was actually 186
businesses here within two blocks that's
when walt disney began his work
[Music]
[Laughter]
so from the 20s until the late 40s
everything was going along that way but
in the
birth of the civil rights era
when you had the call to
desegregate the schools of 1954 you had
brown versus board in topeka i was in
grade school when integration of the
schools came about
and
change
and particularly this kind of change the
potential of the races
uh being in school together
which uh some folk were afraid would
lead to social interaction etc etc so
there was a lot of fear and there were
people who took advantage of that
there's a term called blockbusting
and there were a lot of realtors who
would knock on literally knock on the
doors
of white people who lived in the urban
core
and say to them did you know
that a black family moved in down the
street from you
and in some instances it was blatant in
others it was there were inferences made
that this was going to be detrimental to
property values to personal safety the
whole bit
so this was spurred by the integration
of schools
and it was also spurred by uh
housing legislation which said that a
person
could move wherever they could afford to
live
every city in america had a district
like 18th and vine
because of segregation
the blacks in those cities still needed
services and when you are segregated
then they have to come from within
and then as integration came folks could
put businesses anywhere
uh what ends up occurring is is that
those who can leave
leave
and so if you had uh essentially
middle class to and above you well you
had working class middle class and above
white people and they left
and then you had middle class
black people and above who left who was
left then were people who could not
really financially support or at least
that's the way the businesses felt and
so they left and this is where the term
disinvestment comes from
[Music]
avarice and greed once more did hide
behind the guise of safety and pride
realtors bankers insurance and school
together built apartheid's rule
fear was cast on black and white quickly
move to make it right blacks go east and
whites go west of truth's wealth we must
divest
in the wake of fortunes made a ghost
town felt so void of trade a stigma a
byword a place of woe who can change the
status quo
it wasn't until 2003
that governor blunt issued an order to
take out the racially restrictive
language from the neighborhood
associations
so it's like you know we often have this
idea well
this idea of racism and prejudices way
back then i mean look at all that we
gained in the 50s and the 60s in the
civil rights movement
but in kansas city and especially along
troost avenue and we've come to realize
that that is very much just a beginning
point there's a lot of work to do
[Music]
people talk about the lack of resources
in these communities these communities
have tremendous resources
the problem is is we're not allowing
them to use them
[Music]
martin luther king had talked about this
idea that it's not just
helping the man on the side of the road
and the good samaritan but actually also
dealing with the
eventually we're going to have to deal
with the thieves that keep robbing
people along the road from jerusalem to
jericho we know
that an average person who goes out into
the city in the metro area can gather at
least 35 signatures
in about an hour or about two and a half
hours and that's about how long you're
going to be we're a faith-based
community organizing network located in
the urban core of kansas city and we
work with about 40 congregations
throughout the metro on quality of life
issues one of the longest running issues
that we've been working on since 1998 is
this issue of payday loans payday
lending reform our residents in just
kansas city
are paying 26 million dollars every
single year in interest alone so that's
money that's just buying debt right it's
not money that's contributing to the
local economy it's not producing goods
or services it's not you know
contributing to sales tax it's debt now
how can a community with no resources
provide 25 million dollars in profit to
a predatory industry
so it's not that we don't have resources
it's that we're spending them badly
kansas city is unique in that it was
really one of the two birthplaces of
payday lending when we look at how did
payday loans emerge nationally and also
like specifically locally as a problem
it's really one side of a two-sided coin
the other side being traditional
mainstream banking disinvestment from a
lot of low-income communities
so throughout the 1980s you saw
significant banking deregulation under
the reagan administration
and as a result of that you saw a lot of
small community banks combined into
large corporate entities that we know
really well now like bank of america
wells fargo chase and as they did that
they typically pulled up shop in some of
the low-income communities
so at the same time in places like
tennessee where advanced america was
starting and in kansas city where which
is the birthplace of qc holdings which
we typically know on the street is quick
cash well they could go to to state
legislatures they could go to the
missouri general assembly and say hey
look these banking deregulations have
really created a flight of capital from
low income communities and and the only
way to serve subprime borrowers is to
charge them higher interest rates you
know they're risky clientele
and in doing so and making that argument
the payday lenders were very very
successful and all but destroying the
usury laws in the state of missouri so
historically there was a cap
on on all lending products in the state
of missouri at 28 apr
and that was our usury law meaning
anything higher than that is just
serious it is outside the realms of what
is moral or legal in the state of
missouri
we eliminated almost all limits for for
payday lenders and it wasn't until 2002
we had any limit put into place um that
effective limit in the state of missouri
on a payday loan is one thousand nine
hundred and fifty percent apr
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all can we finish up real quickly in
large group thank you
we're trying to use the tool of the
initiative petition process to build
power for something we haven't been able
to get our legislators to build power
for so throughout the entire state of
missouri we need to gather 240 000
signatures which is like a scary number
right
but we know that there are pockets of
people all over the state that are
gathering signatures on beautiful
saturdays like this just like us
and we have some math that proves our
power and that proves that what we're
doing today can work and can get this on
the ballot missouri doesn't have
campaign contribution limits it doesn't
have limits on lobbying the payday
lending industry is one of the largest
lobbies in the entire state
and we knew that the game was rigged and
we needed to work outside of that game
if we were going to be able to achieve
real reform for our people and so we
began researching the idea of a ballot
initiative
and we found that this was
overwhelmingly supported by the public
that that almost three-quarters of folks
would support a strong interest rate cap
on payday loans in the state of missouri
and so we brought a lot of people of
faith together and we brought
labor groups together and we brought
grassroots groups together and we
brought community groups and social
service agencies together and we said
wouldn't we be a lot better off
if there was a 36 apr cap on payday
loans and the cap the rate initiative
was born from that
this issue is important to me as a
member of this community
that i know that the predatory lenders
are seeking out
predominantly african-american and
latino communities
where it's difficult for people to find
a conventional
banking or lending products that they
are
being preyed upon here well the average
person who does not have 300 today is
not going to have 351 dollars in two
weeks and the payday lenders know that
this product was designed for folks to
fail
[Music]
we've been ignored
we've been insulted
we've been thrown off of properties
but because of this cause we were not
discouraged we packed up
and moved someplace else
this strikes at the gut of your
community this strikes at the gut of the
economic capacity of your community and
this strikes at the gut of your moral
and your faith traditions and that you
can't stand idly by while we continue to
be just ravaged in this way
the other thing that we have to think
about is that there's a difference
between
income and wealth
wealth is built over generations
income is something you receive as long
as you're working
or through investments but wealth is
something that's built over generations
in order for that to occur somebody in a
generation has to say i am willing to
sacrifice for those who are coming after
me
the unfortunate thing in the black
community is that almost every
generation has to start from scratch
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
shirt
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor
this is trillions etf masterchef where
we interview the chefs of the finance
world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take
[Music]
[Laughter]
operation breakthrough came about by
accident
sister karina and i came here in 1968
and we
those were the days that when they sent
nuns places you didn't have any choice
they said next year you're going to
kansas city so you went and one day a
mom said we need a place for our little
kids
and we lived in this big old house and
we said we could do that in our house
[Music]
a lot of the struggles right now
they weren't so much true when we first
came
is many of these children have very
limited food resources at home
many of them are homeless
either live in shelters or often in
their mom's cars
last summer we had a mom that lived on a
bus stop for a week with two kids
i mean our kids
live without the basics
that we feel people need in order to
exist and it's not because their
families aren't trying
it's just the system is built against
them
a young person is killed on a in a car
wreck on 125th street the very next line
in the newspaper is there will be a
counselor at the school to help the
children deal with this person's death
i dare you to find that in a drive-by
shooting
is it because our kids are so used to
the kid next to them being dead in the
morning or so we don't care enough
i mean why
it should be the same thing there'll be
a counselor at the school
i dare you to find that line in the
paper it's never there
i had a foster child that was in my car
one day
he had seen his
mom's boyfriend kill his little sister
and we drove by a gas station he was
four years old
he was strapped in his car seat and he
said to me
if i grow up i want to be a fireman
that four-year-old should say when i
grow up
[Music]
children are part of an ecosystem they
do not drive their own cars they do not
live in their own homes they do not buy
their own food if that ecosystem is
toxic
then the results to those children are
going to be toxic
71 percent of all children in juvenile
detention and long-term inmates
fatherless homes 75 percent
of high school dropouts fatherless homes
80 percent of children in drug and
alcohol rehab fatherless homes
under slavery
more black children grew up with both
parents than they do today
now
slavery was a horrific
horrific tradition in america do not get
me wrong
and i would no way
condone it
but the fact still remains
and sometimes in order for us to
move forward we have to look at in the
mirror and look at some ugly troops
[Music]
and i am convinced if we could get
many many of these young men
to finish grade school finish high
school go to college get a job
support their families
we'd all be out of business because
there'd be no need for agencies like
this but we're aways from doing that we
have to pay attention to these young
guys
not just throw them in jail and say well
we've solved that problem
[Music]
see a lot of folks didn't think that men
needed help
oh no they thought that once you reached
a certain age y'all knew what to do
that's what he wanted yeah
right dr king's biggest fear
was that after the dogs stopped biting
after they turned off the water holes
after the police stopped beating them
and the doors of opportunity were
finally opened that there wouldn't be
people prepared to go through them
that is my concern as well for those of
you who don't know
the man class
is a
it started out as a vision as the mayor
says
i began to see around me a need
the need was there were
males
who didn't know how to be men
it wasn't that they didn't want to be
men
but the thing of it is
is that we are born
male and female
we learn how to be men and women
but in the absence of teachers
how do we learn
the man class is basically 12 sessions
or lessons
that a father normally would teach his
son okay so
there are a number of different knots
you can tie with the tie
nobody wants to come and see a man
locked up like an animal
nobody likes that
that's why some folks won't even come
see you right i used to wonder why they
be crying and stuff i'm the one in here
i should be the one crying well no
no
because you're the one who said i want
to be here
so you don't get to cry because you you
made the decision your crying days is
over
now the had nothing to do
with it
they crying because they know
that this was not what you were sent
here to do
and it breaks their heart
that you still choose to do it
that's the problem
see they see in you
what you don't see in yourself
see we see ourselves as being these
things i'm the stick up kid i'm the dope
dealer i'm
whatever
but the ones that love us don't see us
like that
right they get a vision of us that
sometimes we don't see
so it breaks their heart
when you choose this crazy stuff over
the vision that is for your life
that breaks everybody's heart
yeah i went to jail
numerous times i was a street guy street
kid
a older gentleman uh trying to be a
player a young
young man's role
out here i was still on boys status
[Laughter]
when i came in i was already in school
but i was
lollygagging in school but when i got
got here and i got
an understanding of what a man is
supposed to do and what a man what a man
is and how he conducts himself uh right
now we head up to pitts valley i gotta
drop off some homework
it kind of got me on the right path of
you know
more on my school work and you know just
out here in general in life
right now i'm taking history 121
discussing the
slave trade
that's my number one uh subject right
there this
it helps is else come together
and i'm trying to get on the same level
as you right um you know i want to get
back to the community right and as far
as do my part in that and uh kind of uh
same thing as you you know accumulate
jobs for other people right
i've been going to the uh
support class after the after i
graduated the men's
men's class
and rodney got me the hookup on this job
he said called me up he said they need
three positions and it'll be eventually
go to permanent putting in solar panels
and i'll find out more this tuesday
night at the next meeting
unfortunately in this country we've had
a one-way conversation
and that conversation is that men in
general
and fathers specifically are optional in
the lives of their children what kind of
man
would take his wife his woman his
children
his family out in the woods
and
one of the things i share with my men
is that men do three things they protect
those they love they provide for those
they love and they praise those they
they love i tell them
the women who come into their lives
should leave them better for knowing
them
not broke pregnant and confused
as they are now these young ladies is
lying down with different guys
but no no no no no no no no no
no
they are not having virgin first all
right
what
they're not having virgin birth
in other words there is a man
laying with them
no
you are those men
you are those men these are not alien
men that just pop up
e.t phone on no
you cannot put this on there
no i was i wasn't putting it all on them
you didn't let me finish
our community is suffering because
men you know males do not want to step
up and be men
so i'm hoping that i'm praying hoping
and praying that things do change
in my life and others as well
these men
realize something is missing
they're not sure what it is
but if you can provide them with what's
missing they get it
you guys are leaders
you guys are conquerors
you guys are warriors
okay
but you won't be if you don't believe it
see if every time a battle comes up you
go running
high well you're in the war here
right in your mind you're a coward
but you're not
all you have to do is stand up to the
first battle
and then you realize
a warrior
[Music]
i don't believe that it's that lowering
crime by any means is all left up to the
to the police when i've talked to my
friends you know
some of them believe that that in
suburban areas that crime is the way it
is because the people are white
and my argument is no crime is lower
because
in those areas they don't stand for it
and sometimes within the urban core we
kind of have a living let live mentality
almost like well and you know hey that's
what's going on down the street
but we fail to realize that down the
street
will eventually be
you
and someone further up the block
is going to say that's just down the
street so we have to take a
more proactive you know role in that and
not be afraid
of
what may happen because whatever you are
afraid of today it will be worse if you
do nothing
[Music]
how many of you work every day in or
near or travel through the swiss
corridor as a part of your daily lives
the people of the community
[Music]
absolutely have to be involved in their
own future
they have to find the strength to
believe that it can be better and to act
upon it and to act upon it this idea
that someone's going to come in and fix
our community
is not based in any reality in my
opinion
look at a relationship where one is
giving and the other receiving
that is automatically an unequal
relationship
the giver always stands over the
receiver
and so what we've done is is we've
created this environment where those who
receive think less not only of their
selves but of their community how does
that translate it's translated in the
fact that because my community is less
then i can throw trash i don't have to
pick up
i don't have to vote i don't have to
report crime i don't have to do all of
those things that make a community and a
society functions successfully you men
are the supermen who our communities
have been waiting for
the time has come for us to stop looking
for others outside our community
to rebuild those communities
when a group comes from outside of the
community
they don't know what the problems of
that community are
for so many of the past decades we have
had folks come in and solve problems but
they've solved the wrong problems
in the sense of they came in saying we
know what your problem is and we're
gonna fix it
well the what you do when you do that is
you begin to
devalue and dehumanize
the folks who live in that community
what you're basically saying to them is
that your
gifts your talents your abilities we
don't need
you come in and you say
what are you doing and what do you want
you don't come in and say i'm here to
help
i think the days of
waiting for government to solve all
problems whether it's city state or
federal are over i want to make sure
that you understand that we're here to
work
the role of the mayor is to set the tone
tell the truth and set priorities in
conjunction with the city council
to then focus on those priorities in
such a way
that it affects the quality of life in a
positive way none of that is possible
without a collaborative effort with the
people who live in the city at least
10 15 times a week there is a group who
comes to my office or to whose meeting i
go that wants city and help or
involvement i've eliminated
some of my headaches and problems by
asking one simple question and that is
who are you collaborating with because
if you're not collaborating with
somebody we don't have the money to fund
organizations doing the same thing nor
do we have the desire
[Music]
[Applause]
father piecius who has been in this
fight a lot longer than i have
i think has gone a long way
in involving
and integrating and bringing folks
together
to participate in this process instead
of it being one person's baby
i mean it's like a whole bunch of people
all of a sudden almost at the same time
started realizing this is time let's
make this happen in 2005 members of
saint mary of egypt orthodox church and
others formed reconciliation services
and part of our overarching vision is to
change troost from a dividing line to a
gathering place
i think the most important thing that
we've learned that it's moving from this
idea of charity
to actually building community
and in that respect one of the things
that we've looked at is how are we going
to change this for the long haul
and that brings us to this idea of
village
well the
thursday night meetings have been going
on as the truce folks since the very
first when we when we got started
[Music]
i like the idea that everybody is
involved
i mean we have a wide range of people
that come to the meetings participate i
like the idea that
everyone has something to contribute
we don't have to get our power from
someplace else we have all the resources
and the energy right here that we can
work with and people just need to know
that they can do that they don't need to
go find it from someplace else in 2005
at the same time we started the agency
we started the first troost festival
and that truce festival was a gathering
of people on a day in may
to have a day of shutting down troost
and having a party
[Music]
so we had blues jazz reggae gospel
artists communities association people
community groups individual neighbors
just having a good time all day long
[Music]
one main morning clear and bright
neighbors gathered without fright
instead of darkness gloom and night they
turned from fear to regain sight
they planted gardens sang their songs
made a council to write their wrongs
from the ruins of racist pillage there
would emerge village with children's art
and poet's song
all will know they do belong
some will build and some will plant some
will teach and some will chant
from the strands of all these years a
new bright tapestry appears
the worthless released precious embraced
creating together this most loving space
[Music]
and so
what we've shared with our board at
reconciliation service is that our
long-term strategy
is to not be here as an agency but to
actually see a functioning village
emerge
that the very best thing that we can do
is to be able to help
stimulate and to serve others to the
point where they can be able to find
their work their life work so that they
can begin to do that in this context
i think that there are people here that
care
that truly care and want to make a
difference and are working to make a
difference and they're not just working
on it on from the outside trying to oh
we'll fix that
it's people working on themselves too
and saying you know why am i having this
reaction to this problem
how much of this problem am i
contributing you know my attitude is
contributing to it so
as we look forward i think it's the idea
of
[Applause]
less of me and more of we you know so
the idea of really promoting the
sense of all of us together finding our
voices and doing our part
this past 10 years has begun a
renaissance a renaissance to begin to
pull us together from instead of
thinking of troost as a dividing line
we're now beginning to think of it as a
gathering place as a place where we can
come together and find each other find
each other in music find each other in
arts find each other in a common value
that every person matters
[Applause]
deliberately make a friend on the other
side of troost
whatever site of truth you currently
find yourself on
deliberately enter into a relationship
with someone on the other side of troost
my wife
recently passed
the
whole
experience that i've had around 31st and
troost
really much of that's emerged from the
love that the two of us shared together
and i mentioned this because if it
wasn't for her
there would be no way that i would be
involved with what i'm doing right now
and i just say there's no substitute for
the power of relationship
[Music]
you know when the spinach scare was on
and you were gonna die if you ate fresh
spinach
different people who are friends of the
center no big stores just people who
have families
during that
period of time in the two-week period
after that we had 1 000 cans of spinach
donated now it scared me to death
because let me tell you
good people open their cabinets
there was nothing wrong with canned
spinach we used every can
good people opened their cabinets and
said this could hurt my family
i'll give it to them
now these are good people
right
but to them and us when you're at
parties when you're with groups there is
no them and us as long as there's them
in us we'll have truce dividing it
[Music]
one of the things i don't think is
in this area
is a hope in tomorrow
and our children have to have a hope in
tomorrow because otherwise it doesn't
matter what i do today
if there's no tomorrow
doesn't matter
so if you re redo this for these kids
if i do this no it's when you do it and
i think we have to keep putting the
future in front of them that you have a
future
and you need to work on it and we'll all
work on it with you
[Laughter]
i always say to people the kid that
could find the cure for cancer could be
in this building and we better make sure
that this child gets all the
opportunities they need
these kids have the hope to do anything
just like any other kid does you know i
want to do this i want to do that
not if i grow up it's when i grow up i
want to be a doctor i want to be an
engineer but we have to provide them
with the tools they need to do that if
we have a 15 year old who says i'd like
to be a doctor and he's reading on a
third grade level that won't work
and we have to make sure he's reading on
the right level when he gets out of high
school
my name is nicholas cooper when i grow
up i want to be an er doctor i want to
be an animator when i grow up i want to
be a professional dancer a social worker
police officer
my name is milo smith and what i want to
be when i grow up is a teacher
my name is jada davis when i grow up i
want to be a vet and a ballet dancer i
want to be a professional singer and a
producer when i grow up when i grow up i
want to be an architect
[Music]
[Applause]
so
as we stop and we reflect upon the
dividing line and we think about the
disparity one of the the striking issues
is inequity but if we begin to work
together towards really beginning to
work at this as individuals and as
working this as this as agencies and
businesses and the community we can
begin to have this feeling of village
that transcends any particular group so
that all the ships rise together
thank you so much it's a wonderful time
and an opportunity for us to be able to
gather this evening and be able to
celebrate what we've done up to this
point
this is a place where people are from
here and they live here and they love it
here but not a lot ever seems to change
we've got the same
lines of demarcation that have been
scarring us up for 60 years
we have the same
systems that are keeping people poor
and keeping people powerless and
powerlessness becomes a physical thing
you can feel it
settle
in the hollow space between your
shoulder blades and it's like lead
but what we
did in this campaign
and what we're still doing
is we said we don't want to endure
anymore
because our people deserve better than
this
[Music]
[Applause]
finally upon the east side
father david he said to make a friend
so
anyone from the west side want to make a
friend with an insider see you before
you
religious leave
geographic dividing line in this city
and said our people deserve better than
this
and so when you are force
that
is right there is power because they are
not going to ignore
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
joseph johnson the
barber we cannot forget who they are
hopefully one day i will open a business
again within the
truce area
[Music]
[Applause]
you know my wife and i are committed to
truce we live off 28th in truth
[Music]
[Applause]
so dr king said the arc of the moral
universe is long but it bends towards
justice and we really see the cat the
rape fight as a critical bend and that
justice arc but we're not done
so this is one critical step in that
fight
and when we win we'll have moved us that
much further to the justice
the black community can no longer do
nothing and allow us to continue to lose
generation after generation after
generation
we must stand up and do what needs to be
done
[Music]
you men are the first fruits of many who
will begin a revolution in our
communities to rebuild restore and
re-engage
[Music]
michael long
when i look at my neighborhood and i
look at
my community and that's the inspiration
to me
don't quit
just keep going
bobby thompson
[Music]
we stand so we can reach down and teach
others to stand
when others begin to stand and our
communities will improve our children
will once again get their dreams their
wishes and their imagination back
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
my ears took heed to our corner today
footpaths sworn and children played
look and see what troost became
creation together again aflame
[Music]
hello i'm emma barnett this is my new
show
first i'll be meeting chinese artist and
dissident ai weiwei and i'll talk to the
novelist and political scientist elif
shafak
this is emma barnett meets on bloomberg
quick take
[Music]
[Applause]
how worried should i be about inflation
as a retail investor this is trillions
etf masterchef where we interview the
chefs of the finance world
on their hottest investment recipes if
you're an investor that really believes
in investing for the future that can
handle or withstand some of the
volatility that can come then yeah it
could be used as a core holding you have
athletes and you have influencers as
clients i'd assume they're into crypto
are you getting them exposure we're
absolutely overlaying it on the
portfolio what's your favorite ticker
it's the best ticker ever it really kind
of captures the themes what you're
trying to always deliver is a very
simple solution and if you can deliver
that simple solution powerfully i think
that resonates quite well in the market
tell us about this portfolio where's
that spice gonna come from we're looking
for portfolios that have less risk than
the market but that perform better you
are building a portfolio it's much like
you know cooking a meal and etfs i just
think make investing just so convenient
and easy trillian's etf masterchef only
on quick take you will shed light on
dark matter
you will make aging optional
you will turn 5g up to 11
because when you subscribe to bloomberg
you won't just get news you'll get
insight into limitless possibilities
knowledge and inspiration to feed your
ambition
so before you invent pioneer disrupt
before you change the world
bloomberg
[Music]
oh
the world
the people on this earth
they do not know how to use water
that's why we're running out
which in navajo means water is life
water carries memory
it's a living living being and we're
dependent on it
[Music]
planet is running out of clean water
it's not that we don't have water
somewhere but we've polluted and
diverted and mismanaged the world's
water very badly
you drank that glass of water
literally your blood might rise to a
level that you could be hospitalized one
glass of water
oh we just went and paid for our
water our poison for the month
people just assume
that once your water is running it's
safe that someone out there
is taking care of it on our behalf
in 2010 i covered the resurgence of
uranium mining in the grand canyon area
i'm at the arizona one uranium mine and
this is the uranium ore
which has been dug up
from 400 meters underground
i'm gonna get one more don't get one
more if you were in a high-rise in uh in
downtown london this would be a
120-story building
equivalent that's what you're going from
the top of that building down to the
bottom of that building
so this is what we call a radiometric
probe and it directly reads out in
percent you 308.
is it like a geiger counter
exactly basically
almost one percent work
you feel happy about mining uranium you
don't feel concerned at all about
toxicity it's all over your face right
yeah it washes off
[Music]
but when i went to the nearby navajo
native american reservation i saw a
different side
people told me uranium mining had
poisoned their drinking water
i met a sheep herder milton yazi and he
showed me the old mine pit filled with
rainwater where he swam as a kid
aged 50 had been told he'd not got long
to live
later on i saw him coughing up blood
the next morning i had an interview with
the local woman when she didn't turn up
i assumed she'd got a flat tire but i
later found out she had died that
morning of cancer this seemed like a big
scandal yet back at the bbc i wasn't
allowed to include anything about people
getting ill
there wasn't enough evidence at the time
to link the deaths to uranium
contamination
as a journalist this was so frustrating
as i knew there was more to say
i was crushed
i knew i had to return to america and
give the story the time it needed to
properly investigate
so i've come back out to arizona
the navajo reservation was heavily mined
for uranium from the mid-1940s to the
mid-80s for nuclear weapons cancer rates
doubled from the 1970s to the 1990s
what other possibilities does the future
hold for the use of uranium
the implication of the future of uranium
is simply fantastic
and it's my guess
that the minerals and the models that we
will extract from
will be the basis
of our very life for a long long time to
come
i'm meeting a young woman janine yazzie
who helped organize her community water
testing
i remember
getting the texts and the calls the
results there was uranium
and sanders
school's water system
almost two times the acceptable
drinking water limits
and
you're now a part of that never-ending
struggle to prove that this was unjust
that our babies didn't deserve
to be poisoned
and
the last thing you want to know is that
you are unable to protect your babies
from something that you know is
extremely harmful for them
so flourish what do you do when um
um
there's no water at school if i don't
take a water bottle
there's no water in
[Music]
school that like yeah the standards are
30 10 years 34.6
but there's nothing you can really do if
you have a compromised immune system if
you're an infant pregnant or elderly you
may have an increased risk and you
should seek advice from your health care
provider but if you should drink this
water or not
we've gotten pretty much
no assistance from
any governmental agency
i said why don't you have water trucks
up here live with it basically is you
know what i was told
jenny did you go to that school
yes i went to both the sanders
elementary school and the middle school
so you
were drinking uranium contaminated water
yeah and we didn't know it then either
so all of us were severely exposed over
a very long period of time you know
considering the the size of this issue
and the fact that the school itself
serves about five to six communities in
the surrounding area we don't have
cancer screening
what do you suspect
might be to do with the contamination
i i definitely suspect the church rock
uranium spill of 1979
was a major contributing factor
what was the church rock uranium mines
built the church rock dam break of july
16 1979
remains the largest release of
radioactive waste by volume in u.s
history right now probably in terms of
radioactivity release it it ranks third
behind fukushima and chernobyl
this is bad stuff you don't want to be
exposed to it and you don't want it to
be released
that's why they put it in ponds behind
dams
but that morning the dam broke
so that must be all radioactive
yeah
the fluids went from the site northeast
of gallup new mexico in the community of
church rock about 75 80 miles downstream
the government said they couldn't assign
responsibility and that was it
it wasn't until a curious phd student 37
years later decided to do some water
testing that the truth was finally
uncovered this is where the spill
happened back in 79 this is where all
the problem began for sanders
the groundwater contamination
but when he took his results to the
authorities he found out something
chilling
they knew all along
that there was elevated uranium in the
public water system in sanders but
nothing was done
sanders like undoubtedly has the highest
concentration of the of those metals
but like we have no data to show why
and in this case since we're taking
gamma readings it is showing that there
is some sort of deposit of uranium i
mean there's all this yellow stuff that
seems to be making this pop off
i started to get really sick in college
around
they told me that i had ovarian cancer
i was extremely scared
but i kind of just resolved
just resolved myself to die
i got treated using alternative medicine
go back to a traditional diet and
indigenous diets
it wasn't until
i found out i was pregnant
that i got really scared
they were going to do an ultrasound and
find that i was never better that i was
worse
and they're like oh you have two spots
on your your ovaries but that's not a
big deal like don't don't let it freak
you out i remember like nearly falling
out of that chair it was real it was
real i was going to be a mom
and
have this miracle baby
that's amazing that janine recovered and
went on to have children and it seems
plausible that she got ovarian cancer
from drinking uranium contaminated water
but i remain unsure if this could have
been the origin of her illness so i'm
going to meet an expert who fed rats
water with uranium at similar levels to
that found on the reservation to see
what she has to say
the navajo
unfortunately it had a lot of exposure
to uranium both in their water
and dust that flows around the
reservation
our study was proof of principle that
exposure
to uranium and your drinking water might
lead to gynecological problems uterine
cancer
ovarian cancer given
some of the health problems that are
well known on the reservation
young girls high school age girls having
hysterectomies and so forth
it makes you think is there a link
great power
and great crimes are inseparable
it is only those with great political
economic power
who can with the stroke of a pen or the
utterance of an order or even a knowing
nod of its head send thousands of people
to their deaths or consigned millions to
lives of unrelenting want and misery
when economic and political powers
pursue common interests the potential
for harm is magnified these harmful
collaborations are called state
corporate crime all american indian
tribes have and continue to experience
extreme exploitation since the 1950s
multinational mining corporations went
to the navajo reservation to mine
uranium with the only customer being the
united states government at the time
many of the navajo men are employed in
the uranium mines where they are valued
as conscientious workers day by day they
take their places in operating power
machinery and the numerous other jobs
about the mind
so this is a map of the navajo nation
and it spans arizona new mexico
utah colorado and if you can see here
all these red dots
these are all the uranium mines
am i afraid to be here
yes i am
it's radioactive but the point is is
that this is not the only abandoned
uranium mine there are 520 abandoned
uranium mined sites and with more than
one mine at each site there's something
like 1300 abandoned uranium mines on the
navajo reservation alone that's not
including piles like this one which is
just exposed and outblowing in the wind
some of it has been covered with clean
dirt but a lot of it hasn't i really
want to meet someone from the uranium
industry about this unfortunately all
the companies that operated here have
closed but the uranium producers
association is in santa fe new mexico
the us was the
the major
producer of uranium in the in the 50s
60s 70s there are several abandoned
mines on the reservation you see
numbers that range from
100 to a thousand uh the uranium is just
a small particle of you know a piece of
sand and you break that off the sand the
product is then dried what we call a
u308 or yellow cake and it's called
yellow cake because that's what it looks
like is yellow cake dangerous not really
it's it's you know like like we
mentioned
you could eat it it doesn't really uh
you wouldn't advise you to do that but
but it's not terribly dangerous it's not
very radioactive
this place is the highest readings that
i've got i mean i maxed out the geiger
counter the highest reading possible
you were reading
5 thousand
that's higher than the levels
around chernobyl
much higher
what i found that keeps me up at night
is
i found readings that were half of what
you found
in an unmarked uranium mine
that was next to a grade school
and it's not just the external dose
which is what you measure
but they'll be breathing in dust
they'll be getting it on their hands and
swallowing it
and anything that's edible becomes
radioactive and then contributes to the
dose
24 hours spent at this site exposed me
to the yearly maximum dose of a nuclear
worker
this freaks me out but imagine what it's
like living here and that's not all the
bureau of land management and the
environmental protection agency say
there's at least 15 000 abandoned
uranium mines across the western united
states how radioactive they are and how
they're impacting communities is not
known
at least not publicly anyway
at the same time as residents in sanders
proved their water was contaminated so
did residents in flint michigan on the
other side of the country this morning a
lead poisoning alert near a major
american city residents in flint
michigan under a state of emergency
being told don't drink the water don't
even touch the water
in flint the water is contaminated with
lead after the city switch from a clean
source to the flint river and didn't
treat the water properly the river water
was actually more corrosive and
dissolved the lead pipes into the water
and that's what people drank i'm on my
way to flint to find out more
because this willful neglect that i see
here on the navajo nation is so shocking
to me i want to know if it's because of
racism against indigenous americans
which i feel must play a part
or if there's something more widespread
going on
flint residents christina and adam have
agreed to meet me
i mean people have died from this
freaking water
and then they're gonna charge us for it
funerals are cheaper than paying
everyone back for everything or or
treating treatment's gonna cost more
than it is to bury somebody
adam used to earn good money as a
millwright at the general motors plant
but that life is gone now
the toxins have attacked my
central nervous system
yeah you get the tremors though real bad
it's a bad roller coaster right
it's like what's going on with you right
now
it's like everything's tense
yeah i gotta take it away yeah
[Music]
that's what my husband goes through all
the time that's why we don't go to all
the meetings because he's
he's wrecked
our doctor gave us a packet to get our
will together
so
you know
we don't know if he's gonna die or not
i'll get a brand new parts on these
machines
like just fall apart corrode and then
warp these these engine blocks that they
were that they were cutting so it's
corroding their parts but they don't
tell the public hey don't drink this
water did what did they tell the workers
how did they explain this to the workers
they shut off all the drinking fountains
in the plants
they did yeah
yeah they had them all
yeah they had them all off and they had
these water jugs next to them
so you get water from these water jugs
not
you couldn't use the plants water
to drink
from the fountain yeah so they knew so
they knew mr murphy
presented to my office on april of 2017.
we
did a number of different tests to
actually prove that he
had problems with neurotoxicity he did
have seizures of course
his lead levels were found to be in
excess of six times higher than what
they should have been to the point where
he was
dysfunctional and disabled
protests at the city hall are now
relatively regular in flint
it's not so much that local officials
aren't listening but they were stripped
of their powers as flint was put under
an austerity manager whose sole goal was
to save money
general motors engine plant in flint
said we have a problem since the
switchover engine parts are rusting
before we even get it out of the factory
the emergency manager
allowed
general motors
to
change back to the
detroit system yet when the flint city
council voted to return to the detroit
system the emergency manager overruled
that vote capital was protected and
people were poisoned
period
hi everybody we are here
to celebrate the life of shyonda
robertson she's 30 years old today
she's truly missed
we doing what
as a family is supposed to do
we keep her name alive
happy birthday to you
october 31st 2015
my daughter she wasn't feeling good and
they told her she had pneumonia
monday morning
we called 9-1-1 and she was unresponsive
they rushed to the mclaren they was able
to resuscitate her
then she started seizing
she was having anywhere from 100 to like
150 seizures a day
and she was 28 years old
and that's when they found out it was
the legionnaire that opened the
threshold for the season and they
couldn't stop the season because the
legionnaire was so far in their body
we had recently done experiments that
said if a city should ever do what flint
did which is to stop adding corrosion
control to their water
they would have a serious problem with
dangerous bacteria called legionella
so
who's responsible for the deaths
interesting question
we're going to have to collect data
ourselves i kept all my water okay okay
like this crap i kept it all
i mean we didn't drink it when it looked
like that
we would let it run like they they told
us let it run and then boil it and then
this was one of this
is out of my hot water tank
and then like this one's had like slime
in it
there's got to be an explanation for
this this can't be so horrible the
government couldn't possibly be changing
data and this doesn't make sense now
when you're in my world of science and
experiments and conclusions and and
you're still ignoring it
that was scary when i got sick i had to
be in isolation because i had dysentery
and it's so incredibly contagious and
then coming from home and i was afraid
of my house if i wash my hands with
antibacterial soap
what do i rinse my hands with
the medical society of genesee county
put a statement out saying
we recognize that there are certain
populations
pregnant women infants elderly people
people with autoimmune diseases should
drink bottled water but
the state had extended an idea to the
physicians in the plant
that perhaps physicians could write
prescriptions to people who need bottled
water and then and then with a
prescription somebody could go to one of
these pods and get their pot of water
and the doctors found it ridiculous and
said absolutely not and at this meeting
that i was at the uh representatives of
the state were so incredibly
disappointed with the physicians who
weren't willing to work out an
arrangement because you know there's so
many people who are just taking this
bottle of water and maybe they don't
really actually deserve it
sometimes it'll smell like poop
or it would smell super chlorine-y
people were taking their water
down to the city council meetings but
the thing is is those city council
meetings nobody had any power
so now we pay like the highest rates in
the country for water
that now we can't use and it's poison
people and just kill people
some people like their water bills are
more than their mortgage
they're paying two to three hundred
dollars a month just in the water in
michigan if you don't have running water
your home could be condemned they can
remove your children put them in foster
care
you're listening to stateside i'm
cynthia canty
it has been nearly two years now since
the first indictments were handed down
in the state's investigation into the
flint water crisis 15 current and former
state and city government officials were
charged and we're on the record with
people versus nicholas
lyon
i find this behavior over this time
period corrupt based upon misconduct in
office for probable cost standards
therefore
these
four
charges will be bound over to circuit
court for further proceedings again
involuntary manslaughter count one
involuntary manslaughter count two
misconduct in office count three as well
as the willful neglect of duty of office
and count four
so does this mean flint residents will
get justice it's quite challenging in a
situation like this
to prove cases against higher and higher
up officials
frankly it's not unlike organized crime
in organized crime you're typically able
to catch the low-level people red-handed
they're the ones who are doing the dirty
work
the higher-ups are usually by design
insulated
from the illegal actions that occur on
the ground government and government
decisions often result
in people being polluted
poisoned
losing the quality of their life and
losing their life itself
in a very harsh way
that's how our environmental law system
works
i've come back to see janine because
she's actually trying to get uranium
banned in this county and she's
petitioning the town hall here i'm
pretty excited because she could really
make a difference here
now we know new mexico state is looking
to reopen uranium mining because they
are currently considering legislation to
classify nuclear energy as renewable
energy source and we know that we will
again be ground zero for the type of
uranium operations that will be needed
to support that type of industry
we implore you to
at least reconsider the moratorium i've
lived in new mexico all of my life i
went to school at los alamos high school
i lived down in alamogordo i used to
play volleyball out at white sands
missile range
and i'm full of tumors
we live between two uranium mines and
just
like half a mile away from a uranium
mill our younger generation we're
raising them up
and what are we teaching them to destroy
the land to destroy this world i feel
like you are
we're
voted in
to represent us and to protect us and if
we contaminate the water
we're kind of done for
i am for the moratorium and we've had
people here from the state land office
threatening
to sue us if we passed a moratorium
unfortunately
where hands are tied
those are some really strong testimonies
but i can't believe that the local
officials say they don't have any power
to do anything about it just like in
flint i mean here in the southwest they
don't have an emergency manager to
officially take away local authorities
powers but it seems like business
interests take priority again
one of the things we recommended was
that all the people who lived along the
parco river who may have been exposed to
the tailing spill in 79
that there should be a registry set up
and so to examine their health over time
we were
laughed at we were ridiculed
there was this
constant
voice